greetings everyone this is rob sanders
from simply learn happy new year and
today we're going to talk about digital
marketing skills
so digital marketing
allows business owners regardless of the
business non-profit for-profit large or
small
national local international
to really expand their business
allows them to personalize their content
they could save money and most
importantly they can measure the results
and so that's what we're going to focus
on today we talk about digital marketing
skills focusing on measuring those
results
search engine marketing
also known as
paid search sponsored search google ads
bing ads pay-per-click cost per click a
lot of acronyms a lot of ways to
describe it at the end of the day search
engine marketing
means that hey you as an advertiser have
the ability
and have the opportunity to rank at the
very top of the google search results
now it's different than seo because
you're actually paying for the placement
and so to be found at the top of the
search engine results
as a paid placement or sponsored ad
means that if somebody clicks on your ad
you're going to pay google x amount okay
so
unlike seo sem is very fast moving
and so
when we talk about fast moving we mean
that you're collecting a lot of data
very quickly so sticking with the theme
of what skills should i have for search
engine marketing well
if you're going to collect data then
that means you need to measure the
results of that data
and so sticking with our theme of
measuring results you need to understand
first and foremost what all the
different metrics mean
related to sentry engine marketing okay
so i'm just gonna
rattle off if you will a few of the
metrics but the commonality here is
yes you can learn what those metrics
mean but
you have to act on those metrics
so
one of the the main metrics involved
with search engine marketing is
impressions
so impression is just basically how many
people have seen your ad okay so if your
ad shows up on the search results page
regardless of whether somebody clicks on
it or not
you're gonna get an impression okay so
if you're getting a lot of impressions
that means a lot of people have seen
your ad
what's a lot of impressions well it's
subjective okay so
it could be a thousand impressions or
ten thousand impressions at the end of
the day that's how many people have seen
your ad
now more importantly
you have another metric called clicks
clicks means how many people actually
saw your ad and then clicked on your app
okay so if you have 100 people that have
seen your ad in one person who clicked
on your ad
then you have a click through rate of
one percent
now when it comes to google ads and
search engine marketing in general you
want to have a high click-through rate
especially on google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay it's a quality score simply a
number between one and ten that's
assigned to each keyword okay
so what impacts quality score
click-through rate is one of the factors
that impact quality score
so if you have
200 or 300 or 500 or a thousand
impressions and very little clicks that
means your click-through rate is going
to be low and if your click-through rate
is going to be low then your quality
score is going to be low
and
in order to pay less to google you need
to make sure that your quality score is
good so you need to understand the
factors involve a quality score you need
to understand impressions clicks
click-through rate because if you don't
have a good click-through rate
then how do you improve that so it's
about
measuring the results and acting upon
the results those are the skills
involved with search engine marketing
and that's just on the click side you've
got the conversion side of the house
so you need to be able to understand
how to get conversions
and
how to maintain a high conversion rate
so for example if you have 100 clicks
and only one conversion
that is a one percent conversion rate
okay fair enough
but what are you paying per conversion
what's the cost per conversion
okay
and if that number is high like say 20
and you're only selling a product that's
say ten dollars
well then you got a problem
and so
there's a lot of different metrics
involved with search engine marketing
you're collecting this data very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see so that's the skill
set really involves search engine
marketing
if you're getting the data
if it's a low click-through rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion
or very low impressions you need to be
able to understand
how to react to what you're seeing and
what your data you're collecting
that to me is the primary skill bottom
line with search engine marketing and
there are other skill sets involved
don't get me wrong i mean it's nice to
be able to write copy
because with search engine marketing
typically the ads have very few
characters involved so you need to be
able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so
writing copy
being able to understand your target
audience
those are all things involved with
managing search engine marketing but
really the key component here is again
measuring the results paid marketing is
one of the easiest and quickest ways to
help customers discover your brand and
offerings with paid marketing you can
purchase advertising that allows you to
target an audience instead of waiting
for them to find you organically paid
advertising is measurable and is easier
than seo in this video we will learn how
someone can make use of platforms such
as google facebook youtube and instagram
for advertising and growing their
business so let's begin with
understanding how marketing works
through google ads youtube ads facebook
ads and instagram ads when you're
setting up your brand and you need to
make sure it reaches the right audience
and provide the best results there's
really only one place to turn to it's
one of the largest online advertising
platforms really in the world and that's
on google and so today we're going to
talk about how to advertise on google so
thank you for joining my name is rob
sanders i'm with simply learn and we're
going to talk about all things google
when it comes to advertising so thanks
for joining and let's get right to it
and talk about google ads and its effect
with advertising so we're going to start
out with what are google ads well google
ads used to be called google adwords and
it's been around a good while almost 20
years now so really google has grown at
a really rapid pace it's become one of
google's main sources of revenue uh you
could say probably in the 90 percentile
of its revenue comes from google ads and
when we say google ads we mean people
who pay for advertising on google.com so
google ads really what it does is it
provides services that fall under the
category of ppc
which stands for pay-per-click you may
also may hear google ads or ppc referred
to as cost per click or cpc or sponsored
search really what it comes down to it's
a model so when you advertise on
google.com and somebody clicks on your
ad basically you're paying google for
the click okay so it's just really a
business model where an advertiser pays
google to have their advertisement on
google.com but they only pay google when
they get the click so that's really in a
nutshell how it works for advertisers if
i want to advertise my business i can go
to google ads and say google place my ad
on google.com and then my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as i pay google a
fee so google ads is just an online
advertising platform developed by google
with which advertisers can pay to
display ads they can offer up their
services there's video involved there's
obviously mobile's involved so you got
all the necessary devices and platforms
available in google's ecosystem so for
example if i go to google search even if
i type in you know what is google ads
here i could see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from youtube you
got a knowledge graph here you got
feature snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that i typed in what are
google ads really to sponsor search or
pay-per-click ads appeared now if i
happen to click on any one of these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website they're gonna pay google a
specific cost per click so that's how it
looks on google.com it really depends on
your query and what ads show up but the
great thing about your google ads is
they make it known for the user who's
doing the search query what the ad is so
here i can easily pick out what's an ad
a sponsored search or pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on google.com i'm gonna be
able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have that little ad box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have a little ad box you know it's a
paid search ad now why do we want to
advertise on google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so
what i mean by that is you know search
is really a great place to advertise
because you're meeting the consumer
halfway meaning somebody's typing
something in and your ad is there to
help them find what they're looking for
so google ads advertises your product or
service to the relevant audience to
ensure the users perform the action
required of them so it's really a great
way to get quality audience to your
website because if somebody types in
something and you happen to offer what
they're looking for basically your ad is
going to show up somebody clicks on it
you pay google for the click and you get
quality traffic in return so the other
great benefit to being on google ads is
increases brand awareness so it's a
great way to get your product and brand
out there google has a vast network uh
also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search network
itself the search engine itself millions
of people use it every day fact here in
the united states it's been said or
studied that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the united
states so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of mind
awareness another benefit to being on
google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use google's display
network or we can run remarketing lists
for search as right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or subscribing to a newsletter
or visiting a certain page okay so if
somebody doesn't do what we want them to
do it's okay
maybe they're ready to commit to our
product or service and that's why google
offers up retargeting so it allows us to
reach that audience a second time so
they're going to be familiar with their
product they're going to be familiar
their website because they've been there
and so we can offer up a very unique
specific ad to that audience so that's a
really good benefit to being on google
ads so some other benefits here
increased intelligence so you know we
can certainly get data about who is
coming to our audience so we can look at
what device what you know browser etc so
we can really gain some information
about who's coming to the website we
could certainly measure our performance
so with google we're paying cost per
click and so based on that model you
know we can certainly measure
what keywords what ads are generating
traffic to the website and how much
we're paying for that okay and if that
traffic turns out to be a lead we can
measure that against that specific
keyword or ad or campaign so we can
certainly measure our performance all
the way down the keyboard level and can
we can measure up against how many
conversions or what we're paying for
those conversions so google ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's lots of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and its
network and another benefit really is
high flexibility so google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
google ads has very flexible options in
terms of advertising and we're going to
talk about some of those as we move
along here today so another big benefit
here and this is what i always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider google
ads because as we shown here in our
example if i go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to
bid on the keyword what are google ads
why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help and
advertising on google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you can bid on it so
it definitely is a good option if you're
not ranking for particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option i always say that you know search
is like a fruit bowl okay you have
apples and oranges in that fruit bowl
well the orange is organic search and
the apple is paid search they're
different approaches but they share the
same fruit bowl the same real estate so
you can really really help yourself by
using google ads to complement what
you're doing organically so if you're
not ranked organically for keyword you
can certainly use google ads if you are
ranked for specific keywords and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use google ads to help you leverage the
amount of clicks you get from that ad so
it's okay to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here we can see wordstream.com has a
paid ad and here we can see just two
spots below organically they're showing
up with an organic listing so you could
certainly be in both positions to try
and maximize your clicks so it's
definitely a good strategy to run with
google ads on top of everything we
mentioned in terms of measurement
flexibility google ads does offer up a
really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that again search
is really the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway based on
what they're looking for and when i say
halfway meaning your ad is going to
appear for somebody who is looking for
something whether that be food a cafe a
plumber a doctor
or directions search is there to serve
that that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be tv or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps or also known as organic
search but the great thing is google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now and talk about the
various formats in google ads on google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on google search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so jbl headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we call
ad extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something on your website and so
the purpose of the extension is to help
get the click so the reason why you're
running google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad i'll help you get
that click yes you're gonna pay google
for the click but that's the whole
purpose is to generate the click from
search because remember search is there
to respond to somebody's need or query
and so if you get the click on your ad
chances are it's going to be a highly
relevant visitor to your website so
google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text ad on google for google.com so
google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are responsive they adjust
their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let google do the
heavy lifting why not let google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows google to
you know show the particular ad that's
most relevant to that user so it's a
really a great option when you're
advertising on google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on facebook first
says google you have multiple multiple
sizes that you can choose from in terms
of running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so google owns youtube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on youtube so they could
be standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say pre-roll meaning people are going to
look at your ad before actually watching
the actual video they went to youtube
for so you have a lot of different
options with video advertisements on
youtube so the other ad format you have
on google are shopping ads and shopping
ads are really a great way to get your
product in front of the right user so
somebody's looking for shoes or running
shoes it's an opportunity for you to run
shopping ads so you could put that
particular shoe with a description with
the price with your brand name in front
of that user and so with a cost per
click model if a user clicks on your
shopping ad then chances are they're
probably going to convert because they
could see the product they could see the
price they could see the product name
they can see the brand and so it's an
opportunity for you to really drive high
quality traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if i go to google search and i
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here i could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names i could see the
price point if i hover over it i can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews
return policy so if i actually click on
this ad chances are i'm going to buy it
otherwise why would i click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on google search by certainly
really giving google access to your
product inventory connecting in some
reviews connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up google shopping ads within google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also appears under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if i'm on google search you know i can
go to shopping or i can go to images and
i'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and i will certainly see
those under shopping as well so
shopping ads allow you to really
showcase your products on google search
to those looking for that particular
product so it's really a great option
with google you also have call ads so
when we say call ads really call only
ads are great for mobile so when you run
advertisements on google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number if they click on your number
they're actually going to call your
business and google can track that they
can track how many people click on your
number and even turn that into a
conversion for you so if you have a
phone number associated with your
business it's wise to go ahead and set
up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the app because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
google showing your ads i showed you an
example of google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
google search network so google search
network really allows you to advertise
on google search so with google search
if i go back to google search and i go
to all i typed in running shoes okay
here i can see shopping ads here i can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show at the top and if you're not
at the top then google will place you at
the bottom so really depends on the
keyword that somebody's querying in
google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what google does if i didn't have any
shopping ads here google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and i would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
gonna advertise on google with a text ad
you want to make sure you're always at
the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
google ads is affiliated with so
the first is google search okay so let's
focus on google search and so basically
when we say google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device as well so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above
some featured snippets and the organic
search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again i've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if i scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again i can see the
logo ad here okay so i can see simply
learn using three headlines i can see
simply learn using their two description
lines here and i could see simply learn
using some other extensions with the ad
now all of this is geared towards
getting the click so when you're on
google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on google search if you're
on google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if i change my search query and
typed in coffee in san francisco my
search results are going to be
completely different i'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to google my business not google ads
okay so this is completely different so
don't don't mix this up with running ads
on google search so google my business
is tied to local listings or google maps
and again with desktop which is what i'm
showing you the search result on you're
going to see likely google local
listings above organic results okay and
if i go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing i'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to trump any other type of
results on google search if you can be
in positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called google search partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign in google ads you have the
option to choose google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
google search partners sites and so some
of their search partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with google that's allowing
google to
show ads on their site so the sites can
range anywhere between youtube to amazon
to new york times let's take a look at
an example it could even be another
search engine so if i go to say ask.com
and type in classes on digital marketing
it's a completely different search
engine but i can see the same ad for
simply learn so i can see same i could
see a different headline here actually
but i could see the description and i
could see some site link extensions and
so
notice the ad is still at the top in
this case it's in position one
and i can see
multiple companies running
advertisements why because they could
see ad next to it and i could see those
over
over organic listings so these are
google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be on other partner sites
that google or other sites that google
has partnered up with so you have
options outside of google search and
that option is the display network so
display network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of google
search and if you're going to advertise
on google's display network you have
more ad formats available to you
including image and including a video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific
website if you choose to advertise on
the new yorktimes.com or webmd or
marriott.com you could certainly do that
okay you just need to tell google hey
this is the site i want to advertise on
so some of the advantages of being on
the display network so if you don't want
to advertise on google search okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on google's
display network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because the way the display network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so retargeting as
we said earlier is really reaching out
to people who have already been to your
website and didn't perform a particular
function that you wanted them to perform
meaning somebody came to your website
from paid search on google.com and they
went to page a and then they left so you
really wanted them to go to page b add a
product to a shopping cart and check out
and purchase that product however if
they didn't do that you could certainly
run ads knowing that they've been to
page a and page b and you can offer up
that specific ad to that person who's
been to your website and so that's what
retargeting really is all about and you
can retarget on google's display network
so remarketing your product to people
who previously visited your your website
or even your app allows you to really
get your ad in front of a qualified
audience and so you could take advantage
of analytics so google's ads has all the
information you need so let's actually
take a look at some of these options in
google ads for the display network so if
i actually go to google ads and i
actually go to display campaigns i can
see i have a lot of different options
available to me so if i click on
keywords for example okay i can choose
keywords for my display campaign so what
google does if you choose keywords
basically what they're doing is they're
going to contextually place your ad
based on the keyword okay so that's an
option for you if you're not sure what
websites to be on with the display
network you can certainly just add
keywords and based on those keywords
google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the splake network
you can say hey google i only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the display
network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if i just choose a particular ad
group now i have specific topics that i
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics i can get really specific so if i
go under science i can see subcategories
under the topic science i can see
chemistry and physics and scientific
institutions and equipment so i can
really pick and choose specific topics
where i want my ads to be shown as i
mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let google know okay you can
also advertise on gmail you can also
advertise on youtube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
that one of the best options for
advertising on the display network
because when you tell google you have a
specific audience you want to target and
that audience could be somebody who went
to a specific page or somebody who went
to your website and didn't convert you
can associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
retarget them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in google ads so when i actually pick
and choose how i want to target i can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or demographics for example if
i go back to demographics i have all
this data that google's collected on my
advertising so i can see for example by
age range based on my campaign how many
clicks how many impressions impressions
are how many times my ads been seen
click-through rate meaning the rate at
which people see my ad and are clicking
on my ad how much i'm paying per click
cpc is cost per click total cost and
conversions how many conversions am i
getting so i could see all this data
available to me in google ads so it's a
very powerful platform for measuring
performance okay let's talk about how
you can create a google ad okay so
first thing you want to do is you want
to set up your campaign and you want to
align and go with that campaign just
like we talked with ads related to
facebook you always want to align a goal
with your campaign just like we talked
about there we want to do the same thing
here on google so we have a number of
different options at our disposal so
when you run a campaign why are you
running the campaign so if you're in
just to drive traffic or you're trying
to generate brand awareness okay great
you can still set up that campaign
you're just going to choose the display
network okay the display network allows
you to get your ad out there on millions
of websites so that people can actually
see what your brand product or service
is all about now if you're into direct
response meaning you're in it for sales
and leads then you probably want to
choose potentially google search
partners as a network okay not display
but google search and the partner sites
okay on google search so by choosing
google search as your network it's
director response so somebody's typing
in a keyword query and you're responding
so that's the whole idea behind google
search is we want to meet somebody
halfway we want to be able to offer up
the product or service they're looking
for so if sales and leads are what your
campaign goal is all about then you want
to go search network with the option to
choose
google search partners okay again if
you're into you know driving brand
awareness or product and brand
consideration then maybe you should
choose the display network the bottom
line is you need to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign that's the very
most important very first step and most
important step is to figure out
what the goal is of the campaign and
once you've decided that then it's on to
setting up the campaign and in google
you're always going to have at least one
ad group and what makes up an ad group
keywords and ads so ideally when you set
up a campaign on google search network
you're going to choose keywords and
those keywords should be tightly knitted
or tightly themed or in other words be
all relevant to one another in an ad
group so that's what an ad group is
keywords that are relevant to one
another okay in that ad group you're
also going to have an ad so when you
choose your keywords you're going to
write an ad for those keywords so step 3
is after you set up the ad group and
choose your keywords you're going to
create an ad so let's take a look at how
that looks in google ads so if i go to
google ads i can see i already have an
account set up i have a couple campaigns
so let's just say i have this campaign
set up here i'm just going to call it
industrial campaign okay and if i choose
industrial campaign okay i'm going to
then be asked to set up an ad group now
if i set up an ad group already in that
ad group should be keywords and ads okay
so remember when you set up an ad group
you want to choose your keywords first
painless keywords should be all related
to one another so for example i could
see an ad group here called fig
concentrate well if i click on this ad
group and i look at the keywords they
should all be related to fake
concentrate so here we go we can see a
few key words in this ad group in fact i
have 10 of them all related to fig
concentrate so it's very very important
from a quality score perspective if you
remember when we're talking about
quality score quality score is based on
landing page experience expected click
through and the add relevancy to the
keyword so if you can choose a ad group
and have all your keywords related to
one another like i do here with fig
concentrate then it's easier to write an
ad okay so here i have 10 keywords all
related to fig concentrate so now if i
go to ads and extensions in the google
ads platform we can see here i already
have a couple of ads going okay so
ideally if i wanted to i can run more
than just two ads as a best practice as
a best practice you want to have at
least two ads why because these two ads
are going to be served up against each
other and ideally the whole idea of
running more than one ad is what google
can do is start serving up the ad that
is performing better in terms of
click-through rate or in terms of
conversions okay so it doesn't hurt to
even add one or two more ads so here i'm
going to go ahead and add one more ad
here okay so if i click on that plus
button i have a bunch of options here
i'm going to go ahead and choose text ad
because i'm running this campaign on the
search network and my goal is to get
sales not lead sales so i want sales i
want somebody to click on my ad go to my
website and purchase some fake
concentrate so that's my goal and so if
i'm on the search network i can only
have text ads so i'm going to choose
text at and once i choose text ad then i
have the option now to go through and
create a new ad okay so what google
actually does is they populate the ad
from previous ads and so this gives me
an opportunity to tweak one of the ads i
already have in place so here you can
see i have a final url and that's the
url that the traffic is going to go to
when they click on your ad okay so if
somebody clicks on the ad that's the
page they're going to go to call that
the final url now i have an option to
create
up to three headlines so here i can see
headline one up to 30 characters i have
my brand name headline two i have
something related to the keyword i'm
bidding on so what am i talking about
fake concentrate okay again up to 30
characters now that includes spaces so
if you happen to go over 30 characters
your ads not gonna get approved so here
you can see 32 over 30. i'm two
characters over
if i just get rid of that the ad is okay
so you gotta be careful to stay within
the boundaries of the character limits
including spaces so here i got headline
two is fig concentrate now i'm gonna
write headline three this is new so this
is recently implemented by google and i
highly recommend that all the fields
available to you you use because the
more information you can put in an ad
the better it is for not only your ad
but for the end user because if
somebody's searching and looking for
fake concentrate and you provide them as
with as much information as possible
then the chances of them clicking on
your ad are going to be greater and
that's what we want if we're going to
advertise we want to advertise so that
people can see our ad and click on our
ad that's the whole point isn't it to
get people to click on our ad because
they're looking for something that we're
offering in this example fit concentrate
so
here i have headline three i'm gonna go
ahead and put something in a headline
three maybe a promotion let's just say
i'm offering up twenty percent so i can
say up to twenty percent off through
april and may now you see i'm running
into character count so i'm just gonna
go ahead and keep it at april so up to
20 off through april now i can create
another ad and maybe change the headline
to say up to 20 off through may so you
want to take advantage of all three
headlines now notice when i added the
headline here i can see a preview of it
on mobile and i can see a preview of it
on desktop now underneath that i have
what they call the display path so what
google does is they take your domain in
this case
valleyfig.com and you can basically
customize that domain with what they
call a path so you have path one path
two and the whole point of this is for
you to
customize it based on the keywords you
were bidding on so if i'm bidding on
fake concentrate i'm going to put fake
concentrate in here now remember when
somebody actually clicks on my ad
they're not going to go to valleyfig.com
figs concentrate they're going to go to
the url up here under final url so you
want to make sure you put a path in here
ideally what i would do is put in
something related to the keyword i'm
bidding on in this case fig concentrate
now i have an opportunity to add a new
description a second description this is
new and i have up to 90 characters so i
can go ahead and add some content so
remember with description 2 i have up to
90 characters so i'm just going to go
ahead and borrow some copy from the
website if i'm not actually sure what to
write and
so here you can see thick concentrate is
a natural product containing no
preservatives or additives so that's my
second description so now i can go ahead
and
save and create extensions so i'm just
going to go ahead and push the button
save and create extensions and when i do
that i'm going to be prompted to go
ahead and create some ad extensions and
so add extensions allow me to add in
links site links underneath the ad just
like you see here so when you've added
your site link extensions and other
extensions you save it you'll be able to
see your new ad here here we can see the
ad we created okay notice it's got the
three headlines now this has got the two
descriptions and if i want to edit i can
just click edit add and go ahead and
edit it if i don't want to edit it then
i don't have to i can always go back so
you can always edit it ad after it's
been created okay if not no big deal
notice when you actually create your ad
in some cases google is going to review
it to make sure it fits within google's
guidelines and policies uh but once it's
approved you'll see it under uh you'll
see approved under the status column and
that's pretty much how you would go
ahead and create a text app okay so when
it does get approved it's going to be in
the rotation with the other two ads and
so what google's going to do is serve up
each ad equally and then eventually the
ad that is performing best will get
served up more and that way you're
putting your best ad always in front of
the user who's looking for the product
and service you're offering so now let's
talk about the metrics so associated
with these keywords these ads these ad
groups and campaigns so there are a lot
of metrics
in google ads a lot of metrics and we're
not even going to cover most of these
metrics we're just going to cover what i
deem the most common the most important
metrics to get you going so if you find
yourself advertising whether that be on
google search network or google's
display network you're gonna have some
common metrics and here are the metrics
that we're gonna focus on today so you
have impressions cost clicks average cpc
conversions cost per conversion ctr or
click-through rate and quality score so
let's go through these metrics here and
talk about what they are so impressions
really it's the number of times your ads
been shown on that particular network
whether it's google search or display
and so an impression is just how many
times somebody actually seen your ad
okay whether they actually physically
seen it or not if your ad is showing up
on that network then an impression is
gonna get counted so here if we're
looking at ads we can see we have over a
period of time certain amount of
impressions okay so that's how many
times this particular ad has been shown
so this particular ad here the first one
at the top has been shown
557 times over this period of time which
is year to date okay so that's an
impression how many times your ads been
shown so if we talk about cost cost
refers to the amount of money we've
spent so any time your ad gets clicked
you're going to pay google x amount so
if i go back to google ads i can see
what my total cost is and not only can i
see what my total cost is i can see what
my average cost per click is and so
there's a lot of factors that go into
what you actually pay and some of these
factors are who else is advertising
where you're advertising what network
you're advertising on what time of day
what particular keyword and so there's a
lot of factors and so here i can see on
average year to date i've spent a dollar
eighty per click on this particular ad
for a total of thirty 32.33
so i can really see how much i've
actually spent and so clicks is just
refers to how many times somebody
clicked on your ad so if your ads been
shown you need an impression and when
somebody sees your ad they're going to
click on your ad so the whole idea is to
get the click remember you want to be in
positions one through three so i want to
make sure that my average position is
between one and three and so if you're
looking in google ads at metrics and you
don't see average position well you can
always add that as a column so if i
click on columns here and then i go to
competitive metrics and i click on
average position and i'm going to move
average position all the way to the top
here so if i click move average position
all the way at the top i'm going to be
able to see what my average position is
over that particular period of time so
here i can see i'm in positions one
through three and that's where you want
to be you want to be in positions one
through three so if you're in positions
one through three that means you're at
the top if you're on google search or
that means you're in a problem position
on the display network so if your ad is
shown meaning this gets an impression
then likely somebody's going to click on
that ad and somebody clicks on that ad
it's going to generate a click which in
turn is going to generate cost and so
ideally what you want to do is you want
to measure the rate at which people
click on your ad based on how many times
it was shown so here i can see 28 clicks
over
3549 impressions that's a 0.79 percent
click-through rate so ideally the higher
the click-through rate the better the at
and the higher the clicker rate the
chances are you're going to get more
traffic to your site so we want to be
able to measure clicks and we want to be
able to measure click-through rate and
we also want to measure cost per click
which is really the total cost divided
by the number of clicks so if i go back
to google ads here i can see you know
17.57
over 28 clicks that averages out to
about 63 cents per click so that's how i
get cost per click now your cost per
click is going to vary a little bit okay
so it's going to vary based on keyword
it's going to be based on where you're
advertising what position etc so there's
a lot of factors involved with cost per
click but that's how you would actually
calculate it but google ads actually
does the calculation for you for
collector rate and cost per click but in
case you want to know you can always
divide clicks into cost okay so
conversions probably one of the most
important metrics you're going to use in
google ads because you're paying google
and if you're paying google for
advertising you want to make sure you're
getting return on your investment so
conversions are added when a user clicks
on your ad and performs an action that
you've defined such as purchasing
something downloading something viewing
something signing up for a newsletter
etc so you want to make sure that if
you're in google ads that you're
measuring conversions and so you simply
want to go to tools so if you go to
tools and then click on conversions you
want to make sure that you're running
conversions ideally what you want to do
is you want to run conversions from
google analytics but you can certainly
set up conversions within google ads as
well notice i also have call from ads as
set up as a conversion so you have an
opportunity in google ads to add a
number of different conversions and the
more conversions you add really the
better off you are because you want to
measure up all your campaigns against
conversions if i go back to campaigns i
want to be able to see what campaigns
are driving conversions and if i can
measure that and i have a campaign
that's really driving conversions that
i'm going to continue to advertise on
google okay so here over this particular
period of time i can see one campaign
has driven nine conversions at 128.67
cost per conversion and so how do i get
cost per conversion well i get my total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then i could see my
conversion rate the rate at which people
convert so really if i have 241 clicks
and nine conversions that's 9 divided by
241 that's 3.77
conversion rate so i can measure
conversion rate cost per conversion and
conversion just by setting up
conversions in google ads and so ideally
if you're going to pay google for
advertising you want to be able to
measure return on investment via
conversions so again see cost per
conversion is just really the the total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then click the rate
again just as a reminder the total
clicks divided by the total number of
impressions and then one other metric
we're going to talk about here today is
quality scores so quality score is
really google's way of measuring how
well
your keywords are
are compared to the ad associated with
it the expected click-through rate and
the landing page so quality score is the
backbone of google ads so if i go back
to google ads and i click on keywords
quality score is something you want to
measure and if you don't have it in your
columns you could certainly just click
on columns and add it and so here i can
see my quality score and quantity score
is a measurement between 1 and 10. and
so if you have a good quality score
google is going to score you higher
because your keyword is relevant to your
ad it's relevant to the landing page and
you have a good expected click-through
rate if you don't have a good quality
score google's gonna let you know why
you don't have a good quality score so
again your three categories that make up
quality score are landing page
experience which means really google
looking at the landing page you're
sending people to and they're seeing if
the page loads well fast does it have
ads does that have good content is it
good landing page will the end user have
a good experience they also look at the
ad relevance okay is the ad relevant to
the keyword and they'll also look at the
expected click-through rate okay so
based on other advertisers and their
click-through rate are you achieving the
same click-through rate and so those
three factors make up quality score
quality score is a metric assigned to
keywords so if you don't have a good
quality score you need to fix it because
the repercussion is you're going to have
to pay more so having a good quality
score likely means you're going to pay
less per click so you want to make sure
that if you bid on a keyword that the
keyword goes to a relevant landing page
the ad itself is relevant and you're
getting a good click-through rate so
quality score is the backbone of google
ads and how it works so you want to make
sure you have a good quality score so
optimizing your ads so what if you don't
have a good quality score what if you're
not getting conversions well there's
things you can do so remember we want to
make sure that we're adding extensions
whether that be call site link review
app add extensions to your ads because
it's going to increase the click-through
rate so you can also
really hone your ad copy if you're
selling products and you're running a
promotion maybe you want to add in a
little sense of urgency to help people
you know realize hey if this this
promotion's ending maybe i want to click
on the ad and take action okay with
google ads you can always run a b
testing on ads and so what you could do
is run two ads in one ad group and see
what ad is performing best in terms of
click-through rate or conversion rate
and whatever ad is running better you
can always run that ad and then continue
more testing so that way you're always
putting your best forward in terms of
advertising and the ad copy whether that
be text or display you always want to
use call to action you want to get
people to click on your ad when somebody
clicks on your ad it's going to improve
click-through rate click-to-rate
improves quality score so as i mentioned
several times already you want to make
sure your ads are placed at the top
between positions one and three on
google search so you can measure ad
position in google ads and if you're not
rank between one and three you want to
increase your bid
you can also optimize for local search
so local is an ad extension that you can
add to your ad you can also advertise at
a time when your audience is online or
you can advertise on during business
hours only so you can adjust when you
advertise on google ensure some of your
ads you know capitalize on some
particular events that are related to
your industry so you can capitalize on
that okay you can certainly ask google
to accelerate your ads okay or you can
do standard delivery so google can
spread out your clicks and show your ads
throughout the day google search is all
about keywords so you want to be able to
pick and choose the right keywords first
you can also add negative keywords so
if you're bidding on a specific industry
let's just say you have software and you
want somebody to sign up for your
particular piece of software uh but you
don't offer a free trial then maybe you
want to add free as a negative keyword
so if you don't offer anything for free
free should be a negative keyword so if
somebody actually does type in looking
for free software then your ads not
gonna show up so that's the whole idea
behind negative keywords okay you can
use dynamic keyword insertion into your
ads meaning you can ask google hey i
want to dynamically insert a keyword
into my ad that somebody uses to make
your ad more relevant so relevancy
increases click-through rate and
improves quality score so as you can see
there's a lot of things you can do
here's some more things you can use
branded keywords you can use particular
match types in google so let's talk
about match types for a second so you
have different match types if i go back
to google ads here i could see my
keywords that i'm bidding on so
by default if you actually bid on a
keyword it's going to be broad match and
so if i've been on the keyword medical
computer if somebody typed in something
related to medical and included the
keyword medical but not computer then my
ad may show up however i can make an
exact match so somebody can type in
exactly only medical computers so if i
click edit and i can change the match
type for that particular keyword to
exact then that means that somebody that
types in only medical computer my ad is
going to show up i can basically do
phrase match so if somebody types in
looking for something that's going to
help me with medical computers okay
that's a long tail phrase work keyword
query but the keyword medical computer
is in that order so my ad is going to
show up okay so with phrase match your
ad is going to show when somebody types
in that keyword you're bidding on in
that order you also have broad match
modifiers so if you have a plus sign in
front of the keyword then that means
that somebody actually has to use that
keyword in the query in order for your
ad to show up okay so you could change
the match type of any keyword so if
you're using exact or phrase then
chances are you're going to have lower
volume of queries but probably higher
relevancy if you use a broad match then
your ad could show up for any
combination of search queries so you
really want to be careful on the match
type that you choose so keep an eye on
quality score remember google has
quality score between one and ten the
higher quality score the better you are
so really if you have a quality score i
would say anything below four you
probably want to pause the keyword okay
so you can measure quality score at the
keyword level so if i go back to google
ads and i have keywords that are say
three chances are i'm going to have to
pay more for the click and it might not
be worth it so i may want to end up
pausing that keyword and try other
keywords that are more relevant that i
can send traffic to a more relevant
landing page or i can have an ad that's
more relevant to that keyword in order
to help with the quality score okay you
can ensure that your landing pages are
mobile friendly so that's another thing
you want to keep in mind that most
people start their search on mobile so
you certainly want to make sure that
your landing pages are optimized because
if somebody starts to search on mobile
likes your product or service chances
are they're coming back via desktop or
even going into the store most searches
start on mobile so you want to make sure
those pages are optimized and there's
plenty more things you can do to
optimize your ads you want to make sure
you group and organize your keywords
into relevant ad groups why because you
can write relevant ads for those
keywords so if i go back to google ads i
want to make sure if i go to ad groups
that the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to one another so what's my
ad group name well if it's medical pc if
i click on medical pc i want to make
sure the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to medical pc i want to
structure my campaigns and ad groups to
target more ads effectively so you want
to be able to you know organize your
campaigns and ad groups and the rule of
thumb here is you should organize your
campaigns and ad groups based on the
site architecture of your site so the
way your website is laid out in the
navigation is how you should likely
structure your campaigns and ad groups
focus on your budget okay so you want to
put more budget to campaigns that are
converting okay you can use automatic
bidding for ads to maximize results so
meaning that google has what they call
artificial intelligence so google can do
a lot of the bidding and a lot of the
managing for you that's really a great
benefit to running your ads on google so
their machines are learning behavior
from your keywords that you're bidding
on and so ideally when they learn what's
converting they're going to bid more and
try and help you get the conversion for
the keywords that have historically
converted and so ideally you can use
some of the automated bidding features
that google ads has to offer in order to
improve performance
now google is the dominant search engine
of the web customers turn to google when
they want to find information about
products and services that means people
are actively seeking information to show
your ads to active searchers or people
looking for your products and services
you can use google ads which is google's
advertising program
in this lesson you'll learn how google
ads connects your business with
customers so you can reach your
marketing goals
now by the end of this lesson you'll be
able to understand how google ads works
discuss the various targeting methods
and know the primary benefits of using
google ads
that lets you connect your business with
prospective customers
so for instance let's say someone has a
broken pipe in their house and they want
to find a local plumber
they often turn to google to search for
their answers
if you're buying a new house you might
search for real estate or mortgages or
moving companies
all of these are searches that someone
conducts every day
so to reach these searchers you can use
google ads
now google ads is a complex system made
up of multiple networks targeting
options ad formats budget management and
so forth
so we need to take a look at how the
system works to ensure you're targeting
the users who can turn into customers
it starts with picking targeting methods
this could be a user searching for a
keyword in a specific geography on a
specific device and operating systems so
we'll get more into targeting methods as
we go through our lessons so you can
write effective ads for those targeting
methods you set a bid for how much
you're willing to pay if someone clicks
on your ad now when someone does a
search and it matches your targeting
method then your ad can be displayed
so if the user looks your ad and says
yep that's what i'm looking for and the
user clicks on the ad they go to your
site now at that moment is when you pay
for the click
or for any action that can happen from
an ad directly such as calling your
company now once users click in your ads
they go to your site if they take an
action such as calling your company or
buying a product or filling out a form
or just watching a video then you can
measure those actions now this lets you
see your data for each targeting method
keyword and add data to understand how
each is performing now we'll define this
information as we go through our lessons
so you know what to look for to make
data-driven decisions
then from those data-driven decisions
you can refine your targeting methods
test different ads and set appropriate
bids based upon how each click or
interaction is worth to your business
let's say that you're a plumbing company
and you're only in houston texas so you
could target only houston texas with
keywords such as broken pipes remodeling
kitchen and other services that you
conduct then for each of those keywords
you write an ad and set a bid if someone
is searching from within houston
for kitchen remodeling they could see
your ad so if they were searching from
austin or california or seattle and
they're not in your targeting method
they can't see your ad so it's important
to think about
where are your customers how are they
searching
and then make sure your ads are
compelling
then you can turn those searchers into
your next customers
now the first network is known as search
this is when someone inputs a keyword or
a search query into a search engine and
then sees results there's more than 167
billion searches a month
now then there's another network that
google also supports known as the
display network these are non-search
places that can show ads so google
display network is made up of more than
three million websites and apps that
encompass more than one trillion
impressions a month now these ad
placements could be apps in your phone
or a newspaper publisher site
with so many possible ad displays your
targeting methods help narrow down
when your ad is displayed so you can
ensure only those who you want to see
your ad
will see your ad
the three primary targeting methods to
think about initially are location time
of day or day of the week and device the
location is where our ads are going to
be displayed this could be every country
in the world it could be a single state
it could be 10 states it could be a
radius around your business or your pin
code you have a lot of control and
options over location targeting next we
have time of day and this could be time
of day or even just day of the week so
let's say you have a call center that's
only open from nine to five monday to
friday then you could run your ads only
during those times nine to five monday
to friday now most companies run their
ads all the time but you can't adjust
when they do run there are other
considerations such as you're a small
business where you really only answer
your phone from eight to four so you
could only run your ads during that time
now if you're a restaurant you might
want to run your ads later in the
evening to take reservations you can
also choose the device and operating
systems where you want your ads to run
such as mobile devices tablets computers
or all three so for example if you're a
pizza delivery place most pizza orders
are now on mobile devices so while you
may be on all devices mobile is your
primary one then you pick your location
based upon your delivery area and then
finally you choose the time of day for
when your business is open and actively
delivering pizzas
now if you're a large sas company and
you're international your locations
might be worldwide so we want to think
about breaking down our ads and keywords
by languages or regions so we'll get
more into how these breakdowns occur in
the account but a location could be
worldwide our time of day is 24 7 and
our devices are just all devices so you
have a lot of control of your targeting
methods and how people can see your ads
both when and where
keyword is an object you put into your
google ads account now a search term or
search query is what a user types into a
search engine to see results so when
this search term matches your keyword
then your ad can be displayed so if
you're a modeling company and you do
kitchens and bathrooms and room
additions but maybe you don't do
basements you could pick kitchen
modeling keywords and bathroom modeling
keywords but ignore basement keywords
because you don't do that type of
remodeling work now you can also choose
demographics such as age gender and
income level if you're a high-end art
dealer you might only sell to the top 30
percent of income levels if you're
selling female-only clothing then you
could target just females now in
addition we can do things like
behavioral targeting which is based upon
how people use our websites this is
sometimes known as remarketing if
someone came to your site and they added
items to a shopping cart but they didn't
check out we know they're almost ready
to buy
therefore you could target those users
differently than someone who's never
been to your website let's say a user
searches for accounting services on
google in maryland in the u.s anytime
during the week they could see an ad for
a local maryland accountant let's say
you're on a call center for mortgage
leads and you're only open on the
weekdays then you can run your ad for
the entire country only during monday to
friday during the hours your call center
is open and only show an ad if someone
searches for mortgage rates mortgage
quotes and so forth
so as we think about our targeting it's
where our customers are located
what they are looking for the devices
they are on and the types of people we
want to serve ads to
now google ads is an auction based
system
you set a bid based upon what you
believe a click is worth to you and then
google looks at your bid in the
relevancy of your ads and they do this
for all the other advertisers as well
then they order the ads in the search
results were across display properties
based upon both the bid
and the relevancy now this is an
important consideration as useful ads
are as important as your bids in
determining position so we'll get into
this later when we look at organization
now it's not just who bids the most that
will get you into position one is your
ad relevant to the user there's a lot of
ways to make things relevant and we'll
walk through this later
if a user sees your ad you don't pay
anything only if a user clicks on your
ad do you pay the search engine that's
why it's called
pay-per-click advertising
is you only pay when someone clicks on
the ad now you can then measure results
such as acquired customers return on ad
spend revenue and so forth now based
upon the results you're receiving from
google ads you can then refine your ads
or change your bids based upon what
those clicks are worth to you
when we think about
the google ads benefits we often call
them the three r's reach
relevance roi now from a reach
standpoint google search and the display
networks have tremendous reach they can
help you reach your target audience
because your target audience is probably
using google whether it's on search or
display or both so the advertising
system has the reach that encompasses
your potential customers the next think
about relevance this is a big thing in
advertising are you relevant to the
users
right searches are often resistant to
ads that's why if you're watching tv and
a commercial appears you might hit the
fast forward button or switch the
channel when the ad is relevant
users like ads they'll interact with
them if they're useful and they're
relevant so you can target users based
upon many criteria which means your ad
should be relevant to users especially
on search when you pick keywords that
represent your business as someone is
actively searching for that word that
means they're looking for a solution so
when users see relevant ads the more
likely to click and do business with
your company now finally we have roi
known as return on investment as our
third benefit
returner ad spend row os or roi let us
know how profitable a channel is now as
you can measure results from your ad
spend you can make data-driven decisions
based upon how users interact with your
ads
and how they're becoming customers so
google ads has the reach that
encompasses your users
when you make good accounts and you have
good account structure which we'll get
into later videos you can ensure your ad
is relevant to users so they'll click on
the ads
and come to your website so you can turn
them into customers now with analytics
and conversion tracking you can see
exactly how much that person's worth to
you so then you can adjust your reach
and your relevance data to ensure that
your return investment is fantastic from
using google ads as a marketing channel
so google ads accounts have multiple
levels of structure
in order for you to be able to control
how users can view interact with your
ads along with your budget and bid
controls now in this lesson we'll
examine each level of hierarchy so you
can understand how average accounts fit
together and how data flows throughout
your account so by the end of this
lesson you're able to understand account
level settings understand campaign
targeting options and discuss the
purpose of an ad group
so when we look at the overall account
hierarchy it starts where we have an
account then an account can be made of
one or more campaigns then each campaign
can have one or more ad groups and then
finally ad groups are a collection of
ads and keywords so as we look at
accounts campaigns and ad groups each
level has different items you set with
it so we're going to look individually
at each of these items to see how you
can use various settings at each level
now at the account level we have several
options that we can set the first is
account access this is who can log in
and access your data so when you open an
account you'll use a google account the
list doesn't have to be a gmail address
you can make your own email address for
your company a google account and then
use that for login purposes but then you
can give others access to your account
as well from a security standpoint it's
useful just to have one administrator
who gives access levels to other
individuals that way if someone leaves
their company or no longer needs access
to your data you can disable just that
access point instead of using shared
account logins then you'll also choose
your time zone now some items such as
time zone and currency cannot be changed
once you open the account so you pick
your time zone and when you think about
it you it's useful to have your
analytics your server and your marketing
such as your google ads account on the
same time zone now because if you've got
an ads account in pacific time and your
servers on eastern time there's a three
hour period of time a day when your data
doesn't agree with each other so it's
useful to sync servers google ads
account analytics so forth into a single
time zone now you'll also choose your
currency do you want to be billed in
euros or dollars or pounds or canadian
dollars and so forth again currency
can't be changed once you've set up your
account as well and then you have
billing how are you going to pay for the
clicks that you accrue and then you can
connect
other accounts to your google ads
account such as google analytics google
merchant center firebase etc so for
using multiple systems you can connect
them all together at the account level
so they can all use the same data and
then you have notification settings how
do you want to be notified of
suggestions or disapproved ads and so
forth in some preferences like display
language number formats etc so that when
you open an account the two most
important options really to think about
though are time zone and currency they
can't be changed you can change your
billing later on or you can change who
has account access some preferences but
time zone and currency are set once your
account is open
let's look at the campaign settings you
have an account an account can be made
up of one or more campaigns so a
campaign setting is where you're going
to tell google ads how to show the ads
and keywords within that campaign so
first we have the network do you want to
be on search network display network or
potentially both and when you're first
starting search is the best place to
start because users are actively looking
for solutions so you could have one
campaign that searched and another
campaign that is displayed now we choose
our devices at the campaign level as
well so we might be on all devices we
could be on just mobile devices or just
computers or just tablets if we want to
run our ads at certain times of day or
day of the week we also set those and
the campaign settings so if you only
want your ads to run monday to friday
you can choose those options at the
campaign level now is say you want your
brand terms to run all the time and then
you have other keywords you only want to
run monday to friday then you can use
two campaigns campaigns can have
different settings from each other so
you could have one campaign for your
legion keywords that runs monday to
friday clicks go to a call center you
can maybe have another campaign that's
brand terms that runs all seven days of
the week and they're in another campaign
so that way you can segment out which
items run when now locations are also
set up at the campaign setting so if
you're a multi-location business you've
got one location in houston another in
seattle another in new york and you only
want to run ads in those geographies you
could either put one campaign together
and target all through those locations
single campaign now all those locations
would use the same ads and keywords or
you can make a campaign for each
location
if you make a campaign by location then
any other settings such as time a day or
budgets which use campaign settings can
be customized for each location your bid
method is also a campaign setting so
with bid methods at a high level there's
two types one's manual where you set the
bid yourself and another is automated
where you're setting a goal for the
system and the system is bidding on your
behalf and then you have budget how much
you're willing to spend on a daily basis
so if you have one location and you want
to spend 100 a day and then you have
another location where you want to spend
500 a day that would be two different
campaigns so you can have different
budgets for each of the campaigns
so when you want a campaign level
setting to be different for some reason
a set of keywords location or something
else that's one of the reasons to make a
different campaign so if you want
certain ads to run only in certain
locations only certain times a day if
you have budgets by product line you use
different campaigns to control those
items so when you think about budget
management if you want a different
budget by product line you make each
product line its own campaign so when we
think about search here's a couple
examples of how we might set up
campaigns might have one campaign it's
on search it's not all devices it's only
set to the country of say the united
states it uses an automated bid system
that can spend a hundred dollars a day
you might have another campaign it's on
search it's only on desktops it's set to
france it's based on manual bidding it
has a 50 a day budget so when you want
these campaign level settings to be
different
that's one of the main reasons to create
a new campaign for the ads and keywords
that are inside of that campaign
now ad groups are a collection of
keywords and ads and only an ad from
that ad group that contains the same
keyword that matched to a search query
right can be displayed so ad groups
should be closely related collections of
keywords and ads so we think about the
work involved and setting up a google
ads account it's really quick just to
make an account it can be very quick to
make a campaign but where you're going
to slow down and spend your time is
thinking about your ad groups
someone did a search they are looking
for something they're going to then see
an ad
so that ad is going to take them to a
page of your website so you want that
user experience be very cohesive so you
may have one campaign the campaign could
have 20 or 50 or a thousand ad groups in
it right for each type of idea that
you're advertising so if you want to
show a user
a different ad based upon their search
term changing you want a different ad
group
let's say we sell shoes now we sell
hiking boots we sell running shoes we
sell dress shoes
now we don't want to do is put all of
those in one ad group because if someone
searches for hiking boots versus a
running shoe versus a dress shoe
you want a different ad there's not a
good that explains all those concepts so
we could write an ad
shoes for sale right but shoes for sale
doesn't really speak to the user if
someone's doing a search for hiking
boots right and they see an ad that says
shoes for sale and another ad that says
hiking boots for sale right walk on the
trails comfortably right they're gonna
look at the one that says choose for
sale and say it's not relevant to what
i'm looking for and the ad that
mentioned the product they search for
hiking boots would be relevant we get a
lot more of those clicks and conversions
so why we may take some keywords like
hiking boots trail hiking boot hiking
boots for sale best hiking boots and put
them in an ad group together right we
make an ad only for those keywords so we
create and add hiking boots for sale
walk the trails in comfort but then
someone searches for running shoes that
ad would not be a good result for them
right hiking boots an ad that they're
looking for running shoes so you'd want
a different ad group for running shoes
so you might have keywords running shoes
best running shoes shoes for running
marathon long distance running shoes
right and then we can make an ad that
says running shoes for sale maximize
your performance
now if we were really focused on running
shoes and that was our core business
then we wouldn't want to run just the
running shoe ad because that's very
general we want to get more specific if
someone's running a marathon they want
long distance running shoes others want
minimalistic running shoes you'll see
see people search for running shoes with
high arches
or better arch support
wide box shoes since you can even get
into those very specific terms to create
ads for them in the ad groups
when you think about ad group structure
only the keywords and that ad group can
show for that ad
right if we have two ad groups
and someone searches for running shoes
right they can't see our hiking boots ad
because it's in a different aggregate
they only show the running shoes add so
you can make multiple ads in an ad group
and do some ad testing to see which is
best so if we look at an ad group and we
say here's another keyword that we
really want to look at and the ads we
have aren't great for that keyword we
can move it to a new ad group
so we may have one ad groups that's
dress shoes another for high heels
and we can make new adders for all of
these items so that the ad and then
where the user goes on your website or
is specific to each of those types that
idea of keywords so you might have many
aggregates but the trick about ad groups
is you have a core set of keywords in
each ad group and then you have multiple
ads in an ad group and so as long as all
the ads and the keywords are reflective
of each other then you've got a good ad
group now if an ad does not represent a
keyword that keyword should be in a
different aggregate
settings are inherited downwards across
the account
so for instance the account level you
set billing the billing methods used by
all the campaigns in the account and all
the ad groups so you set access level by
account so anyone with account access
level can see are your campaigns and ad
groups so then at the campaign level we
enter settings like budgets location so
that goes from the campaign level is
inherited down to the ad groups
so any ad group in the campaign that can
show
to all the users in a location that's
set at the campaign level or budgets and
so forth so then that goes from campaign
is inherited to the ad groups so any ad
group in the campaign can show where it
may reach the campaign settings such as
location or it uses that same budget
where all the ag groups on campaign use
a budget
so if we have different campaigns
then only the ad groups in that campaign
would use that campaign's budget and
that campaign's targeting method so when
you create a setting at the account
level it's used at the campaign level
and then anything at the campaign level
is used at the ad group level so if you
create ad group level settings for
something you can set up the ad group
they're only used by the ads and
keywords in that specific ad group
ad group data is never inherited to
another ad group so setting hierarchy
flows downwards across the account from
account to campaign to ad group and then
the ads and keywords
so the first step to getting started
with google ads is opening an account
now once you open an account then you
can fill in your billing information add
additional users and connect your
analytics account to your google ads
account
so in this lesson we will look at how to
create the initial account
now by the end of this lesson you'll be
able to open a google ads account set
permission levels and user access data
and then connect additional accounts
now before you begin creating a google
ads account you'll need a google account
to access it
if you use gmail then you can use your
gmail account
if you want to use your business email
then you can create an account and use
your business email address you'll need
to verify your account through a text
message code or through an email to the
email address you're using to access
your google ads account now once you've
established how to access your google
ads account proceed to setting up your
first campaign
each person who can access your data
should have their own login this lets
you choose their permission level remove
someone when they should no longer have
access
and see what changes were made in the
change history tool which logs changes
by user access
before adding a user you should consider
the permission level that the user needs
so for instance if you want someone to
see information but not change anything
you can give them read only access
if you want a user to be able to make
any changes but not add or move other
users they can have standard access
by giving each user access you can
maintain control over your data and also
add and remove other users as your need
for accessing your data changes
there are times when you will want your
google ads account to connect with other
applications so they can share data back
and forth this is really common with
google analytics
by connecting google analytics and
google ads you can see a lot of data in
both places
in addition you can create conversions
or audience lists in google analytics
and have them imported into google ads
if you're an e-commerce company then you
want to create a google merchant center
account and link it to your google ads
account so you can create shopping
campaigns
a common problem you might come across
is that one email is the admin for one
account and another email is the admin
for your google ads account you might
need to give someone permission to log
into google ads to connect accounts or
they might need to give you permission
to access the accounts that you want to
link to google ads so you have the
necessary permission levels in both
places to connect the data
once you have the necessary permissions
in place
it's easy to connect other accounts to
your google ads account using the linked
accounts tool inside of your google ads
account
so i want you to imagine
having the world at your fingertips
especially when it comes to advertising
imagine having the entire world at your
fingertips for advertising so just
imagine you have the ability to
advertise your brand to any website in
the world can you imagine that well
imagine having that entirety at your
fingertips the entire world so it's not
really an imagination so no need to
imagine anymore because google ads has
come to the rescue so no need to imagine
the world is at your fingertips and why
is it at your fingertips because of
google and specifically google display
network okay so we're gonna talk about
what the google display network is so
let's start out by asking the question
or answering the question what is the
google display network so google has two
networks basically one the search
network one the display network so you
as an advertiser if you want to
advertise on google you have a choice
can i go with google search or can i go
with the display network well the search
network is for google search only so if
you want to advertise when somebody
types in a keyword query and you want
your ad to show up that's the search
network so it looks something like this
somebody types in a keyword data science
and lo and behold ads show up and here
you can see the first ad from simply
learn why did that ad show up because
simply learn was bidding on the keyword
data science and so that's how the
search network works you bid on keywords
somebody types on those keywords and
your ads show up in the search engine
results at the top above organic
listings so that's the search network
and it just simply comprises of ads that
respond to what people are querying okay
the display network is a little bit
different so that's the search network
today we're going to talk about the
display network okay the display network
is a little bit different so imagine
you're on the lookout for a new shoe on
amazon as an example but you don't have
end up buying the shoe you're looking at
shoes you don't buy it well you might
have noticed in the past you've done
something like that whether it be shoes
or shirts or coats or belts or cars or
radios or headphones or phones it
doesn't really matter you might have
been looking at something and then
notice an ad show it might have been
exactly that same product or might have
been something similar to the product
you were looking at but on the same
website so why does that happen well it
happens because google's display network
specifically remarketing which we'll
talk about so on google's display
network you have the option to advertise
that somebody's been on your website so
that's one of the powers and one of the
features of google's display network and
that's remarketing or retargeting
somebody that's looked at your product
so let's take a little bit of a deeper
dive into how the display network works
so if you're a customer you go to a
website and
you leave that website again from a
remarketing perspective your product can
appear on another site okay so that's
remarketing so you can retarget that
person who's been to your site so that's
again one great example of how to use
display network in google terms we call
it remarketing and again somebody goes
to your website they leave in this
example not buying something it could be
a technology company where we want
somebody to watch a video or download a
pdf okay whatever they do that that you
want them to do but they don't actually
do it then you can go back and retarget
them so if they actually go to a page
and look at your product but don't buy
that product then you have the
opportunity to advertise to them again
so the whole idea is if you advertise
them again wow that person can say okay
i remember that i was in still
interested in that product let me go
back and purchase that product so they
go back to the site and make the
purchase so that's again the power of
the display network you can reach people
who have been to your site before so
let's take another look here so
retargeting evolves around adding a
piece of code or pixel on your website
which uses browser cookies to add
website visitors to your audience so let
me just summarize that for you so if you
want to use the display network and you
want to target people who have been to
your website well you need to add a
simple script or pixel if you will to
your website that's all and so when
somebody comes to your website they're
going to get cookied and that cookie is
stored in their browser and so that's an
important piece of the whole process
because that's how google determines who
that visitor is so without that cookie
then google won't know to show their ad
your ad to them again so that's the
first piece in all this so when somebody
does get cookie they're going to be
added to that audience and so when we
say audience we mean you as an
advertiser to finding who you want to
retarget to so in this example we're
talking about people who've looked at a
product and didn't purchase that could
be a whole audience in itself people who
look at a product and don't purchase it
could be everyone who comes to your
website it could be only return users it
could be only new users you defund the
audience but however you define that
audience they're going to get cookied
and placed on a list and when they're
placed in that list they're going to get
shown the ad again so past visitors will
see your product ads when they're
browsing the web watching videos on
youtube going through news sites and so
on so if that's your audience list past
visitors that's where they're going to
be able to see your ad because google's
displayed network is much more than just
websites it's also youtube it's also
news feeds it's also social networking
sites so there's a lot involved with
google's display network so the network
involves several websites that are
partnering up with google along with the
likes of youtube along with the likes of
millions of other websites in fact these
websites together tally up to more than
2 million that encompasses more than 90
of the internet so you can imagine
google's display network is just made up
of a bunch of websites including youtube
okay so you have the opportunity to
really reach somebody that's been to
your website before so again if they're
past visitors and they looked at a
product and they didn't purchase it you
have an opportunity to really put your
ad in front of them on a lot of
different websites so that's just an
intro about the display network
remarketing is just one benefit but
let's take a step back so we dove into
the deep end with remarketing let's just
separate out the two again just so
you're clear on what the display network
is versus the search network well let's
go
through some of the differences so
display network on the left search
network on the right so the display
network as we just discussed is great
for retargeting people who have been to
your website whether they're new users
returning users users who looked at a
product users who added a product to
your cart users who looked at a specific
page whatever that behavior is you're
defining that now the search network is
usually for top of funnel why do we say
top of funnel because users are actively
searching for something they're looking
for a product they're being active so
they're going to search and seeing who
has that product okay the display
network we know remarketing is a benefit
but usually it's bottom of funnel like
brand awareness so if nobody knows who
your brand is or what your brand is or
what you have to offer what your
services are then the display network
remember made up of millions of websites
you have the opportunity to put your ad
out there okay so display bottom of
funnel search network top of funnel
somebody actively looking for something
let's take a look at some other
differences here so display network
easier to advertise products that don't
satisfy an immediate need this is true
because again if you have a new product
you want to get that product out there
you want people to just know about it
some people may not be ready to buy that
product but at least they're going to
know what the products about on the
search network on the other hand if
somebody's looking for something like a
particular product that you're offering
then they could type in a keyword that
describes that product and wham your ad
can appear at the top okay remember top
of funnels so products and services
usually fulfill a particular requirement
now the display network can be used to
familiarize users to your brand so again
going back to remarketing somebody comes
to your website they really don't know
who you are well you can reach back out
to them on the display network with
another ad retargeting and that's how
you get users familiar with your brand
where on the search network users are
showing ads based on what they search
for so it doesn't really matter if they
know your brand or not hey
if they're looking for something and
they're ready to buy and you have that
product at the right price then the
chance of them converting are pretty
good so you're at the right place at the
right time where the display network's
all about familiarity retargeting to
people with your brand getting your
brand out there getting your product out
there in front of millions of people now
on the display network users are shown
these ads in over a million different
websites so with the display network you
have the opportunity to kind of hone in
and pick and choose those websites where
on the search network users are showing
ads in google apps and on the search
engines so you have the opportunity to
place your ads not just on desktop
search but also on mobile and also on
apps whereas again the display network
is made up of much more it's made up of
websites youtube apps etc okay the
display network
has a multitude of different formats
okay when we say different formats we
mean text ads image ads rich media ads
meaning ads that have some functionality
to it like movement okay and then video
ads where the search network is really
only text ads and i say really only text
ads well you can have image ads those
are called shopping ads but mainly it's
text ads where display network you have
an option between text image rich media
or video ad so you can see the
differences here really there are big
differences between the two networks
where search you're just really
responding what somebody's looking for
they're really active and ready to go
display
hey you're trying to reach out to these
people you're trying to introduce them
to something and in some cases with
remarketing you're reaching out to them
again okay you're trying to get them
familiar with your product and brand and
you're trying to do that via video via
rich media via regular image ad via text
ad so you're trying to do it in a
multitude of formats so again bottom of
funnel for display top of funnel for
search so that's an intro to the display
network those are the differences
between
search and display now let's go through
the steps of how to set up a
campaign in google ads using the display
network as our option so here i am i'm
in google ads i'm in an account and i
want to set up a campaign on the display
network so you can see here if i'm in
google ads i've selected display
campaigns i can already see i have some
display network campaign set up in fact
they're all remarketing campaigns and so
remarketing remember is targeting
somebody who fits a list or description
okay so it could be somebody looking at
a particular product they get cookie
meaning that text file is gonna sit on
their browser and then they're gonna see
your ad the next time they're on
google's display network wherever site
they may be so we're reaching out to
somebody who fits a particular
description okay so if we're going to
set up a display campaign meaning a
campaign on google's display network we
want to go to campaigns and we want to
click on the plus button here and we're
just going to say new campaign now we
have the opportunity now to pick and
choose what our goal is for that
campaign and so most of the time with
display you're going to choose brand
awareness and reach okay so here you can
see the campaign types for brand
awareness and reach display and video
usually when it comes to sales or leads
or even just driving traffic okay you
might go with the search network but if
you're just really trying to just
promote your brand you may go with
display because remember you have the
option to get your ad in front of
millions of websites we're going to
choose brand awareness and reach okay
and we're going to choose the campaign
type so here you have display we want to
run different kinds of ads or we can run
just video okay we want to write if
we're running video we can reach and
engage viewers on youtube and across the
web meaning other websites okay let's
choose display here so
we're gonna go ahead and just put our
website in there so our businesses
website
and when that loads up we're gonna have
a number of different options available
to us so here we can name our campaign
okay so here you can see brand awareness
and reach is the name of our campaign
and for now we're just gonna protest now
we have the opportunity to choose our
location here we're going to choose the
united states we have just like a search
campaign we also have languages and
options so with search you have
locations and languages same thing on
display so we're going to target english
as our language and what are we trying
to do what are we focusing on well we
want to get our product out there so
we're going to choose impressions
viewable impressions that's really what
we want to focus on we want people to
see our ad okay so an impression is the
number of times somebody sees your ad
okay so we have viewable impressions
that's what we want people to do we want
them to see our ad and if you take a
peek over here on the right side you can
see your targetings reach so we can
reach over 10 billion plus in
impressions meaning that's a lot of
eyeballs the number of people looking at
our ad right now is over 10 billion plus
okay so that's just gives you the scope
and some idea of how big google's
display network is so just like search
we could set a budget i'm just going to
choose a hundred dollars for now and i
can choose how to deliver that budget
just like on search i have standard
accelerated i can ask google to speed up
the spend or i could just do regular
standard which means they're going to
spend my budget evenly over a period of
time over the course of the day now
remember with display network we have
different options on ad types we have
text ads rich media ads regular image
ads and video so we can rotate our ads
how we like so we could say hey look i
want to run my best performing ads okay
so that means i want google to optimize
for me meaning if i have an ad that's
performing better than some others then
i'm gonna let google run that one more
and that's the one i would recommend but
you do have other options here you can
just have them rotate evenly you can say
hey optimize for conversions but it's
really remember our goal here for the
display is to get impressions eyeballs
we're not interested in top of funnel
conversions in here we could say rotate
evenly and that's not supported for
display so really our best option here
is prefer best performing ads we want
our best performing ads to run okay we
have an option to schedule them we have
an option to start and okay and we have
an option to set a cap how many times we
want somebody to look at that ad so we
can limit how many times our ad is shown
to the same user okay so we're gonna let
google optimize how often your ads are
shown however we do have the option to
set that limit okay so we could set the
limit to x times per day for the entire
campaign or it could be for a particular
ad or aggro okay so we could set the
limit ourselves and we can let google
optimize for us here we have some
exclusions okay and then we have the
opportunity to set up our ad group now
the ad group is the same as the search
network the ad group on display is where
your settings are going to be your ads
are going to be located in your ad group
and now the important part we want to
get to audiences so if we're remarketing
we're going to choose our audience and
if we're not remarketing we still have
the opportunity to choose our audience
so if i'm a tech company and i just type
in tech then google is going to give me
some options here so here i can choose
some tech companies technology client
products new inventions etc or i can
choose some ideas that google has in
mind for audiences like they have an
in-market audience so this is based on
network systems and services network
management so the bottom line is google
is giving me suggestions on who i can
target my ad to okay that's what really
what this is choosing your audience
now you don't have to choose anything
here in fact you can just clear all and
be done with it now you can go down to
demographics now i can pick and choose
based on gender i can pick and choose
based on age parental status and
household income really depending on who
you're advertising to that's really what
it comes down to it okay so you have
demographics and you have audiences
audiences are really for remarketing so
again you can go with some of google's
recommended audiences or you can create
your own audience okay and we're going
to talk about that here in a minute but
this is all part of the setup for the
campaign so i'm saying hey these are the
demographics and these are the audiences
but if you're not remarketing you don't
necessarily have to go with an audience
okay once that's done you can set up a
bid just like you want on the search
network and then you have the option to
choose your ad so that's part of the
campaign setup so when you actually
choose your ad again you have different
options image ad okay rich media ad
video or text once you choose your ad
then you pretty much have your campaign
set up now we're gonna tweak it after we
set it up but that's pretty much the
steps in terms of setting up a display
campaign very similar to search in fact
minor differences really are choosing
your audience and choosing the ad type
that's really the main differences
between setting up a campaign on display
and setting up a campaign on search the
main differences now there are other
subtle differences but those are the
main ones so we talked about remarketing
to people who have been on our website
so going and showing our ad to somebody
who fits a particular description
meaning they looked at a product or they
looked at a particular page so if you're
gonna retarget the people then as a best
practice i would set up the audience in
google analytics so google analytics
talks to google ads in fact you can link
up the two in analytics so regardless of
whether you're creating a display
campaign or search campaign you want to
link up analytics with google ads so you
can see we've done that here okay now
that we've linked the two up we could
set up an audience in google analytics
for use on a remarketing campaign on
google's display network so here you can
see i have audiences set up if you want
to just create a new audience you can do
that so if i click new audience here
here i can choose choose returning users
or new users these are audiences that
google has set up by default i can
create a new one if i want so i could
say hey i want to target you know 18 to
24 year old males who
speak english for example and
who came from mobile so if i go here
technology i'm going to say including
mobile so that could be my audience so
anybody who fits that description of 18
to 24 year old coming to my website from
mobile who speaks english i'm going to
retarget them and you can go ahead and
save this so if i go ahead and click
apply i'm going to name my audience 18
24 year old male english mobile one
thing about remarketing on the display
network is you can choose how long
somebody stays on your list meaning how
long is that cookie gonna live so
depending on your funnel if they're
buying a car the funnel may be
six months long if they're buying a pair
of shoes the funnel may be seven days
long maybe even shorter so really
depends on your business the default is
30 days so if you go with 30 days and
that means any 18 to 24 year old male
who speaks english and comes from mobile
is going to get cookied and that cookie
is going to live for 30 days so if i
click next step i can go ahead and
publish it i can say i want this to be
available in my google ads account so
i'm going to go ahead and pick my
account and it'll be available in that
account so i'll choose my account and
then go ahead and click publish so now
this audience list is going to be
available for me to use in my display
campaign when i go to choose my audience
so if i go back to google ads so google
ads and google analytics talk to one
another why because they're linked and
so now when i go to actually set up my
ad group and i'm choosing remarketing i
can go ahead and choose that audience
list so for example this campaign that's
already set up i can go ahead and choose
to set up another ad group with that
particular audience list so if i choose
new ad group and now i'm going to search
for the audience i just set up so here
you go i just did a search and here's my
audience i'm going to select my audience
and i'm going to now use this audience
in my ad group for my remarketing
campaign so now all i need to do is
align the right ad with this audience so
that's how remarketing works you choose
your audience list you set up your ads
remember you have different ad formats
video rich media image and text and the
whole idea beyond remarketing is you
know who your audience is you know what
you want to say to them so your ads
should really encompass that message the
message of what you want to say to that
particular group in this case 18 to 24
year old male who speak english who came
to your site from mobile so if you don't
really want to retarget somebody who's
been to your website you could certainly
still use the display network to your
advantage remember bottom of the funnel
the goal of our campaign is just get our
ad out there so that people recognize
our brand our services our product so
when you actually go to set up an ad
group you don't have to choose an
audience to retarget to you do have
other options so if i look at this ad
group here you can see i have image ads
already set up so where do i want these
image ads to appear so i do have options
available to me in the display network
so if i choose keywords then that means
if i go ahead and add a keyword then
what google is going to do is
contextually place my image ad on a
website that fits the description or
matches that keyword so if i add one or
two or three keywords then what google
is going to do is going to look at that
keyword and it's going to map
a website on the display network using
those keywords so that's keywords now
you got to be careful here because it's
a broad way of advertising meaning your
ads could appear on sites that you don't
necessarily deem relevant to those
keywords so you're allowing google to
match the the website with the keywords
you choose so that's choosing keywords
audiences again audiences are there if
you want to retarget so if you're
retargeting you can
set up your audience in analytics in
fact that's the best practice so again
if i go back to analytics and i go back
to admin under my property audiences i
can go ahead and choose my audience to
be used in google ads so that's using
audiences on a display campaign on
google's display network when we're
setting up our campaign we had an option
to choose demographics so we can exclude
a demographic if we wanted to we can
always go back and exclude a demographic
just by removing them from the ad group
notice if we choose all demographics we
can actually then see over a period of
time in google ads how many people based
on this particular age group or gender
or parental status or household income
saw our ad but not only saw our ad that
wouldn't be impressions but clicked on
our ad and how much they spent per click
and how many conversions so you have all
that data available to you in the
display network okay so that's
demographics i can also use topics so i
can take i can choose a particular topic
to advertise on so if i choose topics i
can choose a particular keyword find a
particular topic or i can drill down on
google's topic categories and
subcategories so here you can see
online communities if i choose that one
i can see there are other sub categories
under online communities okay i can
choose the whole category of science or
i can drill down to see what
subcategories are under science so i can
do that for any one of these topic
categories and if i choose a category
notice that's where google is going to
place my ad whatever i select again
notice upper right here i can take a
sneak peek at how many eyeballs
google is expecting to see my ad so here
by choosing astronomy and science i have
310 million impressions that's how many
potential eyeballs can look at my ad so
if you're setting up a display network
campaign you can choose keywords you can
choose demographics or you can choose
topics now if you decide not to go with
a topic then your last option here is
placements so i can pick and choose a
specific placement if there's a
particular website that i want to
advertise on let's just say
newyorktimes.com or or
latimes.com or webmd.com
remember there are over two million
websites on google's display network so
i can pick and choose specifically where
i want my ads to be displayed now when
you're done choosing your audience or
your keywords or your demographics your
topics or specific placements you can
always then go to your placements and
then click on where ads showed and so
now over this particular time frame i'm
going to be able to see where my ads
have been shown and so now i can see my
ads have been shown by mobile apps and
on particular websites now if you don't
like any of the particular websites that
your ad is showing on you can always
select it and you can always exclude it
can exclude it from the ad group or the
campaign okay so that's how you manage
where your ads are showing up on
google's display network again you can
go ahead and go to where ads are shown
under placements and over that
particular period of time google's going
to show you where your ads have been
shown and if you don't like that
placement then you can always just
exclude it or if you don't like the
performance meaning you're not getting
many impressions or you're not getting
many clicks or the click-through rate's
very low you can go ahead and exclude it
so this is an opportunity for you the
advertiser to take control over where
your ads are shown so in summary when
you set up a display campaign on
google's display network you have
options if you're remarketing you're
going to choose your audience going to
choose your audience using a list you
created in google analytics if you're on
the display network not remarketing you
have the option you can choose a keyword
and have google place your ad on a
website that fits the description of
that keyword you could choose specific
demographics you could choose a topic or
subtopic category or you can choose a
specific placement okay those are all
the options available to you when you
run your ad on google's display network
now let's go back and take a look at
some of the advantages of the google
display network so i just went over with
you how to actually create a campaign in
an ad group i
actually went over how to set up a
marketing campaign and set up a
marketing list and analytics and i went
over all the differences between the
search network and display but let's
really hone in on those advantages here
so with the display network we can
provide advanced targeting meaning i can
particularly point to a specific website
that i want to advertise on so that's
what i mean by advanced targeting or if
i don't want to advertise to 18 to 24
year olds or 25 to 34 year olds i can
exclude them or i can really pick and
choose a specific audience that i want
to remarket to so those are all examples
of advanced targeting and that's all
done within analytics or google ads so
advanced targeting enables you to target
the people that didn't engage with
previous campaigns and get in front of
people with look at like audiences that
can be created based on the audience you
usually advertise to so
in other words we can really hone in and
pick and choose who we want to advertise
to another advantage is relatively low
starting cost so what we mean by low
starting cost is normally on the search
network you're bidding on keywords and
some keywords can be very competitive
whereas on the display network you can
pick and choose who you want to
advertise to and pick and choose where
you want to advertise so you can really
advertise on websites that get a lot of
traffic may not have a lot of
competition and therefore may not cost
as much so if you compare it to
traditional forms of advertising like tv
or radio display advertising reaching a
large broader audience is a lot cheaper
okay you can do advanced tracking
meaning when we talk about perform
advanced tracking we're talking about
again remarketing we can really pick and
choose who we want to remarket to and
cookie them and pick and choose how long
they are going to be cooking so we talk
about advanced tracking that's what
we're really talking about so we can
also talk about how many times our ad is
shown to somebody we really can pick and
choose how many times we want somebody
to actually see our ad on a site based
on performance okay let's take a look at
some other advantages the ability to
advertise your brand to a broader
audience and google has over two million
websites so we can pick and choose where
really where we want our ads to show up
again it can be by topic it could be
contextually via keywords or it can be
specific websites so we can create
demand for our products and what we mean
by that we can create really cool ads
remember rich media ads video ads these
are all engaging type of ads those are
ad types on the display network we
create engaging type of ads it's going
to appeal to somebody and they're going
to engage so we have that opportunity
just based on the different ad types of
course increasing web traffic we can't
say that enough if you're advertising on
google's display network you have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
millions of people getting from our ads
in front of millions of people we have
the opportunity to get a lot of clicks
and we do have that wide range of
formats search network only has text ads
here we have text we have rich media we
have image we have video so all these
types of ad formats allow us to really
get our ads out there in a number of
different ways again we're marketing our
products and services of the big big big
advantage using google's display network
that's how we started today's webinar we
started talking about remarketing
because it's such a key feature so if
somebody comes to our website and
doesn't do what we want them to do we
can cookie them and we can retarget them
with a more specific ad tailored to that
audience today we're going to talk about
google analytics we're going to start
out with how to set up a google
analytics account and so we're going to
talk about everything that entails
including creating your google analytics
account we're going to talk about
setting up a property in your account
and what a property is we're going to
talk about setting up a reporting view
in your property and we're going to talk
about installing the tracking code so
those are the series of steps we're
going to go through today in terms of
setting up a google analytics account so
let's get right to it and so really the
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a google analytics account is
to have a google login and id so when
you actually go to google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're gonna go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
google id and login so if you have a
gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new google analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here i'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the url for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and i'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute and then
you're gonna choose your time zone and
the time zone is also important because
that's when the day starts in analytics
and the day ends based on that time zone
so the data that google analytics
collects starts and ends with that time
zone so very important to choose the
time zone your business is located in
okay and then you have some additional
options here okay so you have some
settings and so the first setting is to
allow google products and services so if
you opt into this then basically what
google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
i would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by google
it doesn't hurt to hear from google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs in education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymously with others in the
industry in this case jobs and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share anonymous data on other
websites in the same industry and the
benefit of that is we get to see
what other websites or how other
websites are performing compared to ours
what's the benchmark in our industry and
so the benchmarking to me is important
and i'm gonna go over that in a few
minutes when we go over the different
reports but to me i would always opt
into benchmarking because this is the
only report google provides in analytics
about how others in your industry is
performing versus your website okay so
it's a way to compare your website
performance against others in the same
industry the other options here
technical support and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you to
basically
google allow google access to your
account and they'll be able to help you
if you occur or run into any issues so
these are the options in setting up a
google analytics account it's very
simple very easy to do you're just
entering in a few fields note that we
talking about a website right now so i'm
talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
id now i'm going to accept the terms of
service i'm going to accept another
terms of service in relation to data
protection i'm going to click accept
once i accept i'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking id
is the id associated with your account
and so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account id
starts with ua and it's gonna be this
number here now the dash one is the
property you set up so in this case i
set up demo.simplylearn.com
if i wanted to track multiple websites
under that same account then i can
certainly set up multiple properties
just know that every property i set up
in that account is going to have a dash
1 dash 2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up so by default i set up one
property so my first property id is dash
one if i set up a second property the
same account number is just gonna have a
dash two and that's important because
that id that account and property id is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking id up here
notice the tracking id and the snippet
of code now this snippet of code needs
to go on every page of your website that
you want to track and you don't have to
put it on every page but if you want to
track website behavior on every page
your website then it needs to go on
every page of your website so if you're
using a you know platform like drupal or
joomla or even more popular platform
like wordpress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
google analytics plugin to wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in in
the id now there's an alternative to
adding the google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's google tag
manager so google tag manager is the way
i would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with google tag manager i would
recommend watching the
youtube video we have on google tag
manager you can just go to youtube type
in simply learn google tag manager and
this will give you a nice overview of
you know what google tag manager is and
how it works but basically this is the
way i would go and i would recommend
that in addition having google analytics
you set up a google tag manager account
and then that way you can put the
tracking code in google tag manager so
if i go to google tag manager and i just
go into an account on tag manager i can
just simply put in the google analytics
id
right into tag manager and so if i have
it in tag manager then tag manager is
going to be the place that holds the
code and fires page view when somebody
comes to my website so that way i don't
have to add the tracking code to my
website if i do it in tag manager so
that's the recommended method for me is
to add the google analytics id
associated with tag manager if you can
associate it with tag manager then
that's the easier route to go versus
putting code on your website okay so
again take a look at the video we have
on youtube for google tag manager that's
the route i would go now once you do get
the tracking code on your website
whether that be through google tag
manager or through a plugin or you know
just simply adding the script to your
site to pages on your site then what's
going to happen is you're going to start
collecting data so that's ideally the
way it works you need to add this code
to your website now if you're not ready
to do that and you simply want to
basically understand how google
analytics works then i would recommend
getting access to google analytics demo
account and so if you just type in and
search google analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first listing there
and you're going to go to demo account
so if you have a google analytics or
google login then all you need to do is
click on access demo account and so what
google's going to do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this so if
i click on demo account here it's going
to add to my google analytics account so
i'm going to have then access to the
demo account from google and google
analytics so i would recommend going
this route here if you're not familiar
you're not sure what you're getting
yourself into so think of the demo
account as kind of a test drive you're
test driving google analytics before you
even add any code to your website so
again all you need is a google account
and if you have a google account and you
add the demo account to your google
analytics account you're going to be
able to see how analytics works okay and
so that's what i would also recommend so
if you're not ready to start adding code
to your website then what you can do is
just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around google
analytics to see the different types of
reports it has to offer now when you do
actually set up a google analytics
account you're going to have some
settings that you're going to want to
pay attention to so when you set up the
account you have the account name and
then you have a property so under each
property you have by default you're
going to have one view and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings in
future webinars for advanced google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to google analytics anything
from adding users to your google
analytics account your google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up google ads
you can
you know set up remarketing lists
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics but so no those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you can
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in google
analytics so if i'm an admin and i'm
looking at the google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
i click on the real time report and i
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users i actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here i can see that 79
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately 3 are coming from tablet
here i can see how they actually came to
the website so this is the referring
source if they came from
say search or social i can see the
source there and i can see what pages
they're active on and then here i can
see what locations where they're located
and so if i want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview i can
certainly do that if i go to locations
under real time i could see a majority
of my users are coming from the united
states okay where are they coming from
i'll just click on traffic sources and
here i could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's google
it's either paid search or organic
search so i can see here it's organic
then i can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so i
could see currently have three active
users on the homepage two active users
on the google's women's white tee page
so forth and so on now most importantly
if you have event tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if i click on
events i'll be able to see
what events are firing so here i can see
we have event tracking set up and i can
see how many different events are firing
on my website in real time so here i can
see e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and i could see
that these are the current events that i
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes i can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four so
in analytics you can have up to 20 goals
and so here i can see we have goal
number four has already had one active
user and so if i look at the last 30
minutes i can see i still have only one
goal over the last 30 minutes and that
was somebody who entered the checkout so
that's real time reporting in summary it
just gives you an idea of what's
currently happening on your website and
so for me ideally if i'm launching a
campaign or let's just say you do a new
website redesign and you want to see how
users performing and behaving then real
time is a good option for you so you can
see how things are happening in real
time now let's jump down to audience
reporting so if i click on audiences
it's just right underneath real time i'm
going to see a number of different
reports available to me under audience
and so let's click on the audience
overview report so
audience reporting basically allows us
to get a sense of who is coming to our
website when i say who is coming to our
website it doesn't necessarily have to
be a specific person in fact google
doesn't allow personally identifiable
information in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information etc however we
could still paint a nice picture on who
is coming to our website meaning what
country
city or state did they come from what
language what device did they get to our
website from how old were they okay were
they male or female or other what
interest did they have what browser did
they use so we can paint a nice picture
based on all this information that
google analytics is providing us under
audience so if i go to audience overview
here i can see i have all these
different options available to me to get
a basic understanding of who is coming
to our website so for example i could
see a majority of the people coming to
our website speak english and are from
the united states okay in fact that
represents 61
of the users and so google analytics
does a great job of giving me an overall
percentage so if i have a 100 of the
users i could see 61 percent of those
users represented english speaking users
from the united states seven percent
represented english speaking users from
great britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the google analytics tracking
script to your website what's going to
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're going to get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been to your website what google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking in analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here i can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here i can see april 6
through april 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here i could see about 23 24 percent are
returning users okay so i can get a good
breakdown of what type of users are
coming am i driving new traffic am i
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay i can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience so if i
skip down now to demographics i can
click on overview and when that report
loads i can see now under demographics
overview i can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if i
want to change this date range i could
simply do that i can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and i can even compare it to the
previous period
or the previous year i'm going to choose
the last 30 days i'm going to click
apply now i'm looking at data over the
last 30 days and again you can change
the date range to any range you want you
can only go back as far as when you
actually created the google analytics
account you can't go prior to that so
here i'm looking at the last 30 days and
i can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender i
can see
66 percent represent males so i can get
a breakout of gender and age as well as
interest and click on interest and look
at the overview there and see what the
interest is of the users who are coming
to my site based on in-market segments
or affinity i can also choose language
and location
so if i want to know exactly where my
users are located when they're coming to
my website i can click on location and
here i can get a breakout 43 percent of
the users of the last 30 days were from
the united states more importantly i can
align my audience with goals and we'll
talk about goals here in a minute but
here i can see if i have an e-commerce
website i can see of those 43
0.29 of those converted or purchased
something and that equates to 94
transactions so i can get a good sense
of not only how many users are coming
from a specific country but are those
users converting if i click on mobile
and mobile to me is one of those reports
i tend to spend a bit of time on because
i want to know what devices users are
coming to my website and so for my
website here or this is the google demo
website i can see mobile represents
approximately 27
of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic so
for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile is definitely a
majority of what people use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact via mobile whether
that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on behavior so google
analytics is telling me that yes i have
approximately 27 of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile how are
they interacting with my website so if i
look across this report i'm going to be
able to see different metrics so if i'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile i can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48 and
bounce rate means that if a user in this
case for mobile landed on a page they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48
mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41
now if i look a little bit further at
engagement i can see how many pages on
average do mobile users look at so
versus desktop it's a little bit lower
you can see 3.86
on desktop it's 4.5 now if i look a
little bit further in engagement i want
to be able to measure how long somebody
from mobile stays on the website if
they're bouncing at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 pages
3.9 almost four pages per session then
that means in this report analytics is
telling me they're spending about two
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough i can see that mobile over the
last 30 days had more transactions so 51
transactions versus 34 transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
commerce conversion rate is at point two
nine percent that's higher than desktop
at point zero seven it's lower than
tablet but it's higher than desktop and
mobile has the most transactions and
since they have the most transactions
they have the most revenue at 2 380. so
yes the engagement isn't exactly as
great as it is as desktop but we can see
that people are still purchasing with
their mobile devices so it's something
to keep an eye on and mobile is
something i definitely look at in fact
since it's such an important report one
thing you can do in analytics is if you
actually like a report and you think
you're going to look at that report
multiple times then you can simply just
go ahead and click save at the top here
so if i click save i'm going to enter a
name for this report i'm just going to
call it mobile report and click ok and
then what's going to happen is it's
going to be located under save reports
and save reports is located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if i close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if i click on
customization if i click on save reports
i should be able to see my save report
here and i do so here i can see mobile
report if i click on it i can simply go
to the report i was looking at before i
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so let's take a
look at one more report under audience
and let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we were setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and i recommended you do so
and so if you did actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see
how your site compares to others in the
same industry so if i click on
benchmarking and then click on channels
what i'm actually able to do now is
compare my website with others in the
same industry so if i go back to say
jobs in education and i choose education
all education as my industry vertical i
should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how i compare with those
websites so i'm choosing all countries i
can narrow that down if i wanted to i
can just search for the united states i
can choose a specific state and then i
can choose a particular site size so
here i'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5 000 to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
united states sites that have 5 000 to
99999 sessions per day that means that
there are approximately 310 web
properties contributing to this report
okay based on this criteria i chose now
if my site is similar meaning if i'm in
the united states if i'm in education
and i'm receiving 5 000 to
99999 sessions per day then i'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now google sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's shared
data anonymously in particular
industries and verticals and so now i'm
looking at a channel report so if i want
to see how i compare to others in my
industry then i can go ahead and see by
channel for example am i driving as much
traffic as others in my industry
and you can see i'm not in fact i'm 76
77 percent worse in terms of the amount
of traffic being driven from organic
search so anything in red is going to
show as a negative result a negative
comparison whereas something in green is
a positive comparison so if i look at
engagement i can see that i might not be
driving as much traffic but i can see
that the pages per session are better
than the site average or the industry
average i can see if i go over again
looking just at organic search i can see
the bounce rate is better than the
industry average so the channel report
under benchmarking allows you to measure
how you compare to others in your
industry and you could do so by looking
at location and devices so if you opted
into benchmarking when you set up your
account then you'll be able to compare
your website against others in your
industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how did these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning or new came to our website and
so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
do they type something into google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the url
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website and come back via
the bookmark so they're grouping users
under direct they also group users under
referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like twitter or facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say google
then do they come from paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
google's network google's display
network that's a default channel so
analytics will group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default google analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so i could
see how many users came to the site from
each channel now if i want to drill down
on this report i can click on all
traffic and then if i click on all
traffic i can go to channels i can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now i can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users i can see
that number is about 56 percent so 56 of
my traffic over the last 30 days came
from organic search and so those are the
number of users again as a metric you're
also going to have sessions and you'll
see sessions a lot as a metric so users
are broken down between new and
returning so every time a new or
returning user comes to the website
basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so
just like we looked at with the
audience reports when it came to mobile
we can also look at engagement by
channel so just like mobile we looked at
bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 123 64 actually
turned into a transaction which equates
to 0.17 which also equates to 3 000 in
revenue so i'm able to determine not
only how users are getting to my website
by looking at the channel report i can
actually see if they're engaging and if
they are converting and notice when you
look at a report in analytics you can
look at it by channel you'll also get a
summary so here i can see a summary or a
total based on my date range so i could
see over the last 30 days i've had 54
000 users 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that at those fifty four thousand users
i had seventy thousand sessions i could
see my average bounce rate was forty
three percent the pages per session were
just over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about two minutes
and 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was 0.14 and i had a total of 97
transactions totaling 5500
okay and that's all over the last 30
days so any report you look at in
analytics is going to have a summary and
note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
going to go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the save button conversely if you
don't want to save it you can simply
just export it so you can export it as a
pdf if i click on pdf it's going to
allow me to export that as a pdf now you
have other options available to you as
well you can do a google sheet you can
export it as an excel or you can export
it as a comma delimited file so here you
can see i can save it as a pdf if i want
to and if i click ok it's going to save
to my desktop or location of my choosing
and then i can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running google ads note that you
can connect google ads to analytics and
this is key because now i can see
how many people are coming from google
ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with google ads i'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here i'm
running a report based on campaign data
so i could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much i'm paying per
click and you can see on average i'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly i want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see i've
spent 810
over the last 30 days and received 858
in revenue so you want to make sure
that you link up your google ads account
to your google analytics account for
this very reason you want to be able to
see
how your google ads campaigns perform
once the users get to your website and
so i want to see if they're engaging and
i want to see if they're converting so
there are all sorts of reports under
google ads so you can look at it by
keywords by search queries by hour of
the day if you're running display
campaigns you can look at display
targeting so there's all sorts of
reports under google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if i go to
campaigns i can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
facebook whether it be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say twitter or
instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you run an e-commerce platform or if you
have goals set up so you'll be able to
look at how your campaigns are not one
not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
behavior reports are going to actually
show you
how users behaved once they got to your
website once they landed on a page on
your website how did they behave so when
we looked at audience we got a sense of
who is coming with acquisition we get a
sense of how the traffic got to our
website did they come from organic
direct social etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if i go to
overview under behavior now i'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many page views i've had and a page view
is simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here i can
see in this graph how many page views
i've had again over the last 30 days and
if i look further at my overview report
i can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and i can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page i can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so i can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if i click on site
content and i click on all pages then
i'm going to look at a report by page
this is my dimension this is what i'm
measuring my page and now i can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other pages then every page that user
looks at is going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to a to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the homepage five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where page views is accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique pages okay so this gives me
a sense of how my page is performed so
again i can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low
if the exit percentage of exit rate is
high then you probably want to do
something with that page now these are
all pages but if i jump down to landing
pages my landing page report is showing
me how many people actually landed on
that page and so here i can see under my
landing page report i can see the home
page had 36 000 17 sessions in the last
30 days that's how many people landed on
the home page so here i can see 71 were
new sessions meaning that i had a lot of
new users who landed on the home page in
fact 25 000 or 52 percent of the people
who landed on the homepage were new i
could see the bounce rates about 42
but of those who didn't balance they
went on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing i like about
the landing page report is i can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case i can see of those 36 000
sessions i had 22
transactions totaling 1200 in revenue
and that's an e-commerce conversion rate
of 0.06
so the home page over the last 30 days
contributed to
0.06
of the revenue so this gives you an idea
of when somebody lands on your website
and they land on a page is that page
helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed's
important because what google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled 2 835 page
views and of that sample they came back
and said the average page load time is
about four seconds now ideally you want
to keep it as quick as possible i would
say even under three seconds okay now
there are other factors involved with
page load time the browser you're using
the country that you're actually
browsing that page from might not have
the best infrastructure you name may not
even be on the best internet network
meaning you're on a cell network or the
wi-fi is not that great or you can be on
a page that just has a lot of images or
a lot of code that may slow it down so
there are other factors involved and so
what google analytics does is show you
what those factors are so here i can see
by browser what the average load time is
if i want to look at country i could see
what country is contributing to the low
time now the great thing about the site
speed report is if i go to speed
suggestions okay what speed suggestions
is going to do is it's going to show me
the page load time by page and then it's
actually going to provide a link where i
can actually click on to get suggestions
on increasing the page load time so for
example i can look at this particular
page here this google redesign shop by
brand slash youtube page line number
five if i look at line number five i can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if i click on seven total
what it's actually gonna do it's gonna
open up a new window and it's going to
open up another google report called
page speed insights and page speed
insights is going to give me some
information about what i can do to
create crack correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the site
speed report it's important because
there is a correlation
between site speed or page load time and
user behavior of that page and there's
also correlation between page load time
and a page ranking organically on search
so page load time is very important it's
so important that i'm even going to save
it so i'm going to click save and click
on speed site speed suggestions as my
name and click ok and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website and so in google analytics we
have the opportunity to set up goals now
you have the opportunity to set up 20
goals in your google analytics view and
so to set up a goal okay so you're going
to click on admin and under the view
you're going to see goals and so if you
don't even have goals the first step is
to create goals and so you have four
different goal types and analytics so
you have pages per session so how many
pages per session is so if your goal is
set to say three or two if somebody
actually looked at two or three pages
per session it's going to count as a
goal okay so if i look here i could see
i have pages per session set at 10. so
that means that if a user came to the
site looked at more than 10 pages per
session then it's going to count as a
goal another goal type is destination so
destination means that if somebody
actually went to a specific page then
it's going to count as a goal and in
this case i can see here that the goal
is set to this particular page here and
so when somebody actually lands on that
page it's going to count as a goal now
there are two other goal types we can
look at one is duration so just like
pages per session in our previous
example if somebody looked at 10 pages
per session it's gonna count as a goal
with duration it's based on time so in
this particular case if you set up a
duration goal and the duration is set to
say one minute and 30 seconds then that
means if a user comes to my website and
they spend at least one minute and 30
seconds then it's going to count as a
goal okay and then the fourth type of
goal in google analytics is an event
based goal so when you set up event
tracking you could turn that event into
a goal so if somebody clicks on say the
submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's gonna count as a goal so you
have four different goal types in google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if i look at goals overview i can be
able to see how many total goal
completions i've had so if i want to
look at it by goal i can just choose the
goal option here so if i want to look at
for example
goal 2 engaged users this was the pages
per session i can see that i had a
conversion rate of 10
meaning that i had seven thousand of all
the users who came to the website seven
thousand goal completions meaning seven
thousand one hundred six users looked at
ten pages or more on my website and so
that's how you want to be able to
measure whether users wherever they're
coming from whoever they are whatever
pages they look at you want to be able
to look at the conversion reports to see
if they're actually converting based on
the goals you've set up whether that's
pages per session duration destination
or event goal conversion tracking
reports can help you measure
who is actually converting and the great
thing about google analytics here is
that i can actually see
by segments so the default segment in a
segment is just looking at a specific
user set so the default segment is
always all users however i can choose a
different segment so if i want to choose
instead of all users if i want to choose
mobile traffic i can select mobile
traffic hit apply so i'm actually now
looking at a subset of data i'm looking
at mobile traffic so if all the mobile
users have come to my site i can see
1400 engaged or looked at 10 pages or
more okay and that's a 7
conversion rate so the great thing about
google analytics is you have the
opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rate of each goal
but you can also change the segment of
that particular goal to see who exactly
converted okay another report i like
under conversions is the multi-channel
funnel report so if i click on
multi-channel funnel basically what this
allows me to do is see how different
channels work together to convert so
remember the channel reporting we looked
at under acquisition here i can see now
how different channels work together to
drive the conversion so if i look at
three channels direct organic and
referral i can see all three together
drive two percent of the conversions if
i look at direct and referral twelve and
a half percent if i look at direct and
organic 12.24
so i can see how different channels work
together and so if i look at top
conversion paths as an example i can
actually see
what channels how channels work together
to drive the conversion so in this
example i can see over the last 30 days
that my top channel grouping was direct
times two meaning that somebody came to
the website directly meaning they typed
in the url in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only a channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns and different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance how to set up goals in
google analytics so
for this particular webinar we're going
to jump into google analytics directly
and spend all of our time there because
it's about learning practical
applications so
goals are important goals let me just
say this goals are in analytics
something that should be aligned with
your business and
we call goals that are aligned with your
business kpis are key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in google analytics because if
you're using google analytics you want
to measure everything against the goal
so
without further ado
let's jump right into google analytics
so if i go to google analytics and i log
in okay what i want to do
is go down to admin click on admin here
and admin will take you to basically a
screen that looks like this where you
have a account column you have your
property column and then you have your
view column now the view column is where
you're going to go to set up goals okay
so every view in every property has up
to 20 goals okay so by default in
analytics you're going to have at least
one view
for your property so if i have a
property i'm going to have at least one
view but if i happen to set up multiple
views like you see here then i know for
every view i set up i have 20 goals to
work with so where are those goals so
under the view i'm going to click on
goals and now i can see i have 20 at my
disposal now you can see here
by clicking on the recording column i
can see i have in this particular
property this particular view i have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation at least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're going to measure everything
in analytics against that goal okay so
in this case we have five particular
goals we're measuring so we have five
active out of 20 total so
if i don't no longer want to use a goal
i could simply just turn it off if i
want to continue using it just turn it
on okay it's that simple you could turn
on and off goals so here i already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level i would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure
whoever is in charge of google analytics
for your organization or if you're in
charge okay you simply just want to go
to user management and user management
you want to make sure the email address
you're using to log into google
analytics has at least edit permissions
so you're going to need edit permissions
to add new goals so i have edit
permissions i'm going to go to goals and
i want to set up a new goal but before
we jump in and set up a new goal what is
it that we want to achieve that's really
the question we want to ask ourselves
what is the goal of the website well if
it's somebody downloading something okay
are you measuring that download via an
event okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal do you have an e-commerce site
is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that i'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red cta button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or
reading review downloading something
sharing something you could choose all
of these options here what i normally do
is choose custom 99 of the time i'm just
going to choose custom it doesn't really
matter if you use the template or not
it's just a template is basically some
free pre-filled configurations but my
recommendation is always just go with
custom you want total control over how
to set up your goal so
we already have in mind what type of
goal we want to set up so for example if
somebody goes to
fill out a form submission and they go
to a thank you page after that well
what's the url of that thank you page we
want to be able to track how many people
go to that page because we know if
somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if i go to continue i'm going to name my
goal first so i'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an id so notice this is goal
id 15 that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so 1 through 5 6 through 10 11
through 15 16 through 20 into goal sets
so for example goals 16 through 20 is
part of goal set four and why does
google analytics combine these goals
into different goal sets well because
it's easier to ma measure and look at
data by goal sets so for example if i
jump into any report here if i go to all
traffic channels and i want to measure
how many goals by channel i can look at
it by goal set so if i have goal set one
selected then i know any goal i have
active in there between goal id one
through goal id five i'm going to be
able to see those goals in goal set one
and now i'm going to be able to measure
every goal i have active and goal set
one against the channel so if i choose
goal set 2 whatever goals are active
there goal set 3 etc notice i don't have
any goals 16 through 20 active that are
in goal set four therefore i don't have
that option available to me so back to
admin the bottom left navigation again
goals okay we want to measure somebody
going to the thank you page we have edit
access we're gonna choose custom as our
goal set up we're gonna type in a goal
name i'm just gonna say thank you okay
this is goal 15. now this is the
important part google analytics has four
different goal types destination
duration pages per session or screens
per session so screens per session is
related to mobile because google
analytics measures mobile app activity
and then you have an event so we're
going to cover all four of these but for
the sake of this simple example i'm
going to choose destination why because
if somebody goes to that thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page as the goal the goal url
so for example destination is my choice
i'm going to click continue now this is
where i'm going to put the url so if my
url is just simply thank you.html i can
just go ahead and put thank you.html
or if it's just thank you then i can
just do thank you depends on the website
depends on the uri structure so whatever
that url is that's what you're going to
put in and when you're done you can
verify it so what google analytics does
is actually
will verify over the last seven days if
anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct url then we've had zero percent
people go to that page this is just an
example however if you didn't see a
conversion then you might want to make
sure you check the url here that you put
in and if you do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so google
analytics actually has options so we're
saying thank you is equal to so the
destination url is equal to thank you or
thank you.html or thank you.esp or
whatever that thank you page is okay you
do have options so if you have a long
url you could say begins with and you
could say begins with say thank you so
this is the logic we're gonna say hey if
anybody goes to a url that begins with
thank you then count it as a goal or you
could say
equals two so if anybody goes to a url
that equals two thank you then count it
as a goal you have one more option here
regular expression so google analytics
understands the language of regular
expressions so regular
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with google
analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to
track so we can always say you know
starts with or ends with so we can you
know use characters like the dollar sign
ends with or begins with so we can
always do that so you can use regular
expressions as well if you're familiar
with regular expressions if you're not
then you don't have to use them but
there are special characters where that
you can insert in that are used as
regular expression so if you're not
familiar with regular expression don't
choose that option you can choose the
other option of equals to or begins with
now note that on all three of these
options i didn't put the domain so if my
domain is ama dash foundation.org
slash and then thank you i don't need to
put the domain because analytics are
already knows what domain we're tracking
so you don't have to put in the domain
here when you're entering in in this
case the google url so you can omit the
domain so when you put in that url you
know that you have three options to work
with and then you always always want to
verify that goal url you always want to
verify it because if you see zero
percent conversion and in this case of
the last seven days then that should
tell you something either your goal is
not set up correctly or you just don't
have any conversions either way you want
to double check that now when it comes
to the destination url goal you do have
an option here for funnel so if i turn
on funnel then that means i have the
ability to track how people went through
my funnel so if i have a
cart and i want to be able to check how
many people go in and out of the cart
then i have the option of adding
specific pages as part of the car so we
could say you know step one
which is basically cart we could say
step two
is billing information that could be
slash billing we could see step three is
shipping information slash shipping and
then step four could be
you know confirm and that could be slash
confirmation so whatever your url
structure is for your cart and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all i'm doing is putting a
series of steps with urls as each step
and why do i want to do that because i
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that i've created okay
so here i could see this is my funnel
that i've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination url so the
funnels available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step require so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if i turn that off then i'm monitoring
the funnel through each step meaning
that i can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then i'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did
actually convert okay google analytics
is going to count it as a conversion and
you can assign a value so if you're not
an e-commerce website then you may want
to think about assigning value if you
are an e-commerce website then analytics
has the ability to track e-commerce
revenue for your website so you don't
need to add a value but in this case
let's just say your non-profit
organization and you're collecting
donations and
on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the
value for that goal so that means that
if somebody did go to in this example
slash thank you and convert analytics is
going to count it as a goal and then
assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-e-commerce if you're say a
non-profit like this organization or
your b2b and you want to track some
value then you have that option there so
with the destination url goal you have
the option of adding a funnel with all
goal types you have the option of adding
a value all goal types and we're going
to go through the rest of them you have
the option of verifying that goal so
that's the structure of setting up a
goal destination url is just one goal
type we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
gonna cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination url goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's gonna happen
is analytics is going to measure traffic
as it goes through the funnel so where
do you look for that funnel information
well you want to get out of admin you
want to go to the left side navigation
you want to click on conversions then
goals then funnel visualization so based
on the funnel you set up you're going to
be able to see traffic as it goes
through the funnel so notice on this
particular funnel we don't have the
first step required why because i could
see traffic as it goes in and out of
each step of the funnel so let's go
through this funnel and see how people
react so here i can see the first step
is the store front page so over this
particular period of time i have 84
sessions enter the storefront page so
out of those 84 i can see 21 left the
storefront page 63 went on to the next
step in the funnel which is the cart
page i can then see 24
people went on to the cart page directly
and 5 exited the site all together okay
so that gave me 87 total and from 87 i
saw that 82 went on to the next page
with the next step what analytics does
is they give you a percentage so in the
first step we had 63 move on to the car
page out of 84 that's 75 percent so from
the cart page to the create your account
page we had 94
move on so
we didn't have anybody entering the
create your account page we didn't have
anybody leave the create your account
page so we have 82
82 create your account and then we have
82 move on to the payment page so that's
100
okay we have one exit so we have 81 that
proceeded to be on the payment page
which was purchased so 81 of 82 is 98
and we started with 84 so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75 percent
funnel conversion rate so 75 percent of
the people who entered in the funnel
went on to purchase okay so don't be
confused with the overall e-commerce
conversion rate so 75 is the funnel
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is
18.45
over this particular period of time why
because that takes into account all
sessions that have won to the website so
18
of all traffic went on to convert but
those that did go into the funnel 75
converted so
that's a look at the funnel so if you
set up a funnel that's what it's going
to look like you have the option to
measure everything from step one and
beyond or measure as traffic goes in and
out of the funnel so the purpose of this
is we're going to be able to see where
traffic drops off how effective our
funnel is what pages we need to address
in that funnel okay so that's the whole
point of the funnel and the funnel is
available with the destination url goal
so if i go back to admin if i go back to
goals under the view i can actually see
what that funnel looks like so here we
chose regular expression so this is what
the url is okay you can see our funnel
in each of the steps we have set up
notice we're using regular expressions
here and then if we verify this goal we
could see over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination url goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about
is pages per session so if you're not
sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
related goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so basically what this
goal is going to allow us to measure is
for example
if we set the goal to three pages per
session then we're going to be able to
measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if i
open up the goal here i can see three
pages per session is what we're naming
it so basically what we're asking
analytics to do is anything greater than
two pages which would be three and
beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more
then it's going to count as a goal and
so here we can verify it so if we verify
it over the last seven days we could see
a 4.12
conversion rate and that tells me that
four percent of my traffic over the last
seven days looked at at least three
pages or more so
you're probably asking yourself well
what number should i put in for the
actual variable so in this case we see
two well what you want to do is you want
to look at
on average let's just say year to day
you want to make sure you have
statistical significance so you want to
look at a period of time so if you go to
analytics go to audience okay and then
if you go to overview and if i change my
date range to year to date i could see
on average right now i have
1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically
measure
at a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do
is get people to stay on the site longer
look at pages more
during their session so look at more
pages and so we want to be able to see
what segment of the audience is looking
at more pages what channels driving
traffic that's looking at more pages
what pages are contributing to more
pages per session so the whole idea is
you want to hone in on
what your goal is and see what's working
and then see what's not working so you
can make adjustments the whole idea
beyond google analytics is to improve
website performance and so if our
average is 1.2
then if we change it to just two it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're gonna choose three now you can
choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 i
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and i probably wouldn't choose
two so i'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case i have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if i click continue then
basically i'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here i can see a
minute and seven so
do we want a minute and 30 maybe we
could do that maybe we can go with two
minutes so again the whole point is you
want to set the bar a little bit higher
than what the average is and so here i
can see over the last seven days if i
verify this particular goal i can see
eight percent of my traffic over the
last seven days stayed on the site
at least one minute and 31 seconds okay
they stay greater than one minute and
30. and so the whole point is you can
hone in because this is a goal i can go
in this is goal okay this is a goal here
and so i could see that this is goal 13.
so now i can go
to acquisition as an example i can go to
channels as an example since this is a
goal this is gold 13 so that would be in
goal set 3
so i can actually see what channel
is basically driving that goal okay in
other words what channel is driving
traffic that is staying on the side at
least one minute and 30 seconds and so
that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here i can see
we've have a
over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here i could see
for example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here i can see social
media has a 10 percent so i could see
that or people coming from organic
search are staying on the site longer or
they're looking at more pages than any
other channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
dimension just because it's engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of engagement
really goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic to the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available
in google analytics is an event so if
you click on new goal you close custom
click continue you have the option to
choose an event so
an event is something that you can
measure on your website that analytics
can't measure by default so if you want
to measure pdf downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link i mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event
then you want to be able to turn that
event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure
a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so
we need to identify that event
so if i go to for example
this particular website here and i want
to measure how many times
somebody clicks on the donate now button
well if i met i can measure that as an
event so when you set up an event in
analytics you have to actually assign a
category and an action for that event so
that's the first thing you need to do
when you identify an event related goal
first you need to set up the event in
order to set up the event you need to
assign a category an action okay so once
you identify what you want to track as
an event on your website you're actually
going to go in a tag manager or have
your webmaster go into tag manager and
set up a tag and in that tag they're
going to assign that particular category
in action and so here you can see
we have this set up our category is
named donate now and our action is click
and that's what we want to do we want to
measure how many people click on that
donate now button so anytime somebody
does that then the category donate now
is going to appear in analytics with the
action click so when you actually do set
up an event you can go into analytics
and you could test that event so if i go
to the website and i click donate now
okay the reason why i have this as an
event is because i'm taking to
a third-party website to handle the
donations so here i can go into
analytics and now i can see a category
is being fired for header donate with
the action click so that's my category
and that's my action so that category in
action is what is firing after somebody
clicks on the donate now button so if i
want to turn this event into a goal
i can easily do that now that i've set
up the event now that i've identified
the category in action i want to go back
to admin and
set up the event with these parameters
in place so just turns out we already
have the goal set up so let's go through
how this goal was set up so first we
chose custom we chose event we gave it a
name so as a best practice when you
actually set up a goal as an event or
turn an event into a goal i would add
the prefix event colon to it and then
that way when you're identifying goals
and you're reporting you know it's an
event so i'm going to click continue
and now that i've actually have set up
the event already in google tag manager
i given it a category i give it an
action okay see here you can see we have
a regular expression set up so anything
with the header donate or donate is
going to fire this goal so over the last
seven days i have a point eight one
percent conversion rate okay i could
have easily
put in
equals two and put in whatever the
action what or the category which is
donate now
or i could have put action equals click
i could have done that as well so let me
show you another example here so if i do
this
custom continue events donate now here's
my goal id
it's going to be an event so all i need
to do is put in the category in action
so donate now and then click so that's
all i have to do and that's my goal so i
can verify it okay to see if anybody's
fired it and basically that's what i
need to do to turn that event into a
goal okay so you need to set up for an
event first you need to identify the
event set it up in google tag manager
which is another platform and once
you've done that
then you have your category in action
once you have your category in action
you're again going to go into analytics
and then simply put in that category and
action into the appropriate fields to
set up your event related goal now all
events don't have to be turned into a
goal if you actually do set up an event
and use not worthy of a goal meaning
it's not a kpi or doesn't align with
your business goals well don't fret you
can always just go to behavior okay you
can always go to events
you can always go to overview and
measure your events that way so here you
can see
all of our events that are fired now we
do have this one turned into a goal so
if it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we convert
that particular event into a goal okay
if it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under behavior so the
point i'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is that
category all you need is that action and
so
so one final note on that event related
goal
just like any other goal you can add a
value okay so
if i have an event set up i can choose
to add a value here or
in google tag manager if i've assigned a
value to that event so if i go back to
the actual event in google tag manager
you can see i have a value set up for
one dollar then i can just go into
analytics and say you know what i
already have the value added so go ahead
and use the value added in google tag
manager okay so i'm going to choose yes
now if i choose no i have the option to
add the value here just like i would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related goal you can
add the value right into the tag in
google tag manager just as i've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and
measure any dimension against that
particular goal so here i can see e
newsletter sign ups by channel i can go
into another goal set here i can see
contact form submissions okay i can see
what particular channels driving contact
form submissions okay so just know that
you can align a goal against any
dimension so
if you have e-commerce you don't have to
set up for goal for that that's separate
but if you want to take a look at your
goals and analytics on its own you can
just go to conversions goals overview
here i can actually get a good sense of
how my goals are performing over a
period of time so again if i choose for
example year to date now i can see based
on the goals i've set up how many total
goal completion value which takes into
account the value we've added into these
goals okay the total conversion rate and
here i can see it broken down by the
goal i actually have set up and i can
see it by
page or i could see it by source and
media so i could see google organic is
driving the most gold completions then
google cpc direct and then i could see
some others in here as well contributing
to goals now i do want to point your
attention to another report in google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if i go to
assistic inversions i can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions i've set
up and so what do we mean by assisted
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if i have the ball and i pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point i.e the conversion but i get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under assisted
conversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if i want to hone
in on say to donate clicks only then i'm
going to be able to see what contributed
to that particular goal so there's
another report in here top conversion
pass that i think is important so after
you set up your goals you can actually
see
what channels in this particular example
help to drive conversions again this is
year-to-date so i can see all the
different combinations of channels that
work together to
contribute to a conversion so again i
can choose a specific goal or i can
choose all my goals so
those two reports are under
multi-channel funneling there's also
another report that i think is good
that's time lag meaning how long did it
actually take somebody to convert so
here you can see most of our conversions
265 year-to-date happen on the day
somebody arrived on the website but i
could see i did get some conversions a
day later two days later etc so you have
time lag top conversion pass assistant
conversions they're all under
multi-channel funneling and they're all
available after you set up at least one
goal and so if you're not sure what goal
to set up okay don't fret you can always
at least set up an engagement related
goal so that's available to you duration
pages per session you also have
destination and event tracking and
they're all available to you you have 20
available per view now if you're not
quite sure exactly what type of goal to
set up there is an option available in
analytics and that's the gallery so you
can always import a goal from the
gallery so in other words we could take
a look at
what other people
have set up in terms of goals so you
just have to click on the button import
from gallery and i'll take you to the
gallery and you'll be able to see what
are the goals others have set up how to
set up event tracking in google
analytics so welcome and let's get
started so many of you out there have a
website similar to the one i'm looking
at now this is a non-profit that i work
with i'm a foundation and
like this website and probably like your
website you probably have some
interactivity on there that
needs to be tracked for example buttons
uh if you have buttons like this one
that says donate or newsletter sign up
or there's a pdf download or
a video that needs to be you know
tracked based on the amount of people
who click on the play button so i mean
all sorts of inter activity on a website
have you ever wondered how to track that
well there is a way to track that
because by default google analytics
can't track
interactivity and engagement on your
website like you probably want to have
your website tracked so if you have
buttons and videos and things of that
nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wandering around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well
if you want events on your website and
you want data to populate under behavior
top events you're going to need to set
up event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here i'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we got a donate now bob we
got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event i
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less their timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the donating album but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one
identify what you want to track okay so
there's a lot we want to track we're
just going to use one example to start
off with and that's going to be this
donate now button okay so
this donate now button we want to track
now we have a newsletter sign up we have
facebook and and that's fine you could
track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the donate now
button let's focus on the donate now but
then we'll come back and start tracking
these other things but this is what we
want to track to start out with okay so
step one identify what you want to track
now when it comes to tracking events on
a website you want to identify those
events so we did that by choosing this
donate now button now once we identify
what we want to track we need to assign
two parameters
for that event so with event tracking
you have three parameters but one is
actually optional so you have two
mandate mandatory parameters that you
have to assign to everything you want to
track in your website and that's the
category and then the action so event
label or label is the third parameter
but again that's optional okay so
basically when we identify an event on
our website we want to assign it a
category and an action okay so why do we
want to assign it a category in action
because when we're in analytics under
behavior under events top events we
could see we have different categories
here and we have different actions we
have different labels so if i click on
any one of these dimensions i'm going to
be able to see some of the parameters
i've entered in for previous events i'm
tracking okay so the whole idea is you
want to be able to group different
events together into a category and
assign an action and assign a label to
it that's really what you're doing
you're just grouping and identifying the
events you're trying to track and so in
this case i have this donate now button
sitting in the header okay in fact i
have a lot of things sitting in the
header so
if i wanted to and i want to track all
these buttons i can create a category
called header and then if i track all
these buttons all these buttons can sit
in that same category if i wanted to or
i can create a separate category for
each of these buttons it's up to you how
you organize your categories because
basically all you're doing is giving a
name to what you're trying to track and
the name is equivalent to a category so
in this case the donate now button's
very important i'm just going to call it
category header donate now i need to
give an action to each category and so
in this case i'm just going to say click
because that's what the action is doing
it's it's somebody's taking the action
of clicking now
if it's a video and it's a play button i
can assign an action of play it's up to
you whatever you name these parameters
you just need to be organized and
methodical about what you name it that's
all and so in this case header donate
and then click okay and so that's our
category in action and so that's clearly
step two so step one identify what you
want to track step two assign a category
action and or label but remember label
is optional so if i go back into
analytics here i could see some
categories and if i click on action i
can see some actions that i've named now
step three so we've identified in step
one what we want to track we've assigned
a category in action so step three is
going into google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
google search for google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically is
what we want to
use to set up event tracking now tag
managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here is setting up an event for our
website and so i'm logged in to the same
email address i'm using for analytics
okay so now i'm in tag manager and i
want to set up my event for this donate
now but so what do i need to do well for
every event i want to set up i need to
set up a tag okay so if i go to tags i
can see i already have some tags set up
and some of these are events and so when
you actually set up a tag i recommend
having a naming convention so here you
can see any event we set up we start out
by calling it ga dash event dash
whatever it is we're trying to set up
and so in this case we want to set up a
new tag for the donate now button on our
website so we're in google tag manager
because tag manager is what's going to
fire that event so if i click on new
okay and i click on tag configuration
i'm going to choose google analytics and
then i'm going to choose event as my
track type so we want the data to show
up in google analytics and we're
tracking an event we're not tracking a
pageview we're tracking an event and so
now remember in step two you identified
what you want to call that category you
identify what you want to call that
action and you have some optional
parameters like label so first things
first header donates the name of our
category and our action is click and if
you want to add in a label and a value
so if you want to assign a value you can
if you want to add in a label you can
okay those are optional so you just need
to focus on category action and then the
last setting here that's probably worth
mentioning is a non-interaction hit okay
so
this is automatically set to false and
why is it set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if i land on this page here
and i click on that donate now button
that i'm tracking as an event and i
actually leave the site because i have
my settings set to false i want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to count a bounce
if i change it to true so from false to
true then that means it is going to be a
non interaction if somebody lands on the
page and if somebody clicks on the
button so i don't want it to be a bounce
i want it to be an interaction so
my advice is leave it set to false we're
going to choose google analytics as our
setting here this is our variable for
google analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property id and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to fall so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do
to set up the tag in google tag manager
now if somebody else is setting up the
tag for you then again you want to
revert to step two you want to be able
to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label and or
value why because you're the one that's
going to be going into google analytics
and you're the one that's going to have
to go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular act category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case i'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable
for
my label parameter and why do i want to
do that because in tag manager i have
something at my disposal called
variables and variables allow you to see
specifically things that are being
tracked so in this case i choose page
path okay so page path is a url and why
did i choose page path as my variable
for the parameter label because if
somebody does click on the header donate
button and the header donate button on
our website is on every page if i go to
the children's page i'm still going to
see that header donate button and so for
me
i want to be able to see what page
somebody clicked on that hit or donate
button and so this allows me to actually
see in google analytics
what page somebody clicked on the header
donate now button and so now if i go
back to
gtm google tag manager i have a category
i have an action and i have a label
which is a variable okay so note that in
google tag manager you have a lot of
different variables at your disposal and
variables are there to help you identify
specifically
what is being tracked so take a look at
all the variables at your disposal and
tag manager in this example i'm using
page path so now once you set up your
tag pretty straightforward again tag
types google analytics track type is
event you are assigning the category
action and or label and or value you're
changing or leaving the default in place
for non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for google
analytics which is your property id so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here i'm going to
look at a trigger i've already set up
for this particular event and so if i
click on it i'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links
i'm actually saying hey
google tag manager fire this event when
the click id equals header donate button
now it just so happens that if somebody
did click on this donate now button
they're gonna go to
another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager i
could have set the trigger to equal url
equal instead of click id i could have
said
url equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my logic for my trigger in this
case i decided to go with the click id
and so in this case that button has an
id associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click id for your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when i
actually inspect the element i can see
now the button here you can see it's
highlighted in the upper pane and in the
lower pane i can see where it's linking
to it's linking to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if i hone in a
little i could see id equals header dash
donate dash button so that's the click
id notice there's also a class i could
have set the trigger to equal this class
or again i could have set the trigger to
equal the url or the page that this
button is pointing to i could have
chosen any one of those but i decided to
go with the id so this is the id i chose
and that's the id i have in my trigger
okay so that is what's going to fire
that event so if somebody clicks on a
button that equals
header dash donate button it's going to
fire that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our events we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
google analytics so if we go to google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and
go to and test this and go to the
website so if i go here for example and
i click on amagar alumni okay so if i
click on that you can see i'm under our
family and if i click on that button and
go back to analytics and look at real
time i should be able to see this event
fire so if i click on it i'm gonna go to
network for good now if i go back to
analytics here in real time under real
time under events per second i can see
that event firing category equals header
donate the action equals click now if i
click on
the category here i can see the label
the label remember was page path and
here you can see this event fired on the
our family page which was the page i was
just on so that's one way to test to see
if your event works and in this case
analytics recognize the event so it
works it fired and so therefore it's
going to show up under behavior under
events you can go under overview or top
events okay and what am i going to look
for in this case i'm going to look for
header donate okay if i click on header
donate as my category i'm gonna be able
to see my action and if i click on
action i'll be able to see my label in
this case home page and then later on
when the data propagates in analytics
i'll be able to see under label
the page that i clicked on that hit or
donate button which is slash our family
okay the second way in which you can
test to see
if an event fires is if you preview so
if i click on preview in tag manager
okay i'm going to go into preview mode
okay and preview mode allows you to see
in analytics and tag manager and on the
website what tags are firing so here i
could see i'm in preview mode now so i'm
going to go to the website and i'm going
to refresh
and in my browser same browser i'm using
for tag manager i can see the tags that
are being fired on this page already
okay because i'm in preview mode so here
i could see
remarketing i could see page views i
could see google optimize i could see
some tags that are already firing on
this page now if i click on this button
here by holding down my shift command
and then click on that button i'll be
able to see that the tag fired in
preview mode there's my event header
donate and i can see it fired so now i
can see it fired in the preview mode so
in addition to google analytics in
preview mode i can see that that tag is
fired and i know that it's working so
there you have you have two ways to test
to see if the event fires again you have
real time and analytics okay so in real
time if you just go up to real time all
you need to do is go down to events go
to your website click on the button if
you see it firing in real time then you
know it works the second version or
second way to test your event is through
the preview mode okay if you see it
firing in preview mode then you know
it's also working okay so let's rehash
our steps first step is we want to be
able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a cta button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it ga event it's that way
you can see in your list of tags in tag
manager
what event tracking you have already set
up so when you set up your tag you set
up your trigger your trigger is based on
logic that can be a url it can be a
click id it can be a class id whatever
you want to use to fire that event and
then once you do that you want to test
it you could test it in gtm or you could
test it in google analytics if it
doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing i would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website as a best practice what i
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire it could be in
this case when somebody clicks on the
donate now button in the header you want
to put the tag name in here the type
okay then you want to record your
category action and label and then the
great thing about events is you could
turn those events into goals and that's
as simple as going back into analytics
okay so if i go into analytics and i go
to admin and i go to goals if you set up
a new goal okay all you need to do is
choose custom click continue you're
going to choose event as your goal name
and then from a naming perspective in
google analytics for your goal i would
definitely put event first and then
click on header donate okay so if i
click now continue what is my category
it's equal to head or donate my action
is click and so i can verify
to see if this is working and here i can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and i
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal and
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what i would
recommend
if the event is equal to
a kpi or business goal or it's of
importance it's something you really
want to measure okay if it's just a
click say on a facebook button i
wouldn't recommend setting that up as a
goal okay so once you've set up your
event you recorded it in your
spreadsheet it's firing you want to be
able to then go back into behavior back
into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if i choose my date range
here i can just go to year to date so
here i can see my header donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now noticed in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that
unique events are equivalent to one per
session where total events means that
somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same
session so if i go to the yama
foundation website okay i can click on
that donate now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually
in that session count it once but
accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because
in some cases users may click on the
button more than once in the same
session and so
here i can see total events unique
events and if i added a value to that
event i should be able to see it here so
if i added a dollar as an example to
this particular event because it had 164
unique events i should be able to see
164 as my value but since i see zero
that means that i did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average i have per
event so it's taking into account the
number of or the value the total value
divided by the total number of unique
pageviews or sessions and so because i
don't have value i'm not going to have
average value but here you can see
because value is optional here i can at
least see how many events or how many
clicks i receive for particular button
again it could be a video if i clicked
on this video as an example i can see
how many people actually started it i
could see the unique and the total
events and if i click on label if i have
a label assigned then i'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form etc so
what you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here i can see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in google
analytics under behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're going to go
to analyze the data
building a presence on youtube is like
fine-tuning the engine of a car to get
maximum performance
in youtube terms this means maximum
views and maximum subscribers to your
youtube channel
the instruments you have for this are
the video itself how you optimize it in
youtube and the quality of the youtube
channel you create to promote your
youtube presence
if you do get maximum performance out of
your youtube presence youtube will
reward you by giving you the opportunity
to monetize your youtube videos through
the youtube advertising platforms
by the end of this lesson you will know
how to use the new youtube studio beta
how to upload and optimize a youtube
video
how to create and optimize a youtube
channel how to create a playlist on your
youtube channel
how to make a great video
and how to monetize your youtube
presence
youtube has just launched the new
youtube studio beta
most of the youtube features like
uploading and optimizing your videos
have been brought into the new youtube
studio beta some of the features like
creating your youtube channel still need
to be accessed through the old version
of youtube studio
soon these features will be brought into
the new version which will make the old
version obsolete
when you are successful in youtube in
views and subscribers youtube will give
you the opportunity to monetize your
youtube presence
upload video on desktop
to upload a video on youtube you can do
that on the desktop and you can also do
that on the mobile
let's have a look at the desktop version
of uploading your video
so what you do is you go to the
youtube.com homepage and as long as
you're logged into your google account
you see your little login account info
here
you will then see on the left a little
camera with a plus sign and that's where
you can upload a video click on that you
can then upload your video or you can go
live streaming
so let's click on upload video
and that takes you to this screen where
you can select the file to upload or you
can drag and drop the video file
you can immediately add the settings for
published public unlisted private or you
can schedule the video
you can also import videos from your
google photos drive you can start live
streaming from here as well and there is
a new feature which is called premiere
this is where you can schedule a video
and invite your followers to watch the
video together with you and when the
schedule dates is there the video goes
public on youtube and you can watch it
together on the premiere screen
so what i'm going to do is to select the
file to upload
i just click on the finder and then i
can drag the video file here in the box
and while it is uploading i can enter
basic info of the video in this case i
will call it flower garden in malaysia
you can then give a description you can
set tags
so when the processing of the video is
complete you can pick your thumbnail and
then you click publish and you will see
that the video is live on youtube
so let's select set the thumbnail you
can see that the processing is done and
here i click to publish
the video is now live
so if i click here on the link it will
actually take me to the video and there
is my video on youtube the flower garden
in malaysia
upload video on mobile
to upload the video through your mobile
you have to use the youtube mobile app
once you start a mobile app you will see
at the top the little video icon
when i click on that icon there are
various options you can choose from i
can click record if i want to create a
video that i want to upload
i can click on go live that takes me
straight into the live streaming of my
video
or i can select a video from the video
library on my phone
so for this demo i will click on select
the video and then i can select the
video that i want to upload there are
some basic editing functions i have on
the video i'll show that in a later demo
and if i want to select this video i
click on next and as we saw with the
desktop demo i can add the name and the
description of the video and i can then
upload the video on youtube
the video is now uploaded so once the
video is ready you will see it in the
list of the videos and then obviously
you can go into the edit mode to add
more details in the title or in the
description and optimize your video
so now you see that the video is
uploaded to my list of videos on youtube
and you can also see it's just placed
above the video that i just uploaded
through the desktop version of youtube
studio beta
youtube has come up with a new version
of the interface to manage your videos
on youtube it's called youtube studio
beta
not all the features have moved to the
new version for those features that
haven't migrated yet youtube will but
direct you to the old version of the
interface or if you prefer the old
interface youtube will still give you
the option to switch back to it
but like they do with migrations to new
interfaces after a few months they will
switch the option to move back off
the new interface is very simple to use
let me show you the desktop version of
it and then i will show you the mobile
app for it
to access youtube creator studio beta
you have to be logged into your google
account and when you're on the
youtube.com homepage you click on your
little photo here on the right and then
you click on youtube studio better
that will take you to the youtube studio
beta dashboard
what you see here at the bottom left is
creator studio classic so you can still
switch back to the classic format of the
creator studio
and again if you want to switch back to
the studio beta you click here on
creator studio beta to go back to the
new interface
there are still a few features like
creating playlists translations
transcriptions that sit in the old
version
when you select those you will go back
to creator studio classic
so what's there to see on the dashboard
first of all you have your latest video
that you uploaded with some basic
information
you can go to the video analytics of
this particular video and the see
comments
you also get a list of your channel
analytics highlights
it gives you a link to your channel
analytics and your top videos of the
last two hours
and then here you see content that
youtube presents like youtube news and
information about creator insider
here they give you additional videos
where you can learn about how to use
youtube
it will also show you some ideas on how
to improve your channel
or in this case help navigating the new
interface
here on the left you have your main menu
you can go into your videos analytics
check out the comments go to the
transcriptions of your videos and other
features
and then down here you have your
settings and link back to the creator
studio classic
so if we click here on videos you have a
list of all the videos that you have
uploaded on youtube
it's much friendlier and much better
accessible than in the old creator
studio classic
so here you see the two videos that
we've just uploaded
and then here you see what is the
visibility of the video and the date
that you published it
you'll also see how many views how many
comments and how many likes or dislikes
a really good new feature here is the
inline editing as we call this if i want
to quickly change the title or the
description of this video i don't have
to open the video and click on edit
i can actually click it here i can
actually change it here inline so
there's a few things i can do in line
edit the title and the description get a
link promote for advertising
download or delete the video
so if i say edit title and description
and add in consoles and then i'm here
i'm just clicking and then i'm just
clicking save and you see it will
automatically change the title so this
is a very easy and convenient new
feature i can click here and see the
video directly on youtube as well
and here you see the analytics so when
you click on analytics
it takes you to the general overview of
the analytics where you can see what's
the activity and what's the views that
we got what are the top videos that
people are watching
what is the real time activity happening
on your videos
and then you can see here about the
viewers the interest of the viewers the
built-in audience and how to earn
revenue
so we'll get back into the analytics
later but at least here you have an idea
of what you can get from the analytics
you can then check out the comments that
you had on the various videos
you can look at the transcription files
that you had for your videos and which
ones have been published and then it
takes you to your other features as well
in the settings you can set things like
the currency that you're using what your
default experience is for the classic or
for the new youtube studio beta
you can have your channel settings like
the name of your channel the keywords
for your channel and the country for
your channel
you can check on your community you can
add filters you can look at the
moderators and approved users that you
can add and you can look at other
settings like your advanced channel
settings or channel branding
but you will access these through the
creator studio classic
so this gives you a short overview of
the creator studio beta
using youtube studio on a mobile
to access youtube studio on your mobile
you have to download the mobile app and
then when you open the mobile app you
could almost like a similar experience
as on the desktop
it starts with your dashboard
this gives you an overview of your
analytics of the last 28 days the last
videos that you uploaded the last
comments that you received and the total
number of subscribers you have to your
channel
to access the menu you tap on the
hamburger button on the top left and
this gives you a similar list of options
that you have on the desktop version you
can go to your videos you can check your
playlist check the comments go to your
analytics and change your youtube
settings
when i click on videos it gives you a
list of all the videos that you uploaded
for each video you see the number of
views the number of comments the number
of likes the number of dislikes
you can sort the videos by most recent
most viewed and you can look at all the
videos you can filter by draft by public
unlisted and private videos
the view from your mobile is very easy
and it's simple to browse through all
the videos that you've uploaded on your
mobile you can look at your playlist and
make some changes to your playlist
and then you can also check the comments
on the videos
if you click on analytics you get more
detailed stats about your videos
you can see your overview any revenue
that you would have made you can look at
analytics for your playlist and it also
gives you analytics of any interactive
content that you have used in your
videos like click throughs or cards
let's go back to the dashboard to
complete this demo
this gives you an idea of what you can
manage through the youtube studio app
now that your video is uploaded on
youtube there are two things that you
may want to do first you may want to
edit the video like trimming the
beginning or the end or adding some
special effects to the video and video
editing mode it's a very basic video
editing so it doesn't give you all the
functionality like for instance imovie
or adobe premiere but it does the thing
for you if you want to make some quick
changes to the video
you can trim the video you can add music
or play with the sound of the video you
can add an end screen to the video and
you could blur faces for instance on the
video these are basic functions but they
work really well
let's have a look first at the sound
if i click here on audio and i open the
audio library that youtube has it gives
you a full library of royalty-free music
tracks that you can add to your video so
for instance i can select hear the noise
i can add that to my video when it's too
loud you have a slider where you can say
favorite to the original audio so now
you hear my voice in the background in
today's video blog let's go back now and
close this
you can also add an end screen to the
video and there are a number of
templates you can choose from
an end screen will show during the last
20 seconds of the video you can show a
playlist or a subscribe button or you
can have reference to two different
videos or two videos or playlists so
different formats that you can choose
from
let's pick the two video template
when i click on apply then here you
would see how that will show in the last
20 seconds of the video when i play the
video you see that i haven't added any
video but this is how it would show as
an end screen in your video
and then you can add blur to a video as
well you can blur faces or you can blur
specific areas in your video
this is all i will be showing you on
editing your video as i said before it's
a basic video editor but if you want to
do some quick editing on your video
before you publish it then this is a
really good tool to do just that
so the next thing you want to do is to
optimize your video for youtube search
and for google search so
how do you go about it
when you select a video let's take this
one epic fail how to ruin your life on
an easyjet flight
you click on the video and that takes
you to the basic optimization screen
there are a few things that are
important here first of all the title
this title epic fail how to ruin your
life on an easyjet flight is an
interesting title it tells people
there's something happening here
it's very important to use a word like
epic fail people like seeing videos with
epic fails so remember
title is extremely important
there are two reasons why people decide
to watch a video on youtube number one
is the title number two is the thumbnail
and that's the next thing you want to
optimize
youtube will pick a few thumbnails based
on your video but you can also upload
your own thumbnail
the third part is also important the
description of your video
it's important that the description of
the video is in line with the title and
what the viewer is going to see
make sure you use keywords that are
relevant to the video and to your
business
and here you can add tags tags are key
for the search it helps people to find
your video based on the tags that you've
set
here you can see the public url of your
video and here you can decide on the
visibility of your video do you want
your video to be public private or
unlisted
unlisted video will be public but they
won't show up in the search
here you can select the playlist that
you want the video to be part of
you can assign a video to the various
playlists that you have on your channel
this is where you can create cards in
the end screen in the video editing demo
we looked at how you can add end screens
and how you can add video cards to your
video if you click on it then you see
the editing mode and here are the
different types of cards that you can
add
like a video or a playlist or a channel
or you could even create a poll where
you encourage viewers to participate
so you just click on the create and then
you can pick a video from the list that
shows up
that video will actually show up and
then here you see where the video card
will appear
so if we go to the beginning of the
video and we would click play then here
you see the suggested video popping up
so you can now save the changes and go
back to the editor
so these are the basic settings for the
optimization of your video and you can
also go to the advanced settings there's
a lot more that you can add in the
advanced settings
you can add the recording date the
location of the video and you can also
add the license and right ownership of
the video
if you are part of the commercial
network with youtube you can select a
syndication where you want your videos
to show
you can select a category for your video
the language and the caption
certification when there may be
television fcc regulations regarding
closed captions
you can also upload your subtitles and
closed captioning
youtube will actually create subtitles
for you and then you can check that
later
it is not 100 accurate but at least it's
a good starting point for your subtitles
finally you can set things like allowing
comments and ratings and enabling age
restrictions as well
you can allow people to embed the video
and you can also tick whether the video
contains paid promotion like product
placement sponsorships or endorsements
so lots of things that you can set in
the optimization and when you're happy
with it you just click save
google and youtube will then include all
these settings in the indexing of the
video and the better you do all this the
more likely your video will show up in
the search
so let's go to google and check this
epic fail video
we have a good thumbnail and a good
title
if you go to google and search for epic
fail easyjet for instance then you see
that the video immediately shows up here
in google and that's obviously what you
want for your videos
you want them to show up high in the
videos or in the image section of the
search results page
and if you do the same search in youtube
then you would like your video to show
up as well and you see here immediately
it shows up as the first video
so this is all there is to optimizing
your video
another important part and we briefly
touched on this are the subtitles and
the transcriptions that you may want to
add to your video
first you want to check if youtube
created transcriptions for your video
take this video blog for example if i
select other features you see here
translation and transcription
the automated transcription from youtube
has not been brought into the new studio
beta so i need to go to the old studio
of youtube
so i click here on the old classic
creator studio translation and
transcription and then here you see the
link to the published transcript file i
haven't put these in this is something
that youtube will do when it's a video
that's worth transcribing
you could copy the text so you can
download it and then use that for a blog
post or for the show notes of your
podcast
you can also add language and you can
set the transcription on published or
draft
very useful features and very important
to make sure that your video is
optimized
creating a youtube channel
to create a youtube channel you have to
go to your youtube home page and then
you click on the little photo here that
you will see when you logged into your
google account
when you click on the settings it will
take you to the screen where you will be
able to click on the button see all my
channels or create a new channel
so let's click on this and now you will
see the screen where you can enter the
name of your channel
and in this case i'm going to call it
riad for russia i click create and you
will then get to the page where you can
start customizing your channel
if i click on customize channel i see
the blank version of the youtube channel
where you can add your logo your channel
art and where you can add a channel
description
so let's start with adding a short
channel description
welcome to my youtube channel of riyadh
for russia
when we're done with that we can add the
logo to do that you click on the little
pencil icon it will actually take you to
the brand page of your google account
click on edit and you can upload a photo
click on upload photo and here we are
going to upload this image
once it has uploaded the photo you can
play a bit with the size of it you can
move it up a bit if you want so i'm
going to move it so i only show the
mosaic
i click done and then my brand page has
been updated with the image
if i now go back to the youtube page and
i do a refresh you will see that the
image has been added to the youtube page
i can do the same for the channel art
click on the channel art you need to be
aware that you don't have a lot of space
to play with for your image so you need
to make sure that you have a horizontal
photo that will show enough of what you
want to cover in the banner
a nice feature is that it will show you
how it will look on the desktop how it
will look on the tv and how it will look
on the mobile
and if you're not happy with it you can
adjust the crop a little so i can zoom
in and then move it up
so at least i see a little bit of the
mountains and the bit of the mosque on
the photo
when i'm happy with it i click select
and then you will see that you have
uploaded the banner
and you are now ready to start
optimizing your youtube channel
checking the youtube channel settings
so the first thing you want to check
when you start optimizing your channel
is your settings of the channel
you can access the channel settings by
clicking on the little cartwheel on the
top right click on that and this will
take you to the basic privacy settings
you can keep your videos private
subscriptions private your saved
playlist private you can customize the
layout of your channel and you can show
the discussion tab
so you can basically switch all these
options on or off and you can also
translate your channel info
the basic settings you can find on this
little screen but there are more options
in the account settings and in the
advanced settings
so let's look first at the options in
the account settings
this is where you can look at what
you're going to share on youtube
you can look at your connected apps for
instance in this section
do you want any other apps to connect
with your youtube
you can also set how to connect your tv
to the youtube channel you can connect
your youtube to a particular tv device
and you can look at your billings and
payments and your playback and
performance
this is where you can control your video
experience you can show annotations and
in video notifications you can also set
that the captions are always on or when
that's available show automatic captions
by speech recognition
you can also set the notifications for
your youtube so you can receive emails
about your activities if you want
updates from youtube or notifications
around channel subscriptions and other
notifications like recommended videos
if i go back to the main channel page
and i'm going back into the settings i
can then also go into the advanced
settings for my channel
in the advanced settings i can check the
country that i'm based i can set
keywords for my channels i can disable
interest-based ads and i can link my
adwords account i can activate channel
recommendations and display the
subscriber account this is also where
you can integrate your youtube channel
with your google analytics so look a bit
further up here i can see the branding
options that i have so i can add a
watermark to my channel videos
i can also set defaults for uploading my
videos this can be quite handy if you
have standard text that you want to use
for every video
and i can set some standard tags for
instance this can be helpful when you
upload lots of videos so the standard
defaults are already set and then
finally here you see the status and
features of your channel this is where
you have all the different options that
you have with your channel and you can
check what the status is the different
elements that are enabled and elements
that you are eligible for and the
elements that you are ineligible for
for example we're not eligible for
monetization because we haven't signed
up for it and we haven't passed the
requirements for this
so for all these things we can see
whether we have it enabled whether we
are eligible or whether we are
ineligible
and that's all there is to the settings
so let's go back now to the channel by
clicking on the logo and we can then
start looking at the optimization of our
channel
how to optimize your youtube channel to
start customization and optimization of
your youtube channel you have to go to
the standard channel page and click
customize channel
here you see the structure and elements
of your youtube channel
an important feature is that you can
look at your channel as yourself
as a new visitor or as a returning
visitor
you can set a video at the top of your
youtube channel which will change
whether you're a new visitor or a
returning visitor
but let's first look at the different
elements of your youtube page that you
can change
you can add videos to your channel you
can add playlists to your channel and
you can connect with other channels
you can manage your discussions and you
can put more info in your about section
this is also where you can link to your
other social media pages
these will show on your channel banner
and you can feature other channels that
you would like to promote on your
youtube channel
so you start with adding some videos to
your channel click on videos and you see
this channel has no video yet
remember how we uploaded a video in
youtube by clicking this little plus
icon and we say upload video we can then
select the video that we want to upload
let's take this short video add some
basic settings and set some tags
once the video is processed you can then
publish it on your channel page
if you go back to your channel
you will see that the video has been
added so that's how you can upload
videos to your channel
you can then look at playlists here you
can add a playlist to your channel a
playlist is a group of videos around a
particular topic and then you can
feature those playlists
as chapters in your youtube channel
it makes it very easy to organize your
videos
to create a playlist i click on new
playlist i give it a title marrakesh in
this case
additive i click create and then your
playlist has been created
then you need to add videos to your
playlist
if you go back to the video and play it
to get into editing mode then in the
settings of the video i can say to which
playlist i want to add this video
i select a playlist that i just created
and click done and i save it and then i
have added a video to my playlist
so if i now go back to my youtube
channel i can click on playlists and
there is my marrakesh playlist and it
currently has one video
i can add channels so i can link to any
other channel i may have
can manage my discussions and i can
manage my about page in this section as
well
i can activate business inquiries so
people can send me an email through my
channel
i can specify my location and i can add
my social media links who will then show
up in my youtube channel banner
you can also add featured channels for
instance i want to add the social media
examiner youtube channel i can add that
and i can click done and then it will
show in the featured channels
if i'm happy with the settings i can go
back to my channel and then you see what
we've done to the channel right now
we've got our first video we have our
featured channel and we have our
playlist
so this is how i can optimize my youtube
channel
one more thing
i would like to show you if i click
customize channel
then i can see here the featured content
which will show up on the channel for
either returning visitors or new
visitors
if i click here on feature content and
then i pick for instance the video that
i just uploaded then this is how it will
show
i can add a heading for this content so
for example i can say feature
presentation and i click save
and now you see i have a feature video
for the returning visitors i can also do
this for new visitors i can create a
channel trailer for instance i pick this
video and then i click save and that's
how it will show for new visitors so
these are the basic things you need to
look at when you want to optimize your
youtube channel
youtube channel views and subscribers
now that we know how to edit and
optimize your videos and your youtube
channel we will turn our attention to
how to grow views and subscribers on
your channel
first there is your channel
optimize your channel page write a
compelling channel description
use a great channel logo and a banner
and create a channel tagline
then there are your videos make an
awesome channel trailer video publish
long videos of 10 minutes and more
promote videos in your end screen add a
branded watermark and add a subscribe
button and end your videos with a strong
call to action
thirdly there is your channel management
reply to every comment and hard grade
content
and finally promote your channel
embed youtube videos in blog posts and
promote your channel in ebooks webinars
presentations and lead magnets doing all
these things right will certainly help
you in growing views and subscriptions
to your channel
tubebuddy is a great tool that can help
you in growing your video views and your
channel subscriptions
it's a chrome browser extension and it
adds a layer of functionality on top of
your youtube channel
it has features that focus on seo
promotion and analytics
and it also tracks the video rankings of
your videos but also the videos of your
competitors
it's a great tool to find keywords for
your videos
and you can go to your competitor video
and check what tags they have set and
use these as keywords for your videos
it also helps you in publishing videos
on your channel
you can schedule videos to be published
and added to playlists you can make bulk
updates to your videos including the
descriptions
and it also helps you to create
eye-catching thumbnails
factors that make a great video of
course it's not only the optimization of
the video that makes the video
successful it is also about the video
itself
done well you can use your iphone to
make highly professional cinema quality
videos that are being watched by
millions as insane a feature movie from
film director stephen soderbergh proved
let me give you some tips how to make
great video think about composition
point of view and lighting first
composition is about how you place the
different elements in the scene put some
thought into this
use the rule of thirds and focus on
people's eyes i'll explain the rule of
thirds shortly point of view is the
angle you are using of the lens of the
camera in relation to the subject be
creative with this use a low angle or a
high angle and change these regularly
lighting can make the difference to a
good or a bad video always be aware of
your light source and also know that
daylight is the best light source there
is but different times during the day
can give different shadow effects in the
video for instance noon sunlight creates
unflattering shadows whereas a cloudy
day can produce more softer lights using
the right equipment is also very
important in shooting great videos
obviously your phone can fulfill most of
the camera requirements like shooting
video and recording sounds and it will
give you an acceptable level of quality
make sure the resolution settings on
your phone are on 4k or 1080 hd and it's
set at 24 30 or 60 frames per second
avoid zooming avoid backlights and use
both hands if you want to up the quality
to professional then you may want to use
a high quality dslr camera an additional
gear like a tripod and a microphone
the rode lavalier microphone is a great
mic that you can attach to your iphone
and your color
it gives excellent quality sound and you
can overlay that sound over the sound
file of your video earlier i promised
you i was going to explain the rule of
thirds they are part of the basic rules
of composition the rule of thirds is a
compositional rule that suggests
dividing the image into thirds and
placing the subject on one of those
sides instead of in the center
it is one of the most important
composition techniques used by
professional photographers
but there are others as well for
instance using balance and symmetry in
your video or apply leading lines in
your video
these lines direct the viewer to a
particular section of the screen finally
as i mentioned before a simple rule is
to focus on the eye it gives a point of
focus
monetizing your youtube channel
there are various ways that you can make
money with youtube but it depends on how
strong your subscriber base is and how
many views you get on your channel
if you are qualified then you can
participate in google's adsense program
which means that you can get revenue
from ads being placed before
or during your videos when people watch
them
this works very well and many publishers
on youtube get a significant revenue
stream through this channel
you can also try to get sponsorships for
your channel this can take the form of
brand or product sponsorship for which
you will get paid
you can also look into affiliate
marketing with this you can advertise
products from your affiliate partners on
your channel and you would get a
percentage of the sales that comes in
through your channel
and finally if people like your videos
then they may commission you to make
videos for them
as i mentioned before you need to have a
strong channel to qualify for google's
adsense program which means you need to
have at least 4 000 watch hours in the
previous 12 month and 1 000 subscribers
to sign up for adsense you need to go to
the old version of creative studio and
click on channel and monetization
you can set the monetization preferences
and which video you want to run the ads
with
if you qualify google will then approve
your request and you are ready to start
earning money with youtube here are the
key takeaways of this lesson youtube has
recently launched a new version of
youtube studio called youtube studio
beta getting views and subscribers on
your youtube channel is based on your
video the quality and optimization of
your channel and how you promote your
channel
composition
lighting and point of view are important
contributors to the quality of your
video
and you can make money with youtube
through advertising sponsorships and
commissioned work welcome everyone this
is rob sanders and welcome to
today's webinar youtube advertising so
today we're going to talk about youtube
advertising so thanks again i'm rob
sanders and i'm with simply learn and
let's get started and we're going to do
a little role playing here and let's
just say you're an advertiser and you're
not sure where you want to advertise
your products you have a product that
you want the entire world to see well
if you want to advertise your products
and let's just say you have some really
good video of your product that you want
to get out there really there's no other
place to look to than one place in
particular
is youtube hence the reason why we're
doing this webinar because today we're
going to talk about
all things youtube advertising and for
those that don't know youtube is owned
by google and a lot of what you're going
to do is advertise on youtube via google
ads so today we're going to talk about
youtube advertising and we're going to
focus somewhat on google ads so buckle
up and let's get started with why is
advertising on youtube a good idea so
why is it a good idea well if you
haven't been on youtube of late you
should check it out youtube.com and just
take a look at the vastness of videos
that are on youtube now youtube is a
video platform but if it was a search
engine it'd be the second largest search
engine in the world only behind its
parent company google so it's a very big
platform with a lot of videos and hence
there's some good search functionality
on youtube so you can look at it as a
search engine there's 1.9 billion and
growing logged in visitors on a monthly
basis so you have a lot of people that
go to youtube and watch videos on a
daily basis okay that has local versions
in more than 91 countries so if you're
an advertiser who's focusing on a
specific market or you're in a different
market with a different language you
have 91 different options to hone in on
okay so a little bit more about youtube
here and why is advertising on youtube a
good idea well most youtube users are on
mobile almost 70 almost three-quarters
of those that you use youtube use it
from their mobile device which is
staggering but not so staggering
considering most people in the world now
have mobile
phones or mobile devices and most people
use their mobile devices for multiple
reasons and
watching videos is one of those reasons
so mobile advertisements receive viewer
attention 83 of the time so what do we
mean by that well on youtube we have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
people who are watching those videos so
if a lot of people are engaged in
watching a video on youtube and you're
advertising on that particular video
well
then you're going to get some attention
and so that attention has to be in the
80 percentile okay so a lot of people
are going to you know pay somewhat
attention to your ad and it's no secret
video ads have proven to be more
effective and engaging creating greater
impact and and that's just not on
youtube i mean that's that's on facebook
that's on other platforms like twitter
instagram so video is an engaging way to
communicate it's a lot better than
traditional text it's a lot better than
say a display banner because it's
engaging people are going to watch what
you have to say and if they like it
they're going to share they're going to
comment on it they're going to subscribe
there's a lot of things that people can
do when it comes to video advertising so
video helps expand your digital reach so
basically if you are running those text
ads and display ads well having video
kind of adds some more arsenal to
your advertising portfolio so to speak
so if you're running just those text ads
and banners that's fine that's great
because you can reach a lot of people
but having video just adds another piece
of the element and because video's so
engaging you might find that even for
yourself if you're advertising different
types of ads video display or text
you'll find that you know video does
have really really expansive reach to a
particular audience and the other thing
here about youtube is youtube helps to
find a relevant audience for your ads
using advanced targeting so just like
anything else that we've talked about
here at simply learn when it comes to
advertising whether that be facebook or
instagram
or google ads we can really hone in on
our audience here and that's really
important and we'll get to that later
because when you're advertising you want
to make sure your ad is in front of the
right people and if we're talking about
video we're talking about high
engagement if you have your video in
front of a really relevant audience then
chances of that audience engaging can be
even greater and then youtube and video
ads themselves provide it provides a
situation that can be customized to
fulfill your marketing goals and so what
do we mean by that so
basically youtube allows us some
additional features where we can
customize our ads so meaning if our
marketing goal is to just get our ad in
front of millions of people well that's
not a problem if our marketing goals get
people who you know we want to convert
well we can customize our marketing goal
towards that as well so just like on
facebook and some of these other
platforms we've talked about youtube is
no different and so we could set
specific marketing goals uh for our
video ads some other good pointers to
talk about here with youtube so with
youtube just like on google ads we can
enable running cost effective campaigns
and what do i mean by cost effective
well meaning we can really watch our
budget we can measure how how much it
costs for 1 000 people to watch our
video or we can measure how much it
costs for
somebody to click on our video ad we can
measure the cost of when somebody clicks
on our video ad and converts how much
does that cost in us so you can really
run cost effective campaigns even on
youtube and youtube helps determine how
successful your ads with advanced
analytics so not only do we have
analytics on the youtube side of the
house but we also have analytics on
google ads and so we can really hone in
and use both platforms to really figure
out exactly how our ads are performing
and then ads that have reported a 500
growth in views of the channel's other
videos so basically you can see growth
in views just by advertising on youtube
so let's get in now to what are the
types of ads you can run on youtube so
we discussed all the benefits of youtube
we can go on for another two or three
hours because there are plenty of
benefits but i think you get the point
of you know youtube being a place where
you can grow measure and reach a custom
audience so you're already sold on
youtube now let's talk about those types
of ads you want to run on youtube so
depending on what goal you want to
achieve with your ads there are
different types of ad formats available
on youtube so our first set of ads
evolve around building brand awareness
and ad recalls so if you're in the
business of promoting your
product or your brand or your service
then these are the type of ads you want
to run on youtube building brand
awareness and ad recalls because what it
does is it's really going to get your ad
out there in front of thousands and
millions of people lots of eyeballs lots
of impressions impressions are the
number of times your ad was seen so ads
centered around brand awareness are
really ads that are going to put you out
there in front of a large number of
people with the goal of potentially
attracting new customers and ensuring
your brand is on top of their mind so
top of funnel brand awareness is always
introducing the brand getting people
familiar with the brand and getting them
to your website so that you can
introduce them to your brand and service
and product so that's the whole idea
behind the ads we're going to introduce
behind the goal building brand awareness
and add recalls so let's take a look at
what those are so we can build brand
awareness and add recalls so we call
these these types of ads trueview for
reach okay so when we say trueview
meaning our ad is going to appear in
front of a video and we want to make
sure that that adds in front of a lot of
people so skippable ads that will enable
your brand to reach as many people in
your target audience as possible at the
most efficient price so the whole idea
is we're trying to build brand awareness
then we could set it up on youtube so
that our ad appears before other videos
and that's going to ensure that our ad
is going to show up in a lot of places
based on the audience we target and if
we can get our ad in front of
a lot of people a lot of targeted people
at an efficient price then how can you
say no to that so these ads are
skippable have an open video length and
their bidding is based on cost per 1000
impressions so cost per 1000 impressions
cpm means that you're paying youtube for
every 1000 people that looked at your ad
okay so that's what cost per 1000
impressions or cpm means that you're
paying youtube not when somebody clicks
on your ad but when one thousand
impressions occurred an impression is
when somebody looks at your ad and so
that's where you're going to be paying
youtube you're going to be paying them
for 1 000 views or impressions basically
okay so the ads are skippable but they
have an open video length and it's based
on eyeballs so that's the whole goal
there when it comes to brand awareness
you want to go with a cpm model that
ensures you're getting your ads in front
of
lots of people to accumulate impressions
and pay by impressions so this is what
the ad looks like and now we're going to
talk about the type 2 ad that you can
run on youtube and we call these bumper
ads so they're non-skippable ads with
which you can share your brand's message
in six seconds to drive reach and impact
so we've all seen these videos before
and i'm going to share an example with
you here when you're on youtube you
really can't get to that video that you
really want to watch until you watch a
few seconds
of that video ad and so that's what
these bumper ads are they allow you to
really make sure that your ad is in
front of that target audience still it's
still paid by impressions but you know
that your ad is going to run for a few
seconds and the idea behind that is
really you want to get your message out
there and it really does help to drive
reach and impact and so let's take an
exam look at an example on youtube with
a bumper ad looks like so here's an
example of a bumper ad on youtube and
it's only six seconds but this example
it's pretty popular on youtube it's uh
been viewed a lot and we're just gonna
take a quick look at this video here
this video has six seconds but the whole
point is to really look at the ads
purpose and so if we hit play
[Music]
so that was it that was the ad six
seconds long it appears in in front of
other videos as an advertisement and the
whole point of these bumper ads is
really you have to
get your message out there quickly
because the video is going to start and
you want to really make sure that your
message is being delivered and you want
to keep in this case maybe keep users
guessing as to what it is and so this is
why it's a highly effective ad you know
you got a diver jumping off a diving
board into a pool that is basically
drying up over a period of time and so
for curiosity the old saying is
curiosity kills the cat a lot of people
are probably going to click on that ad
to figure out what is the subject what
are we all talking about here and really
the point of the the video was to bring
awareness about global warming but
that's it that's a six second bumper ad
example and you really if you're going
to run bumper ads you want to make sure
that you get your message out there so
it has to have really high impact okay
so again they're non-skippable they have
to be of six seconds and their bidding
is based on again cost 1000 impressions
so
it gives you a a chance to get that ad
out there in front of a lot of people
again you're paying on a cpm model
you're paying google for every 1000
impression okay so that's could be 1 000
different eyeballs looking at that ad so
if it's high impact you know if it's
non-skippable then chances are you can
get you know some clicks some some
eyeballs over to your youtube channel or
to your landing page on your website so
let's take a look at this one from
alaska airlines better yet let's take a
look at this example from airbnb i found
it to be a little bit more impactful
than the alaska air one so let's take a
look at this example actually so
we went on vacation with a tow dipper
and left with a cannonballer
okay so high impact ad great ad by
airbnb really impactful we went on
vacation kids playing you have your logo
on the bottom right corner of the video
and you know it gets people excited
about travel so similar to the alaska
airlines which we didn't look at this
one is just as good high impactful you
know getting people to
you know react within six seconds isn't
exactly a very easy thing to do so
you gotta make sure these videos really
resonate within the time frame that you
have so let's take a look at
type 3 here so
we're talking about reservation of 15 to
20 seconds so these particular ads can
span up to 20 seconds to increase reach
and make a lasting impression so unlike
the bumper ads which are six seconds
long these reservation ads tend to run a
few seconds longer up to 20 seconds okay
so they're also non-skippable and like i
said can be up to 20 seconds embedding
is based on a fixed cpm and what do we
mean by fixed cpm well if you're bidding
on a regular cpm model meaning that
you're paying google for every 1 000
impressions that number could be
variable what you pay google in this
case the fixed cpm is fixed at a certain
rate it could be you know ten dollars
for every one thousand impressions
twenty dollars it really depends on
where you're advertising and who else is
advertising so let's take a look at some
examples of a reservation ad on youtube
up to 15 to 20 seconds long so here is
an example of a 15 second ad
also called a trueview ad so you can see
this ad is going to run for about 15
seconds before the video actually plays
it's non-skippable and so let's just
play this ad
who can paint the corners is known as a
red brand at gmc we get that
everyone loves that kind of
precision
this is gmc
okay so you could see the ad itself
ran a little bit longer than your
traditional or your six second
non-skippable version and
the 15 second you know allows you to get
you know more of the message out there
still high impactful but allows us to
get the message out there um with a
little bit longer of a video
and that's non-skippable so it's so
going to run for its entirety up to
15-20 seconds before
the video actually starts playing so
let's now turn our attention to the
fourth type of ad you can run on youtube
and that four type is an outstream video
ad and so these ads are going to reach
users wherever they're watching
regardless of the site or application
it's the whole point of the out stream
we want to be able to get our ads out
there regardless of the site or
application okay so these ads are also
non-skippable and they can be 15 to 20
seconds long and their bidding is based
on viewable cost per 1000 impressions
and so what do we mean by viewable cost
per 1000 impressions what we mean by
viewable cost per 1000 impressions is
basically
if you're paying for ad impressions
measured as viewable you you can use
this model and basically what that means
that an ad is counted as viewable
when fifty percent of your ad shows on
screen for one second or longer or plays
continuously for two seconds or longer
so there's some criteria about the
viewable but you're definitely paying
for impressions you're just paying when
those impressions showcase the ad 50
or longer or for one second or longer
for you know other type of video ads or
it plays continuously for two seconds or
longer for video ads so if it plays in
short if it plays for longer than two
seconds then you're going to pay for
that impression and so that's going to
count as an impression and that's
viewable for 1000 impressions so
if you get your basically your ad to
show for two seconds or longer then then
that's going to count as an impression
so for example with the viewable cpm for
example if you bid on 1000 viewable
impressions and you pay for impressions
that are measured as viewable an ad is
counted as viewable again when 50 of
your ad shows on the screen for one
second or longer for display ads and two
seconds or longer for video ads so uh so
that's basically what it's about so
really the key number here with viewable
cpm is two seconds or longer that's the
difference between regular 1000
impressions cpm and viewable 1000
impressions vcpm so let's talk about the
next type of ad format you can run on
youtube and the next one is masted and
so masted is unique in that basically
they only run for 24 hours okay so and
they run on youtube's home page so you
can imagine the amount of reach that you
can have by
advertising on youtube's home page so
they're highly visible okay they can run
on multiple devices desktop app mobile
and basically these ads sit at the top
of youtube's home page so they're fixed
cost per day pricing involved and so the
best thing to do is to contact youtube
if you're interested in advertising on
youtube's homepage so that's the
masthead advertising and basically these
ads are non-skippable they have an open
length and again their bidding is based
on fixed price per day so here's an
example of what the masthead looks like
on the home page so you can see here
this is that gmc ad okay you can see
that they have a video supported with a
banner and you know call to action out
there and so what youtube is actually
experimenting with are you know
different ways for advertisers to buy
masthead ads okay so
it's you know these ads are very
prominent so
it's it's basically youtube is now
offering the option uh to buy masthead
ads on a cost per 1000 impression basis
so they're playing around with that cost
format so just keep in mind that
this is a recent change by youtube so
traditionally it's cost per day but now
they're actually offering the option for
advertisers to buy a masthead ad on a
cpm basis so just keep that in mind you
do you do have the option here so at the
end of the day if you're interested in
math says ads and having your ads show
up on youtube's home page for 24 hours i
would still contact google and ask them
about hey i want to pay costco 1000
impressions so youtube is actually
offering up that option on pricey model
so the second set of ads we're going to
focus in on are
centered around the strategy of growth
consideration and interest and the whole
idea behind growth consideration and
interest is really we want to get our
ads in front of people who could be
potential customers but we want to
influence them okay we want to influence
them at a point in time when they when
we think they're going to be most
receptive to our message so that really
means getting our ad out in front of the
right audience at the right time because
the message we put out there is going to
be centered around you know getting them
to not only take notice of our brand
potentially take action so it's moving
our audience a little further down that
funnel so really growth consideration
and interest it's all about
placing your ad your message in front of
that potential customer when you think
they're going to be most receptive to
the messaging you're putting out so
that's what growth consideration and
interest is so let's go back and look at
uh let's talk a little bit more about
those trueview ads so
trueview ads are one of the most popular
ways of advertising on youtube so if
you're interested in
you know getting growth getting leads
getting conversions you might want to
think about some trueview ads because
basically these ads can run before
during or after videos on youtube or you
can run them on video partner sites and
applications again if you're interested
in driving not just brand awareness but
you know clicks to your site so if
you're interested in driving impact for
your brand of products you might want to
focus on the trueview and stream ads
again these are the traditional ads
you've probably
seen before on youtube that run before
during or after a video and these ads
are skippable so you're likely to have
seen the skip add uh call to action
button they have an open video length
and their bidding is based on cost per
view so you're paying when somebody
views your ad and so what what's what
does that mean cost per view well let's
break that down cost for review bidding
is the default way to set the amount
you'll pay for a trueview video ad so
when are you actually paying well you're
paying when somebody views your video
and
but there's a threshold here so a view
is counted on youtube when someone
watches 30 at least 30 seconds of your
video ad or if it's shorter than 30
seconds and let's just say it's 20
seconds then that's going to be
considered a view so 30 seconds is the
number here you need to be concerned
about when you're running a cost per
view model so if you have a video that's
one minute long and they watch 30
seconds it's considered a view and
that's what you're going to pay you're
going to pay cost per view so that's
what the cost per view model is and
that's the really the default model with
trueview ads whether that be before the
video during the video or after the
video it's it's cost per view so let's
talk about the other type of trueview ad
and that's the true view discovery and
so basically what trueview discovery is
is your ads are placed in youtube search
results next to related videos or on the
youtube homepage so you're getting your
ad discovered more or less you know
throughout youtube and including the
youtube home page so here's an example
of what that looks for looks like and so
let's jump over to youtube and take a
look at that so if i do type in let's
just say surfing i may scroll down and i
may see some ads i may not see some ads
so basically if you see an ad it's going
to have ad next to it and so that's when
you know your ad is being discovered on
youtube and so here in this example we
don't see any ads showing up here so
remember
those trueview discovery ads are going
to have something with the ad next to
them that way you know it's an
advertisement
and they're going to be found in the
search results
on youtube's homepage or
any page where you're actually searching
okay third set of ad types center around
driving action and so the whole point of
driving action is getting that potential
customer to actually take action on the
ad that they see so in the case of
videos we're gonna have some call to
action stronger call to action to get
these folks over to the website to
purchase or download or you know sign up
for a newsletter or do something you
want them to do in terms of your
business model so if your business model
is selling a product then the whole
point of driving action on your ad is
getting them to buy your product we want
so the whole point of driving action is
making it easier for customers to take
meaningful actions that you can measure
so the ads we're going to introduce are
centered around getting potential
customers to take action okay so that's
what driving action is further down the
funnel and getting folks to react to
your ad so that they can take the action
that's aligned with your business
talking about true view ads now and so
again these ads discovery can show up on
search results on youtube's homepage you
have your traditional in-stream trueview
ads where they show up before during or
after and then here you have trueview
for action and so these trueview for
action ads are video ads to drive any
action that's important to your business
so again it goes back to that marketing
strategy so the ads we looked at on
early on were about impressions so a lot
of the cost models for a lot of the ad
types were cost per 1000 impression and
notice now that you know it's it's now
cost per view for trueview ads and you
want to be on a different model when
your marketing strategy is more aligned
with getting people to take action
that's important to your business for
example shopping or buying something or
getting a quote or or downloading
something so if that's your marketing
goal you want to go with a true view for
action if that's what's important your
business because these ads are intended
to get users to interact with a
clickable button that leads to your site
so that's the whole idea behind trueview
for action type ads okay so these are
skippable they have an open video length
and their bidding is based on cost per
acquisition so cpa different cost models
so let's now talk about what cpa is so
the cost per acquisition model is in
this case since we're trying to drive
action we're gonna pay when somebody
actually takes that action so if
somebody actually does shop and they
spend twenty dollars then basically
you're gonna pay for that acquisition so
basically if it's to download something
whatever it costs for you to get that
person over and they actually download
that's what you're going to pay so cost
per acquisition
is really a model based on action so
when somebody actually performs that
action that's when you're actually going
to pay google so that's what cpa is and
that's what the youtube trueview for
action ads are all about trying to drive
action so let's talk about the universal
app campaign for video and so this is
all about driving action as well so
these ads promote your app on youtube so
where your ads are more likely to be
clicked and your app downloaded so again
targeting an audience and really it's
about you know getting people to
look at your application your mobile app
so that's what these ads are all about
they're about promoting your mobile app
on youtube okay so these ads are
skippable okay they have an open video
length okay meaning you can make them as
long as you want and again their bidding
is cost per acquisition but you also
have some additional models as well so
we already talked about what cost per
acquisition is because this is a
actionable based ad so we want people to
do something like download our app but
you also have another cost model here
cost per install and you only pay when
that person who watches or sees that ad
clicks on it and actually does install
the app okay you also have another model
that you can apply here and that's the
return on ad spend and a return on ad
spend basically is you're asking google
hey i want to make sure that if i'm
going to run this type of ad i'm getting
my return on investment meaning if i
spend 100
am i getting 101 dollars back so that's
the return on ad spend that's a cost per
install and a cost per acquisition so
you have three models here for the
universal app campaign about some
important metric uh for youtube so we
thrown around a lot of different cost
models when we talked about the
different types of advertising you can
do on youtube and so
with that there's a lot of metrics so
let's go through some of these metrics
here you have views clicks your view
rate so you have all these different
types of metrics and
for some of you it could be confusing so
what do i need to look like look at what
i need to measure so it really does come
down to
you know what's important to your
business that's always first and
foremost but here we listed some of the
most common metrics available to you
with youtube okay so let's go through
some of these and basically a view is
just it shows the number of times people
watched or engaged with your video ad so
a view rate is basically the number of
views or engagement your ad receives and
the number times your ad is shown okay
so divided by the number of times your
ad was shown into the number of
engagements so if your ad was shown a
hundred times and you had one like or
one click for example then that would be
one percent so average cost per view is
the average amount you pay
whenever your watch is 30 seconds of
your video so remember when you're on a
cost per view model remember 30 seconds
is the magic number so if your video is
only 25 seconds then remember that's
going to be the view so it's got to be
minimum or maximum 30 seconds if your
video is under 30 seconds it's 25
seconds or 20 as an example then it's
still going to count as a view if it's a
minute and somebody watched at least 30
seconds of it then that's going to count
as a view so just keep in mind 30
seconds is the magic number here for the
view so if somebody watches at least 30
seconds of your video or engages with
your video that would be a cost per view
so that's the average amount you're
going to pay and watch time is basically
it measured the total amount of time
people watched your video ads shown in
seconds okay so it's the total amount of
time so
it gives you an idea of how many minutes
total your video is run so let's focus
on clicks so clicks is a common metric
across the board it shows the number of
times people actually clicked on your
video not to be confused the view so
views the number of times your video is
actually watched a click is something
also measurable and it's when somebody
actually clicked on it so it's an
indicator for how well your ads are
doing with those who see it and so you
know we want people to click on our ads
if we're running you know actionable
type video ads if we're running those
action at type ads or universal app ads
we're going to want people to take
action if you're running ads just for
impressions that's one thing so clicks
is an important metric depending on the
type of video ad you're running so click
the array is the number of clicks you
receive from your ad divided by the
number of times the ad was shown so my
ad was shown 100 times and i received
one clicked then that's one percent
click-through rate so let's talk about
engagement and engagement is the number
of clicks on interactive elements such
as icons in your video ad okay so that's
what an engagement is here the number of
clicks on interactive elements and then
if we look at engagement rate then any
clicks on an interactive element that we
receive is going to be divided by the
number of times the ad was shown so
that's why we have engagement rate as
well so we want people to engage with
their video is there something that
they're doing on the video if so then
what's the rate at which they're
engaging earned views that's a number of
viewers who have seen subsequent videos
on your channel or watch pages after
seeing your ads so watch pages or videos
on your channel if you've seen those
after seeing your ad then that's going
to be called an earned view so somebody
seen your ad and was impacted by what
they saw if we look back at the examples
we shown earlier on with the global
warming or the gmc or the airbnb ads you
know i saw those ads and i said man
that's really a cool ad or that's really
a good message i'm going to go over to
that that watch page or i'm going to go
over to that channel and see what other
videos they have when you do that that's
an earned view and then if you can get
an earned view you're probably going to
get an earned subscriber because it's
the number of viewers who subscribe to
your channel after seeing your ad so
again going back to any of the ads that
you've ever seen if you've ever gone
over to their channel and then
subscribed to the channel that's an
earned subscriber so your video ad is
doing something for you it's in this
case it's getting you a subscriber so
let's talk about how to create a youtube
ad so this is going to require
some access to google ads and we'll go
over that in a few minutes here but
first we need to think about setting up
a campaign and setting up a campaign
goal okay what's the goal of our
campaign to get eyeballs you know we
want to pay cost per 1000 impressions or
we want to run some actionable type ads
to get people over to our website so
that really is step one we need to
identify what the goal of our campaign
is then we need to create the ad so we
want to be able to create a video out
here that is going to show on youtube
and to our target audience so or whether
it be a bumper ad that's only going to
be six seconds long we need to be able
to figure out what type of ad we want to
run so here i am in google ads if we're
going to run a campaign on youtube we
need to make sure that
we're choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're going to go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads then you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select brand
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video
basically what we're doing is we're
going to tell google we want to go ahead
and set up some video ads on youtube and
so here you can see
the different types of video ads we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our out stream which is basically
our viewable cpm model so we're going to
go ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're going to click continue and then
once we do that you know we're going to
get prompted to
you know move forward with selecting our
ad so you can see here after i set up my
campaign now i'm just gonna go through
some of the settings for my ad and i'm
gonna give it a campaign name a budget
okay when it starts or ends the bidding
strategy so again we're going to focus
on cost per 1000 impressions and then
here's the network so this is an
important selection here so we're
dealing with youtube videos so
we also have the option to select video
partners on the display network so that
means that if you want your video to
show on websites that want to host ads
in video format then you can select this
option here notice you also have this
option available if you're running
certain types of ads on youtube we're
running those bumper ads so bumper ads
aren't available on search results so
i'm going to stick with the video
partners okay youtube videos and here we
can get into some other specifics like
language country the type of inventory
so here you can see the default is
standard inventory so that means that
this is what google recommends we want
to show our ads on content that's
appropriate for most ads okay so we can
go expanded or limited so we're going
with the recommended here okay and then
when we go down we're going to have an
ad group so when you create an a
campaign you can have an ad group so
with an ad group that means that we can
have a more or less a video in every
aggregate we have but we have to have at
least one ad group so we're going to go
ahead and set up you know this ad group
here and here's where it gets
interesting and important because here
is where we can start targeting our
audience so here we got demographics
okay so we can choose gender age
parental status household income okay we
can focus in on audiences if we want to
so we can we can choose a specific
audience that we've set up we can get
some ideas or browse specific audiences
we could also choose a specific
placement so here you have youtube
videos or we can go with youtube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our target cpm and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember we're
in this example we're going to bumper
ads so we're looking at about six
seconds and once we do that then that's
pretty much the campaign but i just want
to stress here that when you're setting
it up ahead of time you want to make
sure you identify what the campaign goal
is and then that's going to align with
the type of video you're going to run
and then once you choose that type of
video then it just comes down to where
you want that ad to be and who you're
targeting so
it's really crucial here that you go
through these steps and these options
very closely so because you want your
video to show in front of the right
audience on the right placement so let's
talk about how you can optimize your
youtube ad so once you get your campaign
set up once you select your channel or
the type of videos where you want your
ad to be and you select your target
audience and you're off and running with
your video ad well we're gonna give you
some tips here that you can focus on for
optimizing those ads and so going back
to what i was just saying on the setup
you want to carefully define your
metrics and goals okay so that's step
one so when you're setting up the
campaign remember you have that option
to choose the type of goal for your
campaign that can be brand awareness it
could be a sale it could be a lead so to
me that's the you know a very critical
step one so you want to make sure you
align your goal with your video and then
the second is track low performing ad
placements so if we just ask
google to place our video ads anywhere
they want then it's up to us then to go
through and choose the ad placements and
remove them okay so let me show you an
example of what that means so if i'm
back in google i'm gonna go to my
campaign and i'm gonna select placements
and here i can see placements but then
i'm going to select where my ads show
and so this is important you want to be
able to scan the list of placements
where the ad was shown so if you don't
like one of the placements on youtube
you can always select it edit it and
exclude it from the campaigner record so
that's really the key is you want to be
able to
manage your placements properly and when
we say low performing ad placements we
mean really what what's your goal if
your goal is to get
sales or leads if you're that placement
is not converting sales or leads then
you need to remove or exclude that
placement so it's all done within the
google ads platform and then you know
you can also use a custom thumbnail
image in your ad as well it's always
helpful in terms of optimization so a
couple of other pointers here to help
you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate cta so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your domain name at
the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be as an other
setting you can use closed captioning in
your ads to make it more interactive so
that way people can actually see or read
what the ad is all about just to make it
a bit more interactive okay you can
always perform a b testing on your ads
so if you have one ad version you can
create another one just to see
what it which one performs better
testing is always a positive okay so if
you're paying too much
maybe think about reducing your bids so
if you remember we said a 10 cpm bid
that may be too much maybe we don't need
to pay 10 so we can always reduce our
bids at the ad group level so reduce
bids in areas where you see lower
performance so in other words you don't
want to pay a lot for poor performance
you can also use remarketing to
re-engage with customers so if somebody
views your ads and doesn't take action
you could always retarget that person uh
to show your ad another even another ad
format it could be text ads or display
ads but if somebody looked at your video
and they didn't take the action you
preferred them to take then you can
always retarget them with another ad so
that's a good way to optimize okay so we
want to make sure the ad has content
that what viewers would find relevant
okay that really you want to make sure
that your ad is you know is with the end
viewer you don't want to put out an ad
that isn't going to give somebody you
know a good feeling after they've
watched it okay so you want to make sure
viewers find the content relevant so if
they don't find it relevant then that
means your engagement rate and your
engagement is probably going to be low
so you want to take a look at those
metrics that we viewed earlier
engagement rate engagement and if
they're low then you probably
need to look at the content of the ad so
try to make sure your ad conveys your
brand's message in the first six seconds
so that's why bumper ads to me are so
critical because you've got to get the
entirety of the ad and make it impactful
and so with any ad you run any video ad
you're on you really want to make sure
that that message is conveyed at the
very beginning early as possible
otherwise you know people are going to
be turned off or not engaged and just
going to go ahead and skip it anyway so
you want to make sure you get the
purpose of it right up front and out of
the way okay you can also include visual
and auditory components in your ad that
can make it more memorable to the
viewers okay meaning music or other
cool visuals okay so again you want to
be able to play around and test
different ads and you want to be able to
you know measure the ad performance
based on the metrics we discussed i mean
click-through rate engagement rate all
of those are indicators whether the ad
is of good quality or not with the end
user and when i say good quality i mean
do they find it engaging do they find it
interesting if so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and and test some of those out
with a b testing because you have
nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry
so they're a good success story on
youtube so super dry
leaned on some youtube advertising to
help lift one of their products so in
september last year 2018
super dry if you're not familiar with
the brand they're you know centered some
asian markets european markets and they
focus in on clothing uh all different
styles and sizes and genders
from jackets to jeans to t-shirts and so
their global brand they really wanted to
take a different approach here and their
approach was they wanted to focus in on
sales they wanted to see if video can
help lift them
with sales and so
what they've done is they set up some
campaigns on youtube and their focus
here was on jackets and jackets to
specific ages across the board all
genders and interests and so what they
did was they want to want to take
advantage of all the different ad types
that youtube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here so if we
go to youtube
and let's just take a look at this one
minute ad here 53 second ad buy super
dry
i'm ready now super jam paigey cakey
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raving the jacket you're waiting
the jacket you're pulling the jacket
your play pal and posing
you'll take five in this jacket you all
want to find this jacket i washed the
jacket it's ruined
it
mates take away free
this is the jacket
the jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that super dry ran
you could see that
you know it was it had some particular
goals there and so super dry is pretty
well known so it probably wasn't built
around brand awareness per se it was
probably growth consideration and
interest and also driving action okay
it's a pretty cool video it was
definitely not a bumper ad because
bumper ads are six seconds so it was
definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on super dry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
target their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
very broad audience of gender
some younger people is who they were
targeting so
younger people tend to slant on youtube
and so they were able to get some nice
views out of it 4.8 million but the more
important thing is because these videos
were to drive action and so they were
able to see a four to one ratio on
return on investment and as a result
these jackets saw
a hundred and thirty eight percent
increase in brand lip i mean the jacket
ad so it was a pretty successful
campaign see as well choreographed good
audio good video just well
professionally done and they probably
were able to now get a few more loyal
customers
under their belt because of this ad
alone so that's the power of video okay
so you're able to know who your target
audience is you can go out and target
them with a cool video and
given that youtube is vast then you can
really take advantage of a lot of their
ads so what they probably did again was
there's trueview in stream ads uh with a
cost per view uh through a skippable
video ad format and they they also use
the shoppable ad format so that is
another option on youtube so they took
advantage of all youtube had to offer in
terms of who they were trying to target
the length of the ad
and given that their product or selling
a product or promoting a product they
will take advantage of the trueview
shoppable ad format which basically
lists your products alongside the actual
video ad and so this is just a good case
study you super dry we'll probably do
this again
based on the numbers that they're
reporting and so
basically that's the power of youtube
getting out in front of your audience
with a really good video ad targeting an
audience taking advantage of different
formats hey guys welcome to this video
on youtube ideas for 2021. youtube is
the social media platform that needs no
introduction launched back in the year
2005 youtube was a fresh breath of air
for the people who were slowly becoming
aware of the hype that surrounded the
internet
several other platforms like dailymotion
with me and vmo which admittedly have
their own fans have tried to stand up
against the vehement that is the youtube
and failed
slowly but surely marketers began to
realize the enormous potential that
youtube offered they could add small
advertisements like they do in the cable
tv they could show banner ads and do
much more and all the thanks to the
robust advertisement features that
google already offered if you're not
already sold on why it's important to
advertise on youtube here are some facts
that might change your mind youtube has
more than 2 billion users across the
world a good fraction of that audience
could be shown your product and could
turn from users to customers next
important fact is that 8 out of 10
marketers consider youtube to be one of
the best platforms to advertise their
products and services followed by that
people watch one billionaires of youtube
per day as you watch this video you are
contributing to that number
next 62 percent of the business use
youtube to post content this could be
just videos on their products tutorials
event announcements and much more 70 of
the youtube watch time comes from mobile
this means that when you create an
advertisement for youtube you keep the
mobile users in your mind
and finally ninety percent of the people
say that they've discovered new products
or brands on youtube which means that by
posting on youtube your brand awareness
is highly likely to increase
now let's talk about the video ideas
the first one is behind the scene videos
these videos give you the opportunity to
showcase your audience how your business
or brand operates a creatively made
video on the inner workings of your
business will show off a more human side
of your brand and make you more
relatable to your audience it is also
guaranteed to get you loads of views and
engagement here's an example how amazon
showcases the warehousing and
distribution aspects of its products it
takes the viewers into the factories and
involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large organization like amazon
how each individual has an important
role to play in the overall process
next we have the company culture
a video that highlights your company
culture will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure the
company works in the way it does
this can help better connect with your
audience
here's an example a company culture
video created by godaddy the popular
domain register
the video talks about how godaddy
creates a fun inclusive and energetic
environment for its employees
it includes interviews of employees
talking about why they enjoy working in
godaddy so much and this helps the
audience relate with the company and
could also catch up the interest with
some potential job seekers
next we have the third idea that is the
marketing team a brand is nothing
without the people working behind it and
that's where these videos come in these
videos will help shine a light on the
people who create the products that the
audience knows and loves
this helps create a personal connection
with the audience these individuals can
end up becoming mascots for your brand
here's an example of meet the team
focusing on olympus group the video goes
into the history of masket maker's brand
and the people that make it a grand
success
the lighthearted tone of the video also
greatly helps with making it more
relatable
now we have number four product showcase
or announcement
a product showcase video aims to show
the features and benefits of the brand's
latest offering to its audience
these short concise videos can inform
the audience about everything they need
to know about the new product or service
a product announcement video on the
other hand can be used to give the
audience a more detailed look into the
product or service than the product
showcase
it can include comparisons to older
versions or competitors the aim of such
video is to show customers how the new
product works and why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
apple's iphone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations of what the product
would be like next at number 5 we have
event announcements
these videos can build a hype regarding
an upcoming event it will also give you
the opportunity to engage with your
audience and build their interest
this promo video for the data innovation
summit 2020 hypes up the event posting
the greatest minds in the tech the most
innovative companies and much more
the next video idea we have at number
six is the explainer videos
these videos are aimed to tell users how
a particular product or a service works
these tend to be much more useful than
wall of text explaining how something
works
they also have an added advantage of
simplifying complex concepts and
features to your audience for example we
have our own video on digital marketing
we cover a number of different concepts
like seo social media marketing search
engine marketing and more on a visual
manner making it more likely to grab the
attention of a viewer
next at number 7 we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights and knowledge that
your users can learn from
these videos aim to be guides to
information complex concepts hints tips
and tricks relating to your industry
here we have our own digital marketing
course video as an example unlike the
previous example i mentioned this video
goes into much more detail regarding
each of the concepts of digital
marketing on that note if you guys are
interested in learning about digital
marketing i suggest you start from this
video it's a great one to get started
with
now on the next video idea at number
eight we have the product tutorial a
product tutorial video will take your
audience through the various features of
your product offers alongside its
intricacies it can also detail some
additional insights about your product
you can also explain the best way the
product can be used
here's a video of how the meditation app
headspace explains the app's usage with
an interesting and creative animated
video
now let's go ahead with number nine at
the number nine we have the webinar a
webinar thanks to its nature provides
your brand with lots of opportunities to
interact with your audience they are
usually very accessible and easy to make
they are also very cost effective and
can be reused as video content after the
session is complete here is an example
of simply learns webinar where we talk
to the industry experts regarding wide
variety of topics while involving the
audience by having the guest answer the
audience questions whenever possible
next at number 10 we have the live
streams live streams for an event will
help build excitement and hype for the
event it can be advertised on other
social media platforms to generate some
hype as well these videos can also help
you bring up your product to a larger
audience and at a reduced cost
here's an example of a live stream that
constantly keeps a track of subscribers
increasing for some of the most popular
youtube channels
next at number 11 we have ama or ask me
anything sessions
the ama or ask me anything sessions are
usually live streams or pre-recorded
sessions that feature questions
collected from the audience
although it originated from reddit these
videos are finding a success on youtube
thanks to the interactivity that it
offers
these sessions can also give your
audience the opportunity to interact
with you provide suggestions feedback
and much more here's an example of ama
session with the actor matt damon
where questions covering a wide variety
of topics collected from reddit were
answered by him
next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your niche can go a
long way to grow your audience
these sessions are doubly advantageous
too firstly you and by extension your
audience get to interact with an
industry stalwart and since this video
can be shared on your channel as well as
theirs you can expose your channel to a
brand new audience here's an example of
an interview between marcus brownlee a
popular tech youtuber with bill gates
the interview covers a wide variety of
topics and maintains a pleasant theme
throughout
let's now go to number 13 testimonials a
testimonial video help highlight the
positive feedback from a client or a
customer they provide social proof and
provide a unique perspective on your
products and services these videos can
greatly help improve people's trust on
your brand shareability and credibility
here's an example of simply lunch
testimonial video that covers a
learner's journey as he grew in his
career thanks to simply learn
certification
a video like this can be greatly
relatable to the audience and even
encourage some of them to take up a
certification
let's go to our next video idea that is
the number 14 whiteboard videos a
whiteboard video offers your visually
attractive way of explaining complex
concepts usually this involves a trained
experts breaking through a complex topic
on a whiteboard
nowadays there has also been the trend
of digital whiteboard videos that work
thanks to the visual style and charisma
of the narrator here's an example of the
whiteboard video simply learn created
covering various concepts of social
media marketing with the help of an
engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have number 15
competitions competitions or contest
videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved with your
channel these videos enable you to
generate fresh and original content with
little from your end
in an interesting example for foldable
flight channel users submitted their
ideas for paper airplanes that would go
to the farthest distance the channel
received a significant amount of
submissions and saw considerable growth
next we have 16 the lists
list videos are some of the most
commonly found content on youtube most
users enjoy this type of content thanks
to it being small easily digestible and
bite-sized
these videos can cover a wide range of
topics like options to choose from the
best products techniques and much more
the main advantage of these videos are
they provide users with value while
further involving them with your channel
here's an example of a list that we have
created on the top 10 skills you need to
become a data analyst in the year 2021
if you are interested don't forget to
check it out at number 17 we have case
studies case studies talk about how your
product or service have benefited
clients and users
videos like this can greatly improve
relatability and making your brand seem
more likeable
here's a video that analyzes coca-cola's
marketing campaign and what it made one
of the most popular brands in the world
now let's talk about content that may
not be necessarily for a brand but for
individual creators at number 18 we have
tech unboxing
these videos usually involve packages
being open for the first time
while these are fairly common for
technology these videos have also found
success in fashion apparel these videos
enable the users to experience the
products for the first time sometimes
even helping them decide between rival
products here's an example of ps5 being
unboxed by marcus brownlee who goes into
detail regarding each of its console
components controllers and other
specifications at number 19 we have tech
reviews with tech reviews you can talk
about the various features of a
particular product what you liked about
it what you did its price and other
practical information and much more
here we have an example of oneplus 8 pro
being reviewed in detail covering its
many features advantages disadvantages
and much more and finally we have number
20 reaction videos reaction videos are
exactly what the name says you giving an
emotional reaction to something like a
movie trailer music video or tv episode
these videos encourage a large amount of
engagement from the audience and make
your brand seem more relatable
here's an example of a reaction video
involving teenagers reacting to the
latest tick-tock videos these videos
usually enable a large amount of likes
comments and shares today we're going to
talk about how to increase youtube
subscribers so with youtube it's all
about subscribers the number of
subscribers you have on youtube it's
just one of the key metrics to measure
success so gaining more subscribers can
help you achieve more view counts on
your youtube videos so it's all about
how to get subscribers and today we're
going to talk about how to get more
subscribers and before we begin let's
just show you what we did at simply
learn so if we look at the past 365 days
on our youtube channel you can see we
started here back in uh if we look back
at march 9 2018 we had 208 and you could
see just over the course of the year it
kept creeping up creeping up creeping up
and creeping up we've gained you know a
significant number of subscribers over
the last year and what's our secret well
it's posting videos so you can see we've
posted a number of videos over the
course of the year and then our
subscribers have gone basically 165
over the last year so you can see it's
part of it is about posting videos
because when you post videos you have
people who can watch those videos when
you have people watch those videos you
can have engagement and then when you
have engagement you have shares and
people who like it and then other people
will see it so it's kind of a halo
effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase those subscriptions so
let's start out with some of those tips
we're going to start with creating
engagement informative content so
engaging in informative content that's
where we're going to start talking today
about how to increase subscriptions then
we're going to talk about publishing
videos frequently so simply learn you
can see the past 365 days we were
consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout the month and
the weeks so another tip we're going to
talk about is how to optimize your
youtube videos so there's a lot that
goes into optimization but this is a key
key tip to pay attention to because when
it comes to posting publishing videos on
youtube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize on our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the youtube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
youtube channel producing high quality
videos we're going to talk about that
adding a subscriber watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
going to mention today engage with our
audience okay that's what we want to do
we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos in
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our channel we have to create highly
engaged and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you gotta create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audio okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for i mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on youtube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on youtube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't veer off
course if you veer off course you're not
going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what i normally do is
you know have an outline and then once i
have the outline then i go ahead and
create my slides if i will or my topics
points i want to talk about and then i
write out those points i want to make
sure i get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of the session i showed you an
example of simply learned subscribers
over the past 365 days and so that's
what we want to do we want to be clear
but use examples to punctuate the
content or the point we're trying to get
across so we want to include sources
from high quality sites so if you're
going to use examples make sure they're
from relevant high quality sites when i
mean high quality meaning does your
audience know who that source is or that
site if it's really specific and your
audience may not know then it's probably
not high quality so just keep that in
mind always play to your audience so you
want to start your video with an
interesting hook so again i go back to
this example if you're still watching
this then the hook worked we showed you
our subscriptions we showed you how we
grew over the course of a year you could
see our growth and part of it was
posting a lot of videos with relevant
and informative content and so you see
how we did it so you're paying attention
you want to know how to do it and so
part of what we did is exactly what i'm
telling you now we know who our audience
is we plan out our scripts we use good
examples and we start our videos with
interesting hooks now when we do our
videos we also create original content
so that goes back to planning your
script okay you always want to you know
come across as original and informative
when you do that you're going to be
engaging but if you're leveraging
somebody else's content then the
engaging part may not resonate because
it's not your content to begin with so
always always always use original
content okay so keep the content flow
organized so again that goes back to an
outline you know feel free to change up
the outline so the flow makes sense add
visuals to your content and make it
appealing always include images to me if
you can use images in your videos and
play off the video or the images then
it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content so visuals help
guide and aid in the points you're
trying to make so don't make it so text
heavy you know accentuate it balance it
with some images use simple language and
crisp sentences meaning don't choose
jargon don't come across and talk above
your audience you always want to talk to
your audience and talk in a language
that they're going to understand so it
goes back to point one if you know who
your audience is you're talking to them
as if they're right in front of you and
not you're above them or they're below
you you want to talk at them so add
cards and screens and pattern interrupts
to engage your audience and so youtube
cards are just interactive panels that
slide in and out when a video is playing
so it encourages
interaction by the viewer okay so you
can add up to five cards which include
images text or clickable links so feel
free to play around with some of these
features that youtube has to offer to
make your content more engaging so tip
two publish videos frequently so
creating and uploading videos
consistently will help you increase your
youtube subscribers so suppose you
haven't published videos for more than
say a month or two months it's likely
that that audience not gonna subscribe
to your channel so think about youtube
videos as a popular tv program that
comes on once a week when a new episode
comes on based on the regular schedule
it's consistency and that consistency is
what helps your users stay engaged so
for example if i go back to our youtube
channel you know what helped us gain
subscribers was our consistency in
publishing videos you could see we were
consistent publishing a couple of videos
a week every couple of weeks and so this
helps users stay engaged they know when
the video is coming out they know that
simply learn is good for two three four
videos a month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or youtube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so i subscribe to
simplylearn's channel i subscribe to
other channels like google analytics for
example so anytime google analytics
publishes a video i get an email that
says hey google analytics youtube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is i'm checking my email and
i'm getting this notification in gmail
so guess what i can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email i don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to social
media examiner youtube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging i always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the youtube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month and ramp it up okay
you'll find that the more you ramp it up
the more subscribers you're gonna get so
tip three optimize your youtube videos
so optimizing your videos will help your
content rank higher on youtube so this
is a get must it's not a given it's a
must you must optimize your videos if
you want people to see them of course if
you don't optimize people aren't going
to see them then people aren't going to
engage and then not subscribe so it's
just kind of a snowball effect so this
is an important tip so i mentioned it at
the beginning when we were going over
all the items we're going to discuss
this is the one item that is a must and
a given to some degree because if you
don't optimize your videos they're just
not going to be found so you need that
audience to watch your video so
audiences who tend to interact more with
your content have more chance to
subscribe to your channel but they're
not going to subscribe if they don't
even watch your video so there is a
snowball effect in play here if we don't
optimize your videos so okay rob what
are some of the tips to optimize your
youtube video well let's go through some
of those tips so to ensure your videos
reaches the relevant audience on youtube
you need to optimize the title
description in the video tag okay rob
what do you mean by title description
and video tag so let's take a look at
that so when you actually create your
youtube video you're gonna have an
opportunity to put in a title you're
gonna have an opportunity to put in a
description and you're gonna have an
opportunity to add text so those are the
three key areas okay so once you put in
that what it looks like on the front end
is this so if i go back to youtube and
here you can see another video that we
did about a month ago you could see what
is seo so if that's our topic that's our
title uh or of the content of the video
then the title of the video is going to
be what is seo and you can see we also
added in some other content for the
title so what is seo and how does it
work seo tutorial for beginners and then
our brand name so we have some content
to work with for the title okay and then
the description we have a lot of
characters to work with descriptions so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about here you can see
we did that and so it's always good to
include this information okay and then
you can see we have tags up here seo seo
tutorial for beginners digital marketing
so we put in the necessary information
here on this video to help us rank
because if we don't optimize it we're
not going to rank and so you can see we
just put a lot of relevant content
around the description around the title
and around those tags by doing so we're
able to optimize this video and get
found so that's just an example three of
the things you can do to help optimize
your youtube video so if you want to
watch more on how to optimize meta tags
then i suggest maybe watching the other
video we did on the subject how to rank
youtube videos so this goes into more
detail about how to optimize the title
the meta description and the meta tags
but those are three quick fields or
areas that you can use to optimize your
video so just something to keep in mind
write a long description with keywords
time stamps and links so what i mean by
time stamps for timestamp an audience
can choose the section of the video that
they want to look for and then links
prefer to include relevant links of your
other videos so those are just some
additional tips to help keep your
content engaging so remember when your
content is engaging then people are
going to like it people are going to
share it and watch it later so upload a
captivating thumbnail okay so you want
to include a thumbnail that's going to
grab people's attention you want to
upload a transcript of the video so that
goes back to when you're creating your
content when you write your original
content you want to keep a transcript of
the content of the video so that you can
upload that as well and then add a start
screen and end screen to your youtube
videos so that way you know when
somebody plays the video they're going
to see it what it looks like up front
and then when we finish it they're going
to see an end screen at the end and so
you just don't want to keep it dark and
black and non-descriptive so according
to backlinko using an exact keyword in
your video title can help you with
rankings so high ranking more views more
views more subscribers so that's what
i've been saying all along you need to
get these videos optimized so again use
an exact keyword in your video title so
let's go back again to that video i just
showed you a couple minutes ago what is
seo so here we started out with a
question what is seo that's the name of
the title that's one exact title of the
video that's our exact keyword okay so
what is seo and how does it work and
then seo tutorial for beginners so what
is seo is our exact keyword and that's
part of the video that's the content of
the video that's in the title and we use
it throughout the description as well so
using that exact keyword in your video
title can help with the ranking so
whatever your topic is your title of the
video or the topic of the video include
it in the title so backlinko also
mentions that there is a moderate
correlation between a channel's total
subscribers and rankings and so for some
of you this may be common sense it's
just like organic search if you're not
ranking you're not going to get traffic
on youtube if you're not ranking you're
not going to get eyeballs on your videos
and you're not going to get subscribers
so higher rankings can help you to get
more subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches the title of the
video itself when you're publishing your
description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which will turn into
subscribers so tip 4 optimize your
youtube channel so we just talked about
optimizing our videos now we're going to
turn our attention to our youtube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your views to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great youtube channel
trailer you also want to add channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good youtube channel so let's talk about
some of these these tips here so we want
to give your audience a preview what
your channel is offering so this is by
hooking your audience with a trailer so
you can create a trailer to you know
just give your audience an idea of who
you are as a brand what kind of videos
you're going to be posting and give them
a kind of a taste of what the future
videos are going to be like okay you can
even tell them your release schedule in
the trailer so you can start up by
saying hey hey guys we're new to this
we're going to be posting one video a
month but as we get rolling maybe two
per month and you know one per week you
know just being honest and open and
talking to your audience and get them
excited about future videos that's what
the trailer is all about so you also
want to keep it that the channel
description short interesting so in your
channel you want to have a description
of what the channel is all about what
kind of videos you're going to be
posting so in addition to the trailer
you want to write something short and
interesting then we want to use keywords
in our channel descriptions just like in
the videos with what is seo we included
what is seo in the title we included you
know what is seo in the description and
so we want to be true to what our
channel is so pick keywords not only
include those keywords in the videos but
include them in the channel description
pay attention to the first 100 to 150
characters of your channel description
because that's what's shown next your
channel on the search results so for
example here you can see we have a
description here simply learn is one of
the world's leading certification
training providers we partner with
companies and individuals to address and
so you can see those characters 100 150
or what shows up in the channel
description when somebody's trying to
understand hey simply learn just
uploaded this video who is simply
learning so you want to write short
interesting channel description so that
when somebody's first introduced to your
video they could see what your brand's
all about so and your description with
an appropriate call to action so short
interesting good call to action at the
end of the video a good call to action
would be hey check out our next video or
check out our latest video something
that's going to gauge somebody and get
them to watch one of your videos so you
want to pick interesting channel art so
let's turn our attention to the simply
learn channel page and here you can see
we recently
had reached a milestone so recently
reached the 200 000 k subscribers so 200
000 subscribers is a big achievement for
simply learn we went ahead and updated
our channel art and i'm sure we will
reach 500k we'll update the artwork then
too but the point is you want to keep
your channel art kind of interesting hip
and cool and feel free to change it out
every once in a while so you have that
option in youtube to do i mean it's very
simple so here you can see simply learns
channel we go home get all our videos
listed here we got the about us you know
something very short interesting about
us here's our call to action for more
information visit simplylearn so you
want to make sure when you create your
channel get some good artwork in there
put your description in play and create
your first videos and get them posted up
there and optimize them accordingly okay
so some other tips to go with that
channel art and description is a profile
picture relevant to your brand so you
always want to maybe put
the company logo up there okay so here
you can see we have the company logo at
accurate relevant channel keywords so if
we go back to who we are who are we
we're the world's leading certification
training provider okay that's who we are
okay we partner with companies and
individuals so we're all about training
and training is one of our keywords so
you can see at simply learn we provide
online training and machine learning aws
amazon web services devops big data
digital marketing project management a
lot of different topics so make sure
that's included in the channel
description feature the playlist on your
homepage so if we go back to the home
page we can see here we have our
channels so you can see we have ai
machine learning trending technologies
cloud computing tutorials devops
tutorials popular videos big data we
have a lot of different channels so you
want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but i
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you
could take a video that maybe hasn't
gotten a lot of views or isn't ranked
particularly high maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
has some rationale behind that so choose
a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if i go
back to our youtube page you can see the
top performing videos here you know for
example this one we got a nice thumbnail
here what is machine learning so if i
click on that
most popular videos so 3 000 likes on
this video a lot of views 250 000 plus
views so have a thumbnail to go along
with that particular video so according
to backlinko youtube seo ranking factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with higher youtube search rankings so
channel keywords so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if i go back to our
channel okay if i go back about us make
sure your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted on our videos so if
you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
us a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the habit of producing high quality
videos because viewers don't prefer to
watch videos that have poor audio and
video quality it's just that simple you
need to know what it takes to produce
high quality videos if you don't you're
just going to discredit you're not going
to come across
as relevant you know i'm going to come
across as qualified professional there's
a lot of things attached to poor quality
video so we need to
create high quality videos for the end
user so let's talk about some ways in
which you can create high quality videos
and so the first is to avoid any noise
in the background so you want to have a
nice quiet atmosphere no distractions so
people can hear you clearly and only you
clearly you want to use good audio
recording equipment there's plenty of
options available on the internet
usually i would recommend going with
something paid not overly expensive
because you get what you pay for so if
you use something free it might not
be
of good quality and you might not have
all the features and bells and whistles
with a free option so you know use good
audio recording equipment again it could
be online or it could be some software
just make sure that you're able to
produce good high quality video and
audio so when you do purchase that audio
recording equipment you want to have
something similar to an input volume
meter that way you can see
whether your audio is coming across or
not so if you're not seeing green lights
then your audio is not coming across if
it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 10 80 pixel size okay
that's hd and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that it's probably gonna come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry not professional not high def so
you want to create a high def video and
1080 is about the minimum you want to go
and then you want to plan your video
script before filming so it goes back to
some of the other points i made earlier
you always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people can see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professional so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to
accentuate your points and then set up a
green background for recording again
this is for you know making sure that
the video part of it comes across in
good quality and stabilize your video
recordings with the tripod that way
you're not moving your video camera all
around and and again it's coming across
as shaky and poor quality shoot
horizontal videos you don't want to go
vertical it tends to cut the screen so
you want to stay horizontal so that
people can see everything that should be
included in the video and you want to
capture a wider shot using a clip-on
lens again a good feature a good tip to
use use that wider shot okay so you
could do that using a clip-on lens and
then choose good video editing software
i can't state this enough because you're
putting all this time and effort into a
video you need to be able to edit it to
cut out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
i would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
at the very least review your work
before publishing i just said it a
minute ago i'll say it again you want to
be able to
have a really professional video and
high def when you have a good
professional video and high def with
good audio horizontal shots you know
nice green background image nice well
lit it's gonna come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are going
to take you seriously they're going to
see you as a professional and then share
or subscribe and like and then they're
going to watch more videos and and
that's how you start to build up a
reputation as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're going to have to do it
all over again so follow these tips get
a high quality video and you should be
on your way to ranking in fact according
to backlinko youtube preferably ranks hd
videos so you got to have that 1080 uh
pixel size that way you know your video
is gonna come across crisp and clear and
youtube prefers that tip six add a
subscriber watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in youtube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your channel the watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your youtube account it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're gonna select your creator studio
icon and then you're gonna go to channel
select branding and then add a watermark
to your video so if we look at that on
youtube so here creator studio on the
left side navigation i'm just gonna
click channel then i'm gonna click
branding and then once you click
branding you have the ability to add
your watermark and then you can add it
to the entire video at the end of the
video at a specific start time and then
just click update and that's pretty much
it so you want to be able to add this so
that you can brand your videos with an
image and then add that cta so this is a
good good feature for youtube it allows
you to be consistent with all your
videos by branding and adding that call
to action tip seven engage with your
audience so you want to be able to
interact with your audience as much as
possible just because the video and you
can't see people doesn't mean you can't
engage with them so when you interact
with your viewers especially when you
interact with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of your busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with youtube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on youtube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback is always going to be positive
some of the feedback could be less than
positive or even negative there could be
mistakes so the idea behind getting
feedback is you want to look at it you
want to read it and you want to react to
it you want to react to it positively in
the form of you know what thank you for
the feedback and looking at the feedback
weighing it and incorporating the
feedback so you don't always want to
make the same mistake twice in a video
so if there's something definitely wrong
with the video that we're doing for
example and somebody looked at it and
gave us feedback on it we'd certainly
definitely take a deep look into that
and try not to do the same mistake twice
because likely that user is going to
watch the video again so you always want
to learn from your mistakes and you want
to turn those mistakes or turn those
comments into future videos okay so
create videos based on your commenter's
request the audience is giving us
feedback we should take that as positive
and sometimes that's creative sometimes
those ideas for more videos okay you
always want to ask questions to your
audience and reward excellent commenters
so we try to ask questions in our videos
and when users respond with the answer
if there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion or something
there's always some way to incentivize
somebody who provides excellent feedback
you can always give emoji hearts there's
so many emojis out there that you can
use emojis just to engage with your
audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is if your
audience is taking the time to give
feedback you always want to respond to
it and you want to respond to a positive
so emojis tend to have a positive
connotation to them and so responding
with an emoji especially to a favorite
comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
youtube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways many ways not
necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
youtube has them other platforms like
facebook have them instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flesh so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they can see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will lend to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
youtube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and get their
videos and use their videos and upload
them to your channel so according to
backlinko video comments of a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey if you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video i see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and i'm going to ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go solicit comments respond to
the comments reward the comments tip
number eight promote your videos on
different platforms so promoting your
videos on different platforms has been
around for many years it's a good
strategy once you create your video on
youtube you want people to see it you
want to get it out there so if you want
to increase your youtube subscribers
this is a strategy you have to perform
so let's take a look at all the ways you
can use and leverage different platforms
to increase your subscribers so before
you do that you want to research
discover how
you can use different platforms so the
first thing you want to do is look at
the platforms you're already using if
you're using facebook and instagram
that's probably a good place to start
but there's other platforms you can also
leverage and we're going to talk about
those so social media most companies
most individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
facebook and instagram so you can start
there so with facebook you can post
something include the link of your
youtube video with facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your youtube video you can
also do the same on twitter or instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to youtube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in a discussion and include
a link to the youtube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning and the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimonial
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here
genix okay there's a article here about
you know certificate of achievements
okay for aws so if you scroll down we
could see our video is included here in
this particular web page so this is a
high quality web page okay that's
generating a backlink for us not only is
it generating a backlink it's also
generating traffic and awareness for the
video go ahead and find out if there's
any websites that are relevant to your
video topic and see if you can
collaborate with them on producing a web
page to include that video you can also
take advantage of email marketing by
adding your youtube link in the email
signature for example it's a simple
email any email client like gmail or
yahoo or even hotmail or outlook is
going to have an ability to or give you
the ability to add a signature in the
signature you could simply just include
a link to the video or to your youtube
channel it doesn't have to be do a
specific video but it's a way to get
people to your youtube page or to that
video so the whole idea is more eyeballs
more potential subscribers engage your
audience by posting your video links on
community pages so for example you know
we're promoting something here on a
community page and that's going to get
some additional traffic over to us you
can always bookmark your videos on
bookmarking sites like stumbledupon.com
again this is free very little time to
do this but it's a chance for you to get
the video out there and even generate a
backlink you can collaborate with other
youtube channels this is always a good
strategy if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on youtube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their channel
and you can take their video and put it
on your channel in a particular playlist
okay so that's a way to collaborate with
other youtube channels is swap videos
you can join high pr qa sites and post
answers to the questions related to your
video like core is always a good example
or e-hop okay so core there's always a
question of being posted and if you have
the answer to that question in the form
of your video then go ahead and post a
response with a link to the video on
youtube it's a great way to get the
video noticed and it's relevant and
natural okay you can embed videos in
your blog posts so if you're using a
platform like wordpress for example very
easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link in
the blog post i like this option i think
blog posts are always good because you
don't have to be text heavy with a blog
post you want to create a blog post
that's nice and balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so having a video in your blog
post always goes well in my opinion okay
so you could promote other videos in
your end screen for example at the end
of your video you can always promote
something related like we've done here
in this example so lots of ideas get
your video out there use them in email
use them in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like stumbleupon you
know collaborate with other people on
youtube you know go to core respond to a
question use social media to your
advantage there's lots of opportunities
to get your video out there the more you
can get your video out there the more
traffic you're gonna get the more
traffic you get to the video the more
subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played in order
to get your video out there but these
are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video some
some subscribers in a world where
a lot of competing different products
satisfy the same requirement you have a
lot of advertisers who want you to try
their product and then you have other
advertisers who want you to try their
product try my product try my product
try my product try no try my product my
product's the best no no no no my
product's the best try my product well i
want you to forget all that and try my
product forget about those other
advertisers try my product well there's
only one way you can prove your product
is better than the rest and that's with
powerful advertising and one of the best
ways to advertise on the internet is via
social media and through the largest
social media platform in the world and
that's facebook so today we're going to
talk about facebook ads tutorial and i'm
excited to teach this class my name is
rob sanders i'm with simply learn and
today we are going to talk about all the
different ads that facebook has to offer
so introduced back in 2007
the facebook ads platform has grown
tremendously over the last few years
almost four billion dollars of revenue
in one year so what does that mean that
means there's a lot of advertisers why
is there a lot of advertisers because a
lot of people use facebook it's a
popular platform so not only is it
popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on facebook you have the
opportunity to
share your product and your brand with
users who you think are going to buy
your product or associate with your
brand and on facebook you can do that a
number of different ways specifically in
somebody's newsfeed and specifically
that person's feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so i
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to
your product and your brand so not only
that but you combine that target
audience with the amount of time that
people spend on facebook okay people
spend a lot of time on facebook in fact
not only do people spend a lot of time
on facebook there's a lot of people on
facebook in fact 2.27
billion in the third quarter of 2018 and
so when we say spend a lot of time we
mean going to that facebook profile at
least once a day okay so a lot of
eyeballs throughout the day checking
their news feed on facebook facebook
also enables you the advertiser to find
the perfect audience and so that's the
great combination a lot of people on
facebook and targeted audience so it's a
platform that allows you
to put your product in front of people
based on specific interest
specific demographics specific location
so you're really really putting your
product out in front of the right people
at the right time and so the other
positive and pro about facebook is it's
lesser spend greater reach and what do
we mean by that well traditionally
facebook is a little bit cheaper
than other
online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on facebook
active on facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
facebook is it also has other features
other advertising features such as
retargeting so you could target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your servicer product but if they didn't
go through
the conversion process meaning they
didn't go all the way through and and
buy your product you can certainly reach
out to them again just like your
traditional retargeting options on say
google or some other advertising
platform facebook works the same way we
want to be able to reach out to people
who aren't fully committed at that point
in time but we can reach out to them at
another point in time and so facebook's
advertising platform allows us to do
that so it's a great feature that we
could take advantage of that we'll talk
about more throughout this session and
then it helps increase revenue sales and
leads and and that's primarily what most
advertisers are after you know more
revenue more sales more leads so
facebook allows us to educate our
audience again a targeted audience about
a specific product we have to offer so
the more our audience knows about our
product especially if their friends and
family members and colleagues are using
the product then the more likely they're
going to purchase so if you go back to
the other feature higher revenue less
spend this is the primary reason because
you have a chance to influence somebody
who's very targeted who's very active on
the platform and who may have
like-minded people in their life
associating with your brand and product
so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad and the
single image ad are just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own facebook
feed if you look so in fact i'll just
jump over to my facebook feed right now
and if i go there what do i see i see a
single image ad here and it's from
shopify partners so become a shopify
partner at e-commerce to your list of
qualifications so shopify must be you
know a brand that is trying to woo my
business okay so they know that somebody
that i'm associated with or maybe i fit
their demographic so they're targeting
my newsfeed with a single image ad so
that's what a single image ad looks like
it's simply just one single image with
some description and the great thing
about this single image if you haven't
noticed is the pixels are pretty large
it's 1200 by 628 so it kind of stands
out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if i go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so i can't miss it if i'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to
you know not see this ad interact in
some way especially again if i know
somebody in my network on facebook or
either that be a friend or family member
is associated with that product okay in
addition to the single image ads
facebook also has multi-product ads or
also known as carousel ads and so what
the carousel ads do is allow you in
carousel form allow you to rotate
different ads with different messaging
and different call to action and so here
you can see
simply learn has a example of a carousel
ad where they're showcasing their
different courses so this allows users
to view a range of all your different
products and services if you have
multiple products and services to offer
then the carousel ads would be a good
option for you so in addition to the
carousel ads and single image ads it
gets a little bit more sophisticated in
terms of technology where facebook
allows us to offer up video ads and so
video ads are interactive it's a good
way to really showcase your product your
brand your service and the great thing
about the video ads is they can go from
just a few seconds all the way up to
you know two minutes or excuse me all
the way up to 120 minutes and so you can
really really put a lot of time and
effort into the video ads to really put
your brand out there and so the one
thing about video is it is interactive
most people engage with video and they
tend to get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other forms of ads so the
video ads are really a popular way for
you as an advertiser to put your brand
or product out there so you can put your
brand and product out there and not just
a few seconds but you know really tell a
nice complete story to get the
engagement to get the person to take the
action you want them to do so that's why
video ads have become very popular
because they tend to get more engagement
more interaction than your traditional
single image ad or say your carousel ad
so facebook also allows us to advertise
something called lead ads and what lead
ads allow us to do is obtain user
details okay so we can acquire or get an
email address or phone number from
somebody who's interested in our product
or service and that person doesn't even
have to leave facebook so
if you look here in the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead ad is
that it can sync up with any crm or most
of your popular crms i should say for
example salesforce is a good example of
a crm where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the forum itself
the interaction stays right in facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really
put your best images out there with a
really strong call to action just like
you see here with the simply learn
example okay so they're showcasing
you know they're different classes and
then they have the get started today
call to action to really punctuate the
slideshow ad so what's interesting is
you can really gauge a person's interest
by throwing different products or images
out there you know you can really
immerse a user's experience here by
showing different different images and
then the last type of ad on facebook is
called a collection ad and so these ads
combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so
if you're an advertiser
who wants to advertise several products
at once then this could be a great
option for you the collection ad so here
you can see the simply learn example
here they're showing you know not only
you know some some good slide shows and
imagery with some good messaging below
that
so before we get into the steps for
creating an ad on facebook let's talk
about some of the important changes that
have happened on facebook recently in
light of data sharing so
really what facebook's done is they've
made an important change on how user
data is being used for advertising and
so
what facebook's done is they removed
something um called a partner category
and that was an ad targeting program
which the targeting option was based on
data provided by a third party partner
so if you're an advertiser
you had a third party partner that
provided some targeted options to you
that was known as a partner category and
in summary facebook has removed that
program and so now the only way you can
gain user information is if they provide
that voluntary like the lead ad for
example now you have to get the data
directly from the third party now so you
can't have that third party give you
that targeting option anymore you can
certainly again capture the data
yourself by relying on leak capture
landing pages as an example or the lead
ads and you can certainly still
outsource your advertising to lead gen
agencies and media buying companies okay
but the partner category has more or
less
gone away
okay so now let's get into
how to create a facebook ad so what are
the steps so the first thing you'll have
to do is set up a campaign so
when you're setting up a campaign you
have to select
what kind of spending you want to do for
your advertisement and what you want to
achieve okay so you have to in other
words identify the goal okay so with
facebook you have two opportunities at
hand here you can jump into an auction
just like google what you're going to do
is your ads going to enter into an
auction and so this is where you can
decide how you want to spend your money
to achieve your goals by choosing an
appropriate bid strategy for the auction
so
in the auction you're competing with
other advertisers another option is you
could do reach and frequency and so with
reach and frequency you'll be able to
advertise to your brand's audience
with a fixed cost so
reach and frequency allows you as the
advertiser to better predict the
delivery cost and reach of your branding
campaigns so with auction you have more
choice you have flexibility of
scalability but not a lot of
predictability okay because again you're
going into an option and your auction is
going to be competing against other
advertisers so it's this option is
available to all advertisers and you can
have pricing that you can change during
the auction price process so
that's the
unpredictability part is the pricing so
pricing can fluctuate during the auction
because you have different advertisers
who are trying to achieve the most
prominence for their ad with reach and
frequency you'll be able to plan and set
up your campaigns and
actually set it up so it's more
predictable on how the delivery is going
to be done
with reach and frequency so
more predictability will reach some
frequency because you could set
everything up in your campaign okay so
again with the reach and frequency
you'll be able to advertise with a fixed
cost auction you're not necessarily
going with a fixed cost you're going
with more scalability flexibility on
cause that can change okay so once you
choose your objective for your
advertisement then you need to choose
the type of advertisement you want to do
and it's based on your objectives so
what's your objective is it awareness to
drive awareness is it to
drive consideration or is it to
drive a conversion so these are the
three objectives
available to you for your advertising
you want to choose one of those
objectives so let's take a look at each
of these objectives available to you
okay so let's start out with awareness
so awareness can help with creating an
interest for your product
or or your service so when we say
awareness we're thinking maybe brand
awareness or product awareness to get
out there in front of people okay so
with consideration it's a little bit
different than awareness but not so
different in that we're really aiming to
get people
to think more about our product and
service and
have them take the next step so with
awareness you're introducing your
product and service with consideration
you're getting people to take the next
step and start looking for information
about the product or service you're
advertising and then conversion is kind
of that final step if you're really
after conversion you really
want that person to make the decision
okay so they're either going to buy
or use your product or service okay and
so that's the conversion objective so
you have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion and so let's go back to
awareness okay so if we look at
awareness under awareness we have brand
awareness and we have reach okay so we
look at brand awareness really what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
increase awareness about our brand or
the product in our brand so
these types of objectives i mean meaning
awareness don't really emphasize
interaction okay you're not really
trying to get somebody to purchase or or
buy something or opt into a newsletter
really your goal as an advertiser with
brand awareness is to get your product
out there so people are aware that it
exists okay let alone forget about
buying it or opting into a newsletter
you really your goal with awareness and
brand awareness is to get people to see
that you're existing your product exists
your service exists it's available and
really the aim is to create high brand
recall
amongst users rather than focusing on
generating revenue so when we say you
know high brand recall what we mean is
hey if your brand is out there and you
are
really pushing it out there amongst a
large targeted demographic audience then
the next time that audience sees your
brand they're going to be able to
associate with it it's not going to be
foreign to them or the first time
they've ever seen it you really want
them to recall hey i know that brand
i've seen that brand before okay that's
kind of the reaction you want to get
from a brand awareness hey that's a cool
looking logo or man that product looked
interesting now i'm going to take the
next step so that's what brand awareness
really needs to do it needs to create
that recall for that for your audience
okay so let's take a look now at reach
so with reach reach ensures that
our advertisement is seen by the maximum
number of people within our target
audience and budget so with reach we're
really trying to reach or get our ad out
there to as many people as possible
given who we're trying to target and
given the amount of money we have to
spend so it helps to target a smaller
audience to visit your website watch
your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's with reach we're
just really trying to get it out there
okay so let's move on to
consideration so we talked about
awareness we talked about brand
awareness and reach
with consideration
we have you know people who are willing
to take that next step okay so if we're
targeting a specific demographic and
we're looking at consideration we really
want them to do something with our ad we
don't want them just recall it or see it
for the first time we want them to take
that next step and so with consideration
we have traffic so if we have an ad you
know the least we want somebody to do
who's seen our brand before is at least
click on our ad okay so we want people
to
you know click on our ad
and go to our website really that's a
goal of consideration is hey i know that
brand i've seen that brand before let me
click on this and see what they have to
offer so this might involve them
listening to a podcast or reading an
article or being introduced to an app so
really you're setting the stage for
further down the funnel by further
introducing them to something that's on
your website so you really want them to
take that next baby step the next baby
step is clicking on the ad going to your
site and further
educating themselves about your
particular product or surface so
facebook shows these advertisements to
people within your target audience based
on their past behavior okay so that's a
great thing about facebook it's you can
really really get targeted here with
your audience okay so engagement so we
talk about traffic we're going to talk
about engagement so these types of ads
are useful when we want users to engage
more with our ad for example we can you
know really have an advertisement or
post that will allow people to like it
they can respond or even take advantage
of an offer so that's what we mean by
engagement we really want people to
react positively within facebook about
our ad or our post okay so it can help
with building engagement an engagement
audience for your facebook page that can
be used for future advertising campaigns
so
we're really getting people to
take that next step and what's that next
step if they don't go to our website
they can like what we have to say and
then we can have app installs so that's
another option to us for consideration
so app installs are great if we want to
send users to an app store for example
so they can download our app so for
really really pushing an app that we
just developed then an app install could
be a good opportunity under
consideration to allow that user to take
the next step
and download your app so that that at a
later stage they can go and interact
with the app we have video views so
video views are are good advertisements
when you're promoting your product or
service and you really want a high
number of views so remember early on we
were talking about the types of ads
available on facebook we talked about
video views how they get 10 to 30
percent more
engagement well that's really what we
want videos to do under consideration we
really want people to understand what
we're trying to do and really engage
with our product and so they could turn
around and like it they could turn
around and
push it out to their friends so video
you we know is high engaging with an
audience and so having a video allows
you to really allow that video to
potentially go viral okay so video views
help users engage and enables the
creation of an audience which can be
used for future advertisements okay so
highly engageable you know interactive
allows people to
you know really
really take that next step with your
product or service by really getting to
know what you're all about okay then we
have lead generation so lead generation
is interesting because remember those
leads that we mentioned in the when
we're talking about the type of ads that
facebook has to offer well lead ads or
you know if you have a lead generation
type ad
really what you could do is you can just
collect the information so really
somebody's interested in your product or
service right away then you can generate
a lead ad and allow them to say hey you
know what i'm interested i'm going to
sign up for your newsletter or yes i'm
interested in your product or your
future any future giveaway or promotion
you have to offer here here's my email
address here's my name here's my phone
number so lead ads are great for
consideration because somebody knows
your ad they've likely engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your crm
so for example salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point so that's consideration so
we have a lot of good options available
to us under consideration you know we
could drive traffic uh video views app
installs just regular engagement you
know and then we got legion so we got a
lot of opportunities for consideration
if you're really trying to target people
who are already familiar with your brand
or product or service and then last but
certainly not least we have messaging so
with messages you know these ads aim to
convert a user's interest in a product
to a successful sale or conversion so it
targets people who are more likely to
respond through messenger so facebook
messenger is a service that is
integrated nicely in with facebook and
so with facebook messenger you know you
can communicate with that person
directly just through messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or it can be a
rep who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service so you can use
messenger to your advantage you can talk
right away to somebody who is really
interested in considering your product
or service so this is kind of the
capstone of consideration because it
takes into account one of facebook's
most popular features which is messenger
and allows you as an advertiser to use
that feature to engage with your
targeted audience directly let's turn
our attention to the last objective
which is conversion so under conversions
we have conversions product catalog
sales and store visits so
for conversions really this is the end
of the funnel this is really the part of
the funnel where we want people to take
action so
ads related to the objective of
conversions really aims to increase you
know whatever the goal is of your
website so if it means ups or
registrations for your services or sales
or downloads or any desired action on
your website then that's the conversion
okay so that's what we're aiming to
achieve when we are tying our ads to
conversions okay so you have conversions
and you have you know pure product
product catalog sales so for product
catalog sales these could be ads to help
promote your ecommerce store or other
products in your store portfolio you
know so think of amazon think about all
the products they have on their website
you know they are probably likely going
to choose you know product catalog sales
because it really will help really push
traffic to the store and really get
somebody to convert either in a for a
particular product or get them to look
at other product categories and buy
something there so a really really
product catalog sales are really great
for future campaigns when you're really
looking for sales and then we have store
visits and so store visits really help
direct traffic to your location and
really helps deliver ads based on your
users current location okay so if we
really want to get somebody to the store
if you have a brick and mortar store for
example then you can use store visits as
your objective under conversions to
really drive traffic to that location so
that's what store visits are we really
want people to you know take that next
step get to your store and check out
your store and purchase so that's what
store visits are under the conversion
objective so within each of these
advertisement objectives we can create
split tests also known as a b testing
and the reason why we call it a b
testing because what you're doing is
you're testing
one variable from the other so really
you have two advertisements that really
are the same except the only difference
is there's one thing that's altered from
the other so in this example we have a
with one promotion and then we have b
which is the same audience same
everything except a different promotion
so you're really changing one variable
when you do a split test and so that's
available to facebook just like any
other type of advertising let's say you
do you know search advertising on google
split testing's available let's say you
do email marketing split testing is
available with subject clients
facebook's no different it allows split
testing or allows you to use two
versions of the same ad i'm able to
change one of those parameters so you
can see really what ads performs best
that's the whole idea behind a split
test okay so if it's the original sales
sale of 25
off then hey so be it you know it works
because you tested it against another
variation and then the great thing about
testing it never ends so if 25 off works
over say two thousand dollars off then
you try something else to see if that
will increase sales that's the whole
idea behind testing is you only want you
always want to see what works okay so
really what it comes down to is it can
be really it could be a promotional
offer or it could be something as simple
as changing the call to action you know
a different color on the call to action
it could be anything you want to test as
long as you're able to you know figure
out what works and then apply what works
so you can continue to improve your
advertising that's really the whole idea
behind a b testing okay so it really is
identifying an element you want to test
and then really once you identify that
element and you test it and you know it
wins then you can move on other things
to figure out what else works so if you
tested the promotion then go on to the
cta so
you could test things like
colors and call to actions and imaging
and messaging and positioning and you
could play around with your target
audience and test a segment of a target
on ends against another so
there's lots of things you could test
when you a b test the most important
thing to note though when you a b test
is you always want to keep in mind what
metric you want to measure the test up
against so some of the metrics you could
use are click-through rate which is ctr
cost per click cpc you can use
conversion rate also known as cr or just
clicks the whole idea is when you do a
test and you're testing a promotional
offer you're testing even the call to
action you need to measure that up
against a metric so that metric is
what's going to determine the winner and
so
it doesn't have to be overly complicated
it can be as simple as testing you know
one call to action against another and
determining which one gets more clicks
and if one gets more clicks than the
other then hey
you know you have a winner okay let's go
through the steps of creating a new
campaign on facebook using facebook's
ads manager so you're gonna log into
facebook.com
ads manager and you're just gonna click
on the create new campaign button and
when you do that you're going to see a
screen that looks just like this and
you're going to go through a series of
steps so as we presented earlier the
first step is always choosing your
objective so we have awareness
consideration and conversion so recall
that awareness was getting your brand
out there to people who never seen your
brand or product or service before so
it's a matter of trying to reach as many
people as you can to get your brand out
there and so you have brand awareness or
you have reach remember one is
controlled one is uncontrolled okay so
reach is a little bit more control
because you can set your budget okay and
you can control your budget a little bit
better so brand awareness is just
getting it out there having facebook
plop it in front of
the ad in front of as many people as
possible uh with reach you are trying to
maximize how many people you show your
ad to but it is a little bit more
controlled against the budget okay
either way choosing awareness is going
to set the objective of trying to
maximize your exposure for your brand
your product or your service okay if
somebody has already seen your brand or
somebody's already familiar with your
product or your services then you may
want to choose the objective of
consideration and so these are people
who again are already familiar who you
want to take that next step remember
facebook is an environment where you're
targeting a specific audience so you're
targeting people you know have likely
seen your brand product or service so
you want to take that next step that's
what you want them to do okay so here
under consideration we have traffic
engagement app installs video views lead
gen or messages all of these choices are
getting somebody to do something for you
for example app installs you want them
to install your app or engagement you
want them to like or share your post
video views watching your video or
messaging you want them to interact with
you via facebook's messenger
uh feature so all of these are
interactions of some sort where
somebody's taking that next step they've
seen your brand they're interested but
you they're not ready quite ready to
purchase yet okay so that's what
consideration is then you have
conversion this is people in the funnel
who you know or think you know want to
convert and when i say think you know
meaning you know you're really targeting
people who you've targeted before
who
maybe has purchased from you before or
is exactly the type of audience you're
looking to purchase okay so you have
conversions you have catalog sales and
you have store traffic meaning driving
foot traffic to a store okay so these
are people further down the funnel who
you don't necessarily want to take a
smaller action like just share your
facebook post or provide their email
address and name okay so you want them
to purchase so these are three marketing
objectives you're gonna choose from
okay so we're just gonna choose
conversions for the sake of this example
and then when we go to choose
conversions remember we can create a a b
split test okay so that's a choice you
should always choose because you always
want to be testing something okay in
this case we might want to test the ad
we might want to test say the call to
action because we're looking for
conversions so it could be as simple as
having one ad with a buy more and the
other way that says hey check out our
website so you have that option to a b
split test and then you have budget
optimization which basically allows you
to
set your budget evenly across your
different ads okay and so what
facebook's gonna do is basically make
sure that the best performing ad is
gonna be seen more often so that's
budget optimization you're maximizing
your budget towards an ad or ads
that
you want to be able to have more control
over in terms of what's working and
what's not working versus not selecting
this option your ads are just going to
randomly show and there's not going to
be any necessary control over how much
spend each head gets so that's the first
step in creating your campaign it's
always choosing your objective with a
few options built in
so the next step in the process
is ad set
okay and as you can see here before you
even get to ad set what uh facebook is
prompting us to do is look at
basically how the a b test is gonna work
so
here they're explaining how an a b split
test works okay so
basically what an a b split test does is
serve up 50 50 the original versus a
variation of the original okay so that's
more or less how an a b split test works
and so facebook is doing us some good by
showing us this messaging okay because
that's what we chose now
notice we chose conversions objective
okay so what we're going to be required
to do is put a conversion pixel on our
website so that facebook can actually
track conversions and so what we want
people to do is purchase
and so what we need to do then is add a
facebook pixel to our website so that
facebook can actually track how many
people purchase from your campaign so
this is very important and so if you're
driving traffic to your website and you
want them to convert then you need to
make sure all the tracking's in place
so the next step in setting up your ads
is setting up an offer so if you have an
offer that you want to provide go ahead
and select on because the default is set
to off okay what you could do is you can
associate it with
your particular
company page
on facebook and then you're going to
create your offer so i'm going to put my
offer title i'm going to put a little
bit more details in there i can put an
end date when the offer expires in a
specific time so
based on what you put this is what
people is going to see with the ad and
here you have the redemption section
where you can have people redeem the
offer online or online and in store so
if it's online you need to provide
facebook with the url
where people can go and redeem that that
promotion that offer and then you have a
chance an opportunity to add a
particular code so you don't necessarily
have to have a code with your offer it
could be a one-time code it can be a
unique code okay or unique codes okay
and then you have an advanced option
here and this advanced option is pretty
important because if you're
setting up an offer and you only want a
specific number of people to see that
offer then and you don't want them to
share that offer then what you could do
is hide the share option so that way
people won't be able to share the
promotion with friends or family or
whatnot now they could still copy and
paste the link of the offer but they
won't be able to easily do it with the
share option
and uh here you can put some terms and
conditions
so that's the offer okay and it's pretty
intuitive in the wizard
my recommendation is you should always
put out an offer to get people to
you know again your objective is to get
people to convert so an offer always
helps incentivize conversions
okay here we have our variable because
we're testing we're split testing okay
so
here we're we're choosing what we want
to split test so if we choose creative
basically what we're doing is we're
telling facebook we want to test are
creative our ad and so now what we're
going to do is we're going to select the
audience and so we could choose a custom
audience a look-alike or all so here you
can see we have a look-alike and it'll
look like basically is basically what
facebook does is they're trying to
find people who are very similar to your
customers okay so that's who you want to
target people who look like your
customers on facebook okay so you can
choose a look-alike audience you can
choose a custom audience if you already
have one
so we're going to create a new custom
audience here
and
basically what we want them to do is
website traffic
and we're just going to call it website
traffic and basically it's going to be
all website visitors
okay so we're going to create this
audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell facebook okay if our audience is
all website visitors where are those
visitors going to come from so we want
to choose a location so it could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the location or
traveling in a location okay so here you
can see we have it set to united states
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose areas or cities
and even exclude areas
you can even upload locations in bulk so
if you have a specific set of locations
you can upload that
after you choose your location you're
then going to choose your age so
here you have
if you look all the way down to 13 years
of age and then your range goes all the
way up to 65 years of age
then we have our gender we can choose
both men and women or just men and just
women and then we can target a specific
language if we want to target spanish
people or people who speak spanish then
we can choose spanish notice we can add
multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting for example we can do interest
or specific behavior so if i click
suggestions then for example facebook's
going to offer us up some suggestions so
if we want to target people who have an
interest in foreign language or charity
and causes or mindfulness or it could be
specific job titles okay so we can get
really detailed with our targeting we
also have connections so who do we want
to target so are these people who like
our page who are friends of people who
like our page we can also exclude people
who like our page okay so remember your
advertising is tied to a facebook page
however
you could still drive that traffic to
your website but what facebook does is
once you connect
your ad or your campaign to a facebook
page then they have an idea of the
profile then they have an idea of what
type of community you have on facebook
okay so that really helps them offer you
more detailed targeting in the form of
connections okay so when we're done we
could save the audience
so i'm just gonna name it uh
english and spanish click save okay now
i have my audience saved and the
important thing here is that this
audience is saved we can use it at a
later date or if we're setting up a new
campaign we can pull from the same
audience under use a saved audience
so if i just type in english and spanish
you'll see my audience here
okay and we can always edit it if we
need to okay so next is the placements
section so here placements is where we
want to show our ads okay so we want to
be able to place our ads in the proper
placement and so what facebook does is
they actually recommend you do an auto
placement and so facebook will based on
your audience show your ad in different
spots or different placements throughout
facebook
based on the people you're trying to
target the audience okay so in this case
we're targeting both spanish and english
okay and we're targeting 13 to 65 year
olds who live in the united states and
so what facebook's going to do then
because we have automatic placement set
up is they're going to be able to place
our ads based on our target audience so
this is an option i always recommend you
do and facebook recommends as well if
you're specific
about where you want your ad to be
placed then you can just select edit
placements and notice when you select
edit placements here you have different
options not only on facebook but on
instagram as well okay and facebook's
network and in facebook messenger so you
have all these different options
available to you if you really want your
your ad placed in a specific position so
here if i just scroll over here i can
see what it looks like in a feed in
stream video
i can scroll down to instagram that's
what it looks like in a feed on
instagram okay uh you have instagram
stories if i want to go and advertise on
facebook messenger then i have some
options here
in
messenger inbox or sponsored messages
okay so you have a lot of options
available under edit placements meaning
picking your placement specifically but
again i recommend as does facebook just
go with the recommended placements for
now unless you're really clear and you
really understand how
facebook works and where these
placements are actually going to be but
remember if you choose edit placements
and place it in a specific position
let's just say on messenger inbox
remember your audience may not be there
so going with the automatic placements
you know is a way for facebook to help
you get your ad in front of the right
audience
here the next section delivery
optimization okay how much of our ads
are optimized and delivered so
remember we chose conversions here so
we're going to optimize our ads for
conversions
so what facebook's going to do is take
into account each conversion that each
ad is getting and they're going to show
that ad that's getting more conversions
more often than the ads that aren't
getting as many conversions
okay so they're optimizing the ad
delivery based on
how many conversions each ad gets and
there's an option in here as well so
you can put a cost control in place so
you have an average cost per purchase
okay so facebook will aim to get the
most purchases and spend your entire
budget okay if you put in an average
cost per purchase so for example if i'm
selling t-shirts i may not want my
average cost per purchase to be
twenty dollars because i'm not going to
make any money so i'm probably going to
choose maybe two three four even as high
as five dollars on a cost per purchase
because i want to make sure i'm not
spending a lot of money just to get a
purchase so you have that option
available to you to put in as a cost
control
and here we have a conversion window
and so what this conversion window is
going to do is
you know help
facebook
optimize your ads a little bit better
based on the number of conversions that
happen in this
window okay so you have some other
options in here you want to do standard
delivery
ad scheduling you can run your ads on a
schedule
or you can run them all the time
okay
and then moving down to the next option
in our ad set
is we have split test and uh split test
budget and schedule so
we have the opportunity to put a budget
in place for ads okay and we can
schedule the the a b test to start
running immediately if we want to or we
can have the a b test run at a specific
date and we can have it run for a
specific period of time so this goes all
the way back to the first option where
we chose a b split test on step one so
we have a series of options available to
us for the split test
okay once we
have all our options in place okay we're
going to click continue
and then the final step is actually
setting up our ads okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
name our ad in this case add a okay it's
going to be tied to a facebook page
it's going to be tied to an instagram
account
and then we can choose the format of our
ad so remember we have a lot of
different options available to us on
facebook we have the carousel which
allows us to have
multiple images scrolling horizontally
we can have that single image ad we can
have a video we can have a collection of
images
so we have a lot of options available to
us
and then what we could do is we can link
up
our ad to a specific page okay now
before we do that we want to be able to
upload our images okay so we're going to
manually choose images videos and links
okay
and then we're going to add some text to
support that image
okay and so when we add text in for our
ad we have the option of setting up a
headline actually it's not an option
it's actually mandatory the description
is actually optional okay but my
recommendation is you want to add a
headline that's going to grab attention
and you want to add a description to
support that headline so i always
recommend
putting in a description and then once
you do that you're going to add your
destination url
and then you're going to be able to
preview your ad okay so
if we have an image here okay we can
just say hey this
come check out
our new product and so as i add
this information i'll be able to view it
on the right side
okay so it looks like facebook at this
point is not able to view the image but
normally you're able to see a preview in
this case it's on the mobile news feed
so if we drop down we can see desktop
right column okay so we need to really
choose our images so we're going to
change an image here let's see if i can
choose another image
okay i'm going to choose an image here
and so now i can see the image
now i can see the headline
and then i can see what it looks like
just by changing the placement okay so
if i want to choose facebook stories
whoops that's not available
if i go to
for example instant articles okay
here i can see
what my ad looks like on instant
articles
so it wasn't available on certain
placements because of the type of ad we
chose but the point being when you set
up your ad and you choose your image and
you write your headline and put your
destination url in then you'll be able
to preview it on certain placements
depending on what type of ad you chose
okay once you're once you're set up and
remember we're setting up a b testing so
that was add one now we want to test the
second ad or the variation and so
basically what we want to do is choose
the same type of format then what we
want to do is pick a variation what is
that variation going to be it could be
maybe just a different headline okay or
it could be a different url
you need to decide what it is you're
going to test
once you decide what you test you're
going to add that to variation b
once you add out the variation b then
you have both ads set up
once you confirm facebook is going to
confirm for you whether the ads meet
their criteria okay and if it doesn't in
this case you can see we have some
errors
then we need to go back and fix them so
i'm going to go back and choose single
image ad
okay so now
i can just choose my one image
so i can browse a library of images i
already have
now here's my single image ad
i'm going to add some text in there a
website url
a headline
remember you want it to be catchy okay
you can change the call to action here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type of format you choose
so remember we chose a b test so
we're going to
set up both ads add a and add b okay and
when we do that again we can have
facebook review it once they review it
we they can confirm this you can see we
still have some errors on ad a so let's
go ahead and fix that i'm going to
choose single image because that's what
add b is i'm going to browse my library
maybe i'll just test a different image
i'm going to click continue
and so basically keep everything the
same what i'll test is maybe the image
so you have to go into an a b test
knowing what it is you want to test
ahead of time okay once you do that
you're going to go ahead and continue to
add b and then once you do that
here let's go ahead and fix this error
here
the link field so let's just go ahead
and put a link in there
continue to add b
once i confirm then i have two ads
ready to go on specific placements or
excuse me automatic placements and this
option is that's the option we chose and
basically the ads are set to
optimization against conversions we have
a set budget and we're going to be able
to then once our ads go live is look at
some reports to see how they're
performing so that's the steps in
setting up a campaign
on facebook you're choosing your
objective okay then you're setting up
your ad set okay and then once you set
up your ad set with your target audience
then you're actually going through the
motions in this case we set up two ads
because we chose a b testing okay
and if you didn't choose a b testing
then you would just choose to set up the
first ad and once you do that you
confirm and voila your campaign is set
up based on these three steps okay so
let's uh review with some do's and
don'ts of facebook so we mentioned the
types of ad that facebook has we
mentioned how to set up a facebook ad
itself and choosing the right
objectives and so some of the do's
involved are what's just what i
mentioned we always want to do a b
testing on our ads whether that's again
just changing out the color we're
changing out an image you always want to
do a b testing because facebook has you
know carousel ads and because they have
you know ads that can rotate and you can
use even video with your ads you always
want to take advantage of what's given
to you and so facebook allows you to do
it do it so if you have the opportunity
to have a video ad then use the video ad
highly recommend it remember video ads
have higher engagement so definite do is
use engaging videos and imagery so you
don't necessarily have to use a static
ad or image ad you can use the carousel
for example or the presentation mode
where you can show multiple images to
really showcase your product and service
so with all the advertising that you do
you always want to align your messaging
so use a message that will stay with the
audience okay so use something that's
going to be able to trigger remember it
depends on the funnel and where you're
at so if your awareness or consideration
or conversion that has to align with
your messaging so if you're you know
targeting ads you know when you want
people to convert then your message is
going to be as such you're going to talk
to people as if you want them to convert
as if they're ready to convert and you
want to keep your message consistent and
simple so
remember the ads are available to you
and you have so many different features
available to you within those ads but
that doesn't mean you gotta convolute it
with messaging so keep your message
consistent and simple if it's brand
awareness you know definitely keep your
message simple so that people can
understand exactly what it is your
product or service is all about then you
want to alter your reach so that the ads
are shown to the appropriate audience
okay so you always want to keep in mind
who you're trying to target okay so you
don't want to target somebody who's not
in your demographic so alter your reach
so that the ads are shown to the
appropriate audience remember you have
you know reach available to you and
reach allows you to really pick and
choose exactly who you're targeting to
and how often remember you want to reach
as many people as possible but you don't
want to reach the wrong people some of
the don'ts to stay some things you want
to stay away from is you don't want to
put all your money on one campaign so
you want to separate out your budget
allocate your budget across different
campaigns and i would even take that a
step further and you know put different
types of ads in different campaigns just
to see what works so again it depends on
where you're at in the funnel if it's
just brand awareness okay maybe create a
campaign for that if it's consideration
create a campaign for that because in
consideration you might have lead ads in
there say with the awareness campaign
you may just have a single image ad okay
just to introduce your product to
somebody with a simple message so
you want to
you know definitely think about how you
want to separate out your campaigns but
don't be afraid to separate your
campaigns by the type of ads
don't put too much information in the
ads remember keep it consistent and keep
it simple that's the best thing i can
say and remember a lot of these ads are
image based so images tell a thousand
words they tell a thousand stories a
video will do the job if you have to say
too much so if you're saying too much
think about a video but if you're using
an image let the image tell the story
okay don't forget to proofread your ads
i can't stress that enough remember if
you're an awareness campaign this is the
first time somebody's seen your product
or service so you definitely want to get
the messaging not only correct meaning
consistent and simple but grammatically
correct you don't want to be so active
on your facebook page so you know when i
say being don't be so active on your
facebook page really it depends on where
you're at you're trying to introduce a
product or service so that doesn't mean
that you need to go out and tell
everybody to start buying your product
remember these people may not even know
who you are what product and service you
offer so you want to be able to approach
your audience on your facebook page in a
manner which is suitable for your
audience and then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so
you you want to be able to
you know have an image that does
correspond so if you're targeting a
specific audience with a specific
product then make sure the image on your
facebook page aligns with that okay
don't be inconsistent don't confuse the
audience you know be consistent with
your imagery as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don'ts you
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising
one of the biggest challenges facebook
faces is to keep people and businesses
happy with continuously driving change
in its functionality
recently new challenges have been added
in this light of privacy of user data
and fake news
the engine of facebook's platform to
drive all these changes is the facebook
algorithm
understanding facebook without
understanding the facebook algorithm
will limit you in efforts to use
facebook successfully by the end of this
lesson you will be able to discuss the
recent news feed changes to explain the
concept of organic reach in facebook
explain the new facebook algorithm and
its main components
identify the three active interactions
in the facebook algorithm and discuss
the future of the facebook news feed
the facebook algorithm is facebook's
secret source in which is decided which
post to show in your news feed whether
it's your friend's post or a post from a
business
facebook has recently announced a
cleanup of the news feed which
particularly affects how businesses
should use facebook it is now commonly
understood by businesses that to use
facebook successfully they have to pay
to play in this lesson you will learn
about these facebook changes in the
algorithm and what you can do to improve
your organic reach and we will close the
lesson with looking at the future of the
news feed the facebook news feed and
organic reach
the facebook news feed is the core of
the facebook platform
it was launched as far back as 2006 and
it has seen many iterations since
initially the newsfeed was the place to
see posts from your facebook friends
it was the facebook way to stay up to
date
and the facebook algorithm decides which
posts show up in what order
on top of the feed you see the what's on
your mind in which you can do your own
status updates and it allows you to add
photos videos tech people check in and
so on
facebook continuously adds new features
that you can add to your updates
newsfeed is the place where you can see
the activities of your friends and the
pages that you follow
you can access the news feed on the
mobile app or on your desktop i'm going
to show here how to access your news
feed on the desktop by clicking here on
the home button
you get access to your news feed and in
the news feed you can see all the posts
on the top of the news feed you have
your create post section i will come
back to that later and then immediately
be loaded you can see the posts of the
various
companies that you follow or the people
that that are your friends and obviously
the facebook algorithm and that's what
we're talking about in this module
will decide which posts it will show
based on
your activities of your friends how
engaging are their posts and how many
comments are they getting on their posts
and that is a whole sort of calculation
that facebook does to make sure it shows
the most engaging post in your news feed
you can see how many likes they get how
many comments so you see this is a very
engaging post ernie you can like comment
share the post yourself
if i click on the company name for
instance here then i would go to the
company page and then on the company
page i can see all the posts that
company has done and not necessarily all
those pages have made posts have made it
to your news feed companies can use
facebook by setting up a facebook page
and get people to like the page and
become a fan posts done by the company
would then show up in the news feed of
their fans
in the early days of the facebook pages
this was like the gold rush of the 18th
century in america
companies like coca-cola got tens of
millions of fans and had a tremendous
exposure on facebook and all for free
but when facebook started to monetize
their business through advertising they
needed to find a way to push businesses
in using facebook advertising the way
they did this was to slowly erode the
organic reach in facebook let's look at
this organic reach in a bit more detail
on this slide you see how organic reach
has dropped over the years and how the
facebook share price has increased they
are clearly related the share price has
gone up because a continuous drop in
organic reach forced businesses to use
facebook advertising to reach their
audiences and this strategy clearly
works what started as small-scale
advertising opportunities for businesses
on the side of the news feed than in the
news feed and then on the mobile next
businesses could advertise in videos and
with the acquisition of instagram and
the launch of the new facebook messenger
new advertising opportunities emerge for
businesses but his drive towards growing
advertising revenues came at a price
where the news feed once was the place
where friends posted updates on what
they were doing it became a garbage bin
of business posts ads trivial videos
fake news quotes and other irrelevant
stuff practically impossible for the
algorithm to manage
you may have noticed this yourself when
you checked your news feed over the
years it used to be a place where your
friends shared what they were doing
and it became a place where you could
find stuff that the facebook algorithm
believed you liked facebook knew it had
to do something about this
the growth in new users was slowing down
there was an increase in fake accounts
fake ads and fake news and on top of
that there were many issues on data
privacy that got reinforced because of
the introduction of the gdpr
so it was time for a change
the facebook algorithm today
january 13th 2018 goes into the facebook
history as a significant day so much so
that facebook lost nearly 119 billion
dollars market value in one day
it was the day that facebook announced
to clean up the news feed
zuckerberg said in a statement that they
got feedback from their community that
public content like posts from
businesses brands and media are crowding
out the personal moments that lead
people to connect with each other
zuckerberg continues that it's easy to
understand how we got there
video and other public content have
exploded on facebook in the last few
years
but what he doesn't say is that facebook
is a big culprit itself in polluting the
news feed by pushing more and more
businesses into advertising and by
offering more and more places on
facebook instagram and messenger to
advertise
and all this pollution of the facebook
news feed is driving facebook away from
the most important thing it does
helping people to connect with each
other to cut a long story short facebook
has dropped organic reach to less than
three percent
and businesses now understand that they
have to pay to play or in other words
use facebook advertising to reach their
audience
so where in the early years of the
facebook page you could build your
audience and your brand organically on
facebook and then use facebook ads to
give your reach a boost
nowadays you have to pay to play but
don't let it scare you it doesn't have
to be expensive
and facebook has created an amazing
advertising platform that can help you
achieve your business goals
and don't worry there are still ways
that you can beat the facebook algorithm
and improve your organic reach
in the next few slides and lessons we
will explain you how to do this
so let's look at today's facebook
algorithm in a bit more detail the
facebook algorithm has to make sure that
it selects the most relevant posts for
you from the thousands of potential
posts that may be displayed in your news
feed
it analyzes the posts and arranges them
in a way that you would like to see them
its aim is to give you a better overall
experience
it does this by looking at four
different elements
it looks at all the available posts
it analyzes these posts on various
factors called signals and it predicts
how you would react to the posts
it then summarizes all this with a score
and the posts with the highest score
will feature higher in your news feed
let me explain the signals to you on the
next slide
these are the signals facebook looked at
before the cleanup announcement
time spent on the content
overall engagement when it was posted
story type how informative is the post
but with the clean up facebook fine
tunes the algorithm and here is what
it's looking for now the facebook
algorithm will now put extra focus on
the engagement on a post and the usage
of other facebook tools like facebook
live or facebook messenger which means
business posts that do not drive
engagement like commenting and sharing
will not show up in the news feed posts
with short videos quotes quizzes polls
and links to other websites are now
being demoted
so what can you as a business do about
this
that's not an easy question and many
businesses are still searching for the
answer to this but let me give you a few
tips
let's look at today's top ranking
factors in facebook
top ranking factors in the facebook
algorithm
for the cleanup of the news feed
businesses use their posts to get people
to click we call this link bait to watch
a video or view an image by hovering
over it these were all passive actions
nothing to do with engagement
in the new algorithm facebook now looks
at three interactions
commenting
sharing and reacting
commenting is at the core of the updated
facebook algorithm
posts that will lead to high volume of
comments will show high in the news feed
these are the posts to generate
conversations between people comment
baiting is definitely a no-no in
facebook these days
facebook will demote posts that use
engagement bait like comment vote react
or share the algorithm will also reward
posts that are being shared
facebook likes posts that are shared
within messenger and also business posts
that have engagement when shared by
friends
but sharing alone is not enough facebook
will favor those posts that are shared
and lead to conversations between people
facebook also likes it when you use
reactions
although not as powerful as comments and
shares but it remains a form of active
engagement
facebook will promote your business
posts to more people when people use the
reactions buttons on your posts
so here are the new tactics that will
help you increase your organic reach of
your business posts call for quality
instead of quantity
post once a day instead of five times a
day
understand and analyze your fans
check when they are online and post
accordingly
think about your content
create specifically for facebook and use
video and facebook live
facebook live is a key tool that will
help you improve your organic reach
there is also a little secret in
facebook called see first when somebody
likes your
page it is set at default when they like
your page which means all your business
posts will go through the facebook
algorithm
but when you set it as c first your post
will guaranteed show up at the top of
the news feed of your fan
analyze your posts and see which posts
have lots of engagement
recycle these posts or boost them with
advertising
learn from other facebook pages
experiment with your content and
certainly make sure that you will reply
on every comment you are getting
another way of driving your organic
reach is to start using facebook groups
facebook has revamped the group
functionality recently and are promoting
groups to be used by businesses as well
and this brings us back to the basics of
marketing
by implementing these new algorithm
changes facebook now forces businesses
to understand their customer to
understand their target audiences
to understand their challenges their
motivations what they like to interact
with what they care about
because only then will you be able to
create content that sparks emotion
because emotions will generate comments
likes and shares
the future of the facebook news feed
so what will happen with the news feed
when we look into the future the news
feed has been around for more than 10
years now and the concept has become a
bit outdated obviously it won't
disappear straight away but there are
many new features emerging that will
drive new types of engagement if we look
at stories messaging facebook live and
community features like marketplace
dating
these are areas where you don't need a
news feed and where you naturally find
more engagement
instagram is a good example of this it's
a fact that today's instagram users
spend more time in looking at people's
stories than spending time on the
instagram newsfeed
but for now make sure you understand the
news feed and you understand the
facebook algorithm because that will put
you in an excellent position to take
advantage of everything that facebook
has to offer
here are the highlights of this lesson
recently facebook announced that it
would update the facebook algorithm to
only show posts in the news feed to lead
to genuine conversations between people
as a result organic reach for business
posts on facebook has dropped to the
lowest position ever most businesses now
understand that to reach their audience
on facebook they have to pay to play
which means using facebook ads
fortunately there are still ways to beat
the new facebook algorithm using
facebook live is one of them
with the increase in commerce on the
internet it is obvious that e-commerce
is also moving into facebook in fact for
years social commerce has been an
important word in mark zuckerberg's
vocabulary
enabling people to open a shop front in
facebook and then linking it to their
existing online shop
but the next step is to let all these
commerce take place
in facebook
and of course on the mobile
on top of that facebook now features
many different ad types that shops can
use to promote their products linking
back to the online store
now watch this space we've only seen the
tip of the iceberg by the end of this
lesson you will be able to set up a
facebook shop
connect your facebook shop with
e-commerce sites like shopify
create a facebook catalogue
use facebook dynamic ads to promote
specific products
and promote your facebook shop facebook
has many options for e-commerce
you can set up a shop on your facebook
page and tailor it to your own products
these products can be presented on your
page and you can advertise for them as
well and you can also add a catalog to
your shop which gives you the
opportunity to promote and target your
product advertising more specifically
setting up your facebook shop facebook
allows you to set up shop on your
facebook page by doing this you can
promote your products on facebook and
offer prices for your product you can
also add a shop now button
once people click on the products it
will take them to their website where
they can place the order they want to
buy directly into the shopping trolley
setting up a facebook shop has many
advantages you don't need an existing
catalog so you can add an unlimited
number of products you want to feature
in your shop like any shopping catalogue
facebook allows you to organize your
products in collections so people can
easily find the products they are
looking for and by activating the
messaging button people can ask
questions or even place an order
to create your facebook shop you have to
add a shop tab here on the left side
menu now the way to do that is to go to
the settings and then in the settings
you click on the templates and tabs
and then here you see you currently
haven't got the shop as a tab so you
click add tab
and that's where you have shop so you
simply click add tab and that means your
shop has been added and then you can
drag the shop to a higher level in the
tab menu
and then you can go to the settings of
the shop where you can switch it on and
off and where you can also copy the url
of the shop but the main settings of the
shop are also within the tab when you
are on your page
so now that we've installed the tab for
shop you now see on your home page of
your facebook page you here see as the
third item the shop click on the shop
and the first thing obviously you need
to do is to agree to the terms and
conditions for your shop you click
continue
and then you're basically going to set
up all the details in your shop now the
first question you need to answer
yourself is how do you want people to
buy the products from your shop they can
either send you a message to buy you can
activate that or you can drive them to
your website for instance where you have
your online shop you can just get them
to the link of that particular page
so for this demo sake let's click
message to buy and we'll click on
continue you select the currency and
then you click save and you're getting
to the next screen of your shop setup
where you're going to add products and
you can also add the description
of what you sell
so when i click here on the scribe what
simply business sells i have 200
characters to describe what my business
does so i can just add for instance for
the demo sake social media
training products and services and i
click save changes
and then i'm going to add products so if
i click on add product you're going to
add
visuals for your product you can add a
video of your product you can add name
the price whether the product is on sale
a description of the product whether you
want to share this product on your
facebook page you can give inventory
information different options about your
product like sizes and colors and how
you want it to show up on your page and
who do you want to be able to see the
the product so let's add some products
so here we're going to go to
the
photos that we're dragging
from
the the desktop so let's say that is
product one
and we're going to use that this is
social media book
and the price is
10 pounds
and the description
how to attract
date and love your
customers
on social media
i'm just gonna leave these as standard
options and i click save and now i have
my first product added
and i can add more products you see how
the product features in the product list
i can add my next product
and add a photo
select the files here i'm going to
product number two
and this is
social
media training
and we'll say that is 50 pounds
description introduction
[Music]
to social
media
keeping those settings standard that's
product 2.
and then i'm going to add product three
product three is let's say a
linkedin training
and i'm going to say
again linkedin
training the price is
50 pounds
i'm clicking save and then the fourth
product that i will be adding
this product for
and that would be the facebook training
and that would be
let's say 50 pounds as well
intro
production to
facebook
and i'm clicking save
yeah if i now do a refresh of the page
you will see that all the products show
up now there is another area where you
can actually put products in different
collections so for instance if i want to
do the facebook training and the
linkedin training in a collection
i can then click here add collection
yeah so these are the products that are
currently in the catalog but if i'm
going to add a collection i'm going to
say
training
products
yep and then i can add the products to
the collection the one i wanted was
facebook training and linkedin training
i've now added two products to this
collection and i can then click save
and if i now go back to my shop
so let's go to the page
and i'll go to the shop
you now see that i have
two
collections
that i can sort of scan and browse
through and i have my different products
so i can now start promoting my shop
through facebook advertising or by
sharing particular products from my shop
on my timeline
here you see an example of a facebook
shop you can see the desktop and the
mobile version of it on the desktop you
can see the shop tab on the left you can
decide what position the shop takes in
the tab listing you can do this in the
settings
you can see the products by category and
also you see the shop now button and the
send message
on the mobile you can show the product
specs a photo the price the details and
the link to the website in the shop
setup you can manage all aspects of
running your facebook shop you can add
products you can add collections you can
get an overview of the orders and the
pending orders the facebook shop also
allows you to tag products you can tag
up to 30 products and links in your shop
you tag these in your page posts when
people see your product tags in your
posts they can then click on the tag to
shop for the tagged product finally it
is important to connect your facebook
page with a payment engine
you can set up your payment within your
facebook page so people can buy your
products directly on your page but this
only works in the us
for those shops outside the us you need
to integrate your facebook shop with
e-commerce platforms like shopify
fortunately many online store builders
who have e-commerce engines can
integrate your existing products on
their store with your facebook page this
means that you can connect your existing
online shop with facebook and your
existing products will automatically be
uploaded in your new facebook shop
creating your facebook catalogue
to expand the capabilities of your
facebook shop you should use or set up a
facebook catalog consider this catalog
as a folder with all the products you
want to promote and advertise once
you've set up your facebook catalog you
can target people with specific product
ads based on their browsing behavior in
your shop for example when somebody
clicked on a specific product in your
shop you can target them with an ad for
that product the next time they are on
facebook
now that your shop is ready you can
target people who visit your shop or
your online shop on your website
through setting up a facebook catalog
now in order to set up a facebook
catalog you have to be in the ads
manager
and when you click here on the ads
manager you go down under assets and
that's where you see catalogues because
we've created the catalog when we set up
our shop it will automatically show up
here in your list of catalogs
and when you click on the catalog you
get to the screen where you can select
different type of ads that you want to
run for the particular products you can
see what products do we have in our
catalog what product sets do we have in
our catalog and what are the data
sources for the catalog that we're using
and there is the settings for your
catalog as well like what's the name of
your catalog what notification settings
etc
so back to the diagnostics area of your
catalog this is where you are going to
decide what type of ad you're going to
use for your catalog
so you can have generic ads or you can
have dynamic ads generic ads is
basically where you can feature
an ad for a specific product in your
catalog
or when you do a dynamic ad you can
actually
retarget people who
see specific products on your website
and they can then receive an ad with
that particular product that they saw on
your website but then on their facebook
just as a little reminder that may push
them to buy the product
so if i click on the
ad to drive traffic it will ask you
which accounts do you want to use
and then it takes you to the ad manager
where you go through the standard
process of your campaign settings your
ad account settings your ad set
and the creation of the ad itself now
i'm not going to show you all the
details of how to create an ad we've
done that in other demos but in very
important section that you have here is
that you can create an instant
experience
which is a much more multimedia type ad
that you can select within your catalog
for instance you can check which
products do we want to select for the ad
how do you want to order the products
like dynamically or you can even specify
an order are there specific sort of
collections that you want to use for
this ad
where do you want to use a cover video
or a cover image
and then what is the call to action
button that you want on your ad
and once you're done with that you're
going back into the ad set creation
where you are looking into the traffic
for the ad and the audience segmentation
and then you follow the process of
developing your ad
using facebook dynamic ads here are a
few more details about the facebook
dynamic ads
they promote products from your catalog
to people who are more likely to respond
to them because they have seen that
particular product before in your shop
or in your app or they have shown an
interest in the category for instance if
people are browsing hotels on your
website but don't make a reservation you
can then target them with specific
product ads from your catalog based on
their travel preferences
finally it is important that you promote
your facebook shop there are many ways
you can do that you can promote your
products by making them stand out
through videos and really good
photography and another effective way of
promoting your shop is by enabling
ratings and reviews
often people look at customer reviews
before making a buying decision and if
you have a physical store it will also
help if you add all your shop details
like the address and the opening times
and it goes without saying that when
people message you with questions or
even an order make sure you respond
instantly
so what did we learn in this lesson
setting up a facebook shop will enable
you to list and promote products you
sell you can even connect your shop with
e-commerce sites like shopify
you can set up a facebook catalog that
holds all the items you want to promote
across all of facebook's social media
platforms
and facebook dynamic ads automatically
promote products to people who have
expressed interest on your website or in
your app
three simple elements for promoting your
shop respond quickly to messages from
customers encourage people to leave
reviews and add the address of your
physical store
facebook live setup and how to use for
business
the final facebook tool that businesses
can use is facebook live
which basically allows you to live
stream video to your facebook audience
live streaming started on twitter a few
years ago through periscope it soon
moved to youtube and facebook and is now
a really exciting communication tool to
connect instantly with your audience
live streaming has caught the media
world by surprise
i can now be at a live concert and
stream it live to my facebook friends
where do media rights fit into this the
industry is still trying to come up with
answers
fact is that facebook live allows you to
start your own live tv program and
broadcast it instantly to a global
facebook audience and on top of this
facebook loves you to use facebook live
and will reward you for using it by
giving your facebook live post a higher
organic reach
facebook live has lots of opportunities
for businesses
it gives natural engagement by people
liking and commenting during the live
broadcast
and facebook gives you lots of
opportunities to promote the live event
before and after the live broadcast
at the end of the broadcast facebook
will ask you if you want to save the
broadcast and post it on your feed
often this leads to lots of additional
views and engagements
on this site you can see where in the
world facebook live broadcasts are
happening right now you also see a lot
of live activity in southeast asia so
let's look at some of the features
facebook live covers three aspects of
communication
first it allows you to have live
conversations with your followers and
facebook live turns these conversations
in very engaging experiences with likes
and emoticons flowing over the screen as
they come in and comments showing up as
well
second you can turn your live broadcast
into a visual story like you want to
tell it you can add filters colors texts
overlays etc
adding augmented reality features is not
far away
and thirdly you can target audiences in
multiple ways for your broadcasts and on
top of that facebook will give your live
broadcast a higher than average organic
reach allspice brazil is a great example
of a facebook live campaign
they did a two-day live broadcast to put
their anti-perspirant products to the
test
they turned it into a big marketing
campaign with which they reached over 9
million people with the time of the
broadcast
there are many ways businesses can use
facebook live it's a great tool for
promoting your products or services you
can do live tutorials or product
launches
it can be used to support your live
events
you can do a broadcast during your event
and interview an expert who attends the
event it can also be used to support
your customers
you can do a live q a ask for feedback
hold the webinar and facebook live also
lends itself for sharing news announce a
sale or organize a sales party lots of
opportunities it may take a while to
build traction with your broadcast but
if you can maintain the momentum you can
generate plenty of coverage and
engagement a good way to maintain
engagement is to turn your live
broadcasts into recurring episodes
weekly or monthly so you can build your
campaign around this and build up a
library of great content
it is very easy to start your facebook
live video when you are on your company
page what you do you click on the
publish button on your mobile and then
in the different options you see one of
them is live video you click on your
live video you immediately see what you
want on the the screen you can have
different background settings if you
want to
different filters you can select where
you want to to post
and you can then basically click start
the live button
when you start a live button
your life you can still add different
effects you can invite people you can
chat and basically we are now live if i
now would go to my other phone and let
me just quickly do that i will go to
facebook
and i will go to the facebook page
so of simply learn and i can see that on
facebook let me go here
yeah so i go to the simply simply learn
business page and i can then see that
the video is live on the page from
simply simplylearn and here i can then
engage with the page you can also see
here in the screen
that i have one viewer and that is me in
this case here you can also see that i
can like and this is i think a really
cool feature of the facebook live which
shows you the engagement that is
happening during the broadcast it can be
a thumbs up it can be a heart
it can be a
smiley face
and i've seen companies do polls
give me a smiley face if you like the
product give me a sad face if you're not
happy with the with the product and then
you can count the number of likes that
come in
in that way you can also see who is
watching and that in this case is mark
antman i can then also put in a comment
to this post and i can just say hi
and post it and that comment that will
show up
on the feed as well so a very engaging
very interactive process to run your
facebook live broadcasts so when i click
finish
then what facebook will do is will save
the video
and it will then give you the option to
save it on your news feed on your
timeline you can upload it in high
definition so when you save it on your
timeline then you can share it straight
away or you can save it on your disk i
click share and now you see that on my
business page in a minute the page the
the live broadcast will show up actually
it's already shown up here and you can
then see who was on the the video
yep you see the comment that came in and
you can see the video and you can see
the engagement in the video as well so
very powerful concept to run facebook
live broadcasts
greetings everyone this is rob sanders
and today i'm going to present facebook
advertising tips and strategies so thank
you for joining today we're going to
cover a number of tips to help you gain
a better advantage on advertising on
facebook so let's get right to it with
tip number one and with tip number one
not all advertisements need to sell
something so remember you have different
objectives on facebook you can advertise
an event you can promote a customer
story you can send traffic to your
website or you can get them to download
an app so it all goes back to your
objective so if we go to facebook and i
want to create an ad remember my first
option is to create an objective so you
have awareness you have consideration
you have conversion so depending on what
you want somebody to do that's the
objective you're going to choose so just
keep that in mind when you're setting up
your campaign on facebook you need to
align your objective with what you want
people to do tip number two we want to
use facebook messenger for advertising
so facebook messenger is a feature that
can be used with advertising on facebook
and it's a good tool it's a good
practice because it allows you to as the
advertiser to commute with individuals
directly so it's a feature that you
should take advantage of because it
allows you to quickly engage with your
target audience so that's the beauty of
leveraging facebook messenger with your
advertising the communication tools
available and for you to engage with
your target audience so it's great for
not only interacting but taking care of
any other objections that they have as
an as an audience or prospective client
so you can answer any concerns they have
right away so it's a lot more personal
and interactive than other forms of
advertising because you're directly
communicating with your audience tip
three use video advertisements i can't
stress this enough video is very
engaging in fact it's not only engaging
but it's very easy to use so if we go to
facebook really facebook is telling us
for video all we need to do is have
basically a phone handy and an app and
just to be able to upload it so with
facebook video you can really drive
awareness and you can really drive sales
when you can really make some really
splashy videos on facebook all you need
is a mobile camera so with facebook
videos it's really very easy to create
you just gotta be creative that's really
the key to videos you know they're gonna
be engaging to the end user say
something do something that's gonna
really grab their attention and get them
to do what you want them to do so these
are just some of the examples you can
see on facebook and you can see how
creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call to action great video or
great imagery good promotional use so
there's a lot you can do with video and
really make it interactive so i can't
stress video enough as an option for
facebook it really is one of the better
features of facebook advertising and
really very limited use of resources all
you need is that web camera an app and
the ability to upload that video that's
really it for video advertisements so
keep in mind and the reason why i'm
harping on those video ads is they tend
to outperform your traditional facebook
image ads and other formats like the
carousel or the presentation mode so
there's other types of formats on
facebook video tends to give it that
extra edge because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement so in this example you know
people are going to react they're going
to comment they're going to share the
video and that's what you want as an
advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it'll help you not only engage with
the person but allow that video to be
shared and expand your reach towards
your target audience so remember video
can range from a few seconds all the way
up to 120 minutes so you're really gonna
get more views regardless of how long
the video is because it's just gonna be
so interactive so just keep that in mind
it doesn't have to be full on 120
minutes it could be you know anywhere
from one to five minutes you know to me
that's probably a good range but just
know that you have that lead way if you
wanted to so remember video ads always
perform better than single image ads or
other type of image ad formats on
facebook and they also perform better
when they have subtitle support so just
keep that in mind as well because you
may have you know individuals watching
the video from you know different
countries speaking different languages
say tip four when you're placing your
advertisement where you place your
advertising will play an important role
in deciding how many people come across
it so facebook offers a number of
different options to choose from so
remember you got the news feed you got
instant articles right column you got
suggested videos so you get a lot of
options at your disposal there's lots of
other options too so you can have
facebook actually automatically place
your ads or you can specifically tell
facebook where you want to place your
ads and that's all part of the facebook
setup so if we go to facebook and then
we go to create your campaign so if we
close ad sets here is where we're going
to be able to choose our placement if we
click on choose placement we'll be able
to you know be able to allow facebook to
place it or we can edit the placement
specifically so just keep that in mind
you have a lot of different options here
again feeds and stuff articles in-stream
videos got rycom you even have instagram
so you have a lot of options available
to you so my recommendation and
facebook's recommendation is always go
with the auto placement but you could
specifically choose your placement if
you want to when you're setting up your
campaign so start the advertising on the
news feed could be recommended the news
feed is where you're probably going to
get your most eyeballs most users spend
most of their time there and it has the
highest chance of grabbing their
attention so the newsfeed could be a
good place to start again you can have
it at auto placement and your ads may be
there as well or you can specifically
choose just the news feed or other
placements so tip four just be careful
where you place your ad it's really
important you wanna place your ad where
you're going to get eyeballs so tip five
facebook ads also offer you the option
to advertise on instagram so you have
that option available to you as i
mentioned in tip four you have the
option to advertise through stories
carousel ads photo ads and video ads so
again that's all part of the ad setup
when you go to choose your placements
here you got instagram feed you get
instagram stories and again with both of
those placements on instagram you can
work with several different types of ads
including that carousel ad including
that video ad so just keep that in mind
that instagram is an option for you take
advantage of it there's a lot more
eyeballs on instagram these days and it
plays off nicely with what you're trying
to do with facebook so go ahead and give
it a try okay so let's take a quick
break from
the first few tips we went over and
let's take a look at an ad so it's an ad
break time so let's take a look at this
and this is by new scientist and so what
makes this ad so great well there's been
a lot of
shake up in the world today about fake
news you know what is fake news so new
scientist is actually playing off of
that they're mentioning hey fake news
not in our world so they're actually
playing off of that that term fake news
and so that's an attention grabber so i
think that's what makes this look so
good but this is a single image ad and
you can see here they're promoting this
ad with a promotion so try 12 weeks for
just 36 euros okay so they have a
promotion in there so and you notice
they the image of the you know the
magazine they're also displaying that
hey you can look at this digitally on a
laptop a tablet or a mobile phone so you
have other options as well so they show
you that in the image which is placed on
the right side of their messaging so for
me this is a good ad because of the
placement of the image the type of image
they're using the play on fake news and
the promotion that they're offering up
so this is really a good ad it's very
eye-catching and hopefully the promotion
is good enough to get you to sign up
okay so tip number six so tip number six
we want to continuously do a b testing
you want to always have this option
going for you you want to be able to
test variation a versus variation b
because you want to be able to find out
what works and what doesn't work with
your audience and on top of that it
helps you really put your best foot
forward by showing your best ad so by
doing a b testing you're getting
feedback from the audience and turning
that feedback into positive returns so
you're then turning your ad that does
work well in front of an audience and
you're going to continue to do that so a
b testing is always a good option so
remember when you're setting up your ad
in facebook go ahead and choose to have
your a b test set up and when you do
that you choose that option you're going
to be able to then go in and choose what
it is you want to test with that a and
then with add b so you're going to again
align your test with a facebook page
you're going to choose an ad format once
you choose your ad format then you're
going to be able to go ahead and you
know put your ad in there and then
you're going to choose your call to
action so the whole idea behind an a b
test is you want to be able to find what
it is you want to test is that going to
be the
call to action is it going to be the
messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there are lots of things you
can test with facebook on a b testing so
it's all part of the ad setup so things
you can change again are the color of
the elements imaging text the call to
action the position of the ad there's
lots of things you could test that's all
part of the facebook setup so the thing
is you want to continuously test that's
the key continuously test certain
elements of an ad so testing can be done
initially on broader elements and then
smaller finer details like statements in
your ad copy so my advice is when you're
actually setting this up on facebook you
know think ahead think what it is you
want to choose to test my advice is
maybe start out with a call to action so
if you're in facebook itself you know
you have an opportunity to test
different call to action try that that's
an easy way to test and then you know
when you test the call to action once
you find out what works and doesn't work
then you can move on to something more
sophisticated like maybe the image type
or maybe trying different types of
imagery or ad types like the carousel
versus single image so start small start
easy and then work your way up tip
number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action in your
advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
the simply learn ad about hey learn how
seo works search engine optimization so
if you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interests it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do if it's you know customers
in the buying process then that's our
objective is to get conversions then we
want to move somebody over to a product
page and get them to purchase you know
if it's focusing on just website visits
then maybe it's the objective of
consideration maybe you just want to get
people to your website to learn more
about your product so that's the whole
idea behind you know choosing uh the
right you know objective uh because you
want to align the objective with your ad
okay so tip number nine create
look-alike audiences and i'd like
lookalike audience because what facebook
does is they create an audience that's
similar to the audience you already
advertising to or customer base you
already have so in other words facebook
already has an idea of who your audience
is you can also you know provide them
with additional information like an
email list to give them a better sense
of who your audience is and then what
facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of an audience that looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a look-alike
audience so it's a great feature by
facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have one example provide facebook with
an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could target so that's
the whole idea behind lookalike audience
it's a great feature by facebook
definitely recommend taking advantage of
that why because it will increase the
number of people who will find your
advertisement relevant remember you're
targeting people who are similar to your
actual audience to your the people who
are already connected with your brand or
already liking your page so if they're
similar to those people then the chances
of them engaging with you are going to
be greater so look-alike audiences tend
to perform well because you're targeting
an audience that's very similar to your
actual audience tip number 10 so use the
golden point rule on your ad creator so
what do we mean by golden point rule
well let's take this ad here as an
example so what we want to do is we want
to divide the creative into nine equally
sized boxes so what we want to do is
draw two horizontal lines and two
vertical lines just like a tic tac toe
box and so ideally what we want to do is
place the main subject of your ad in the
cross sections of the drawn lines and so
what that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there is a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on facebook
and this one's by blue apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about this
particular ad takes into account a lot
of them okay so this is again they're
using multiple images in this ad here so
again what they're doing promotion
they're offering up a 30 off promotion
here and what they're asking you to do
is sign up to get that 30 off so you
could see the call to action we already
mentioned that at one of our tips the
call to action matches the ad so they're
asking to sign up they're using really
good imagery here and they're supporting
that with
you know some good copy and text so this
is what makes this ad so good i mean who
doesn't like good looking food or tasty
food and healthy food okay so they're
definitely taking advantage of the
imagery with a promotion and with a good
call to action and so remember we want
to a b test so blue apron is likely
testing this ad so what they could do
with this is test different imagery or
they could test a different promotion so
there's a lot they can do here on the a
b testing side so
for me if i were to test this yeah i
would probably be testing the imagery
because we want to be able to see what
images get people to sign up
alternatively we can also test the offer
as well what offer is going to get
somebody to click on that sign up button
so ideally there's a lot to do here from
the a b test standpoint and the way they
structure this ad it makes it very easy
to test so that's what makes this ad
really good is shows good imagery has a
good promotion and aligns the cta tip
number 11 so we want to place the
product in the right hand of your
creative so the right side should
contain our product imagery so why is
that why because there's been a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
placed users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the ad creative so here you can see
countdown to black friday this is an
amazon related ad and you can see the
product
is basically a litter box which is
placed on the right side so it's a black
friday ad they didn't place the image on
the left side they placed on the right
side because people tend to react
positively when the product image is on
the right side so keep that in mind when
you're placing your imagery try to place
it on the right side tip number 12 don't
use images that have more than 20
text okay so you want to use images that
are clean remember that blue apron image
we looked at that was a very clean image
of food no text overlaying the image so
we want to try and stay away from images
that have text on the overlay okay so
there's no limit to how much text you
can add to your creative but you know
facebook and myself recommend hey the
lesser text you have the more likely it
is for your ad to have its desired
impact meaning somebody's gonna click on
that ad okay so keep that in mind let
the image do the talking for you you
don't necessarily need to overwhelm the
image with words or messages tip number
13 so we want to use an ad creative
that's attention grabbing and is
relevant for your business so again
going back to that blue apron ad hey who
doesn't like good looking food good
looking healthy food green food well
switching gears we're looking at a nike
ad who doesn't like a good looking shoe
here this is a good running shoe and
nike is definitely taking advantage of
the opportunity to place the shoe
against a nice looking background so
here the image on the left you got a
nice mob looking color the shoe on the
right on a nice red background to kind
of really play into the color of the
shoe and so that's attention grabbing so
the colors kind of match and go with one
another and it tends to grab your
attention so nike's doing a good job
here of just not showing an image of a
shoe really what they're doing is put
the shoe as the central focal point and
supporting that with additional color
and they're really putting the messaging
kind of as the background behind the
shoe so they're making it as
attention-grabbing as possible here so
nike's done a good job with this ad you
know me personally i'm not the biggest
nike fan when it comes to shoes but hey
this ad definitely grabbed my attention
because now i could see you know this
shoe is really popping to me we don't
want to use clipart in your ad creative
okay and don't use low resolution
pixelated images as well we want to use
high quality imagery so and use images
that are well lit you know natural
lighting always tends to work well as as
well so when you're doing a placement
for product whether that be food or shoe
you can see here in this plated example
they're putting it on the right image
they're putting it in a natural
environment on a table on a plate with
some paper next to it you know and then
you can see
the one on the left it's of a person
holding a box with the image of plated
on it and so to me that's not stock
imagery or clip art you know that's an
actual person holding the product so
it's real life you want to make it as
real life as possible and as clear and
quality as possible so when you create
attention grabbing ads you show images
of people benefiting from your product
instead of just having the product
itself so that's always a good idea in
the case of coca-cola you know these
people are enjoying their bottle of
coca-cola well going back to the nike ad
you know they could have had a person
wearing that shoe or you know running
with that shoe that could have been an
alternative for them as well so the
whole idea is just make sure your ads
are attention getting and they grab your
attention and if you're to use people
make sure the person's enjoying it just
like on the previous image the person
holding the box we could see she's got a
smile on her face and she is enjoying
holding that box so to me you want to
use people with the images to the best
of your ability and that means use that
person who's enjoying it so that's
really going to put the product in the
forefront okay tip 14 don't hesitate to
experiment with your advertisements
creative or it's copy okay so what do we
mean by that really we want to be
refreshing our text we want to be
refreshing our images okay so
if you're going to place an ad on
facebook don't let that be the only ad
okay if you're using a single image ad
you know feel free to change out that
single image from time to time
especially if a lot of people have seen
that ad so
if you're using reach as your objective
and you're trying to reach as many
people as possible just keep in mind
that if that ad is reaching the same
people over and over again it's going to
get stale and you want to be able to
update that ad so feel free to change
out the imagery changing out the text is
just as easy okay so feel free to play
around with the text even if you're not
doing a b testing you can always change
out the text just to see hey if changing
out the text actually gets you better
engagement or meet your goals tip 15
plan your campaigns for the holiday
season okay so can't state this enough
you know towards you know october
november december there tends to be a
lot of holidays you know across multiple
religions okay so it's really the time
of year where people are in full ad mode
and audiences are in full watch mode so
advertisers are really pushing ads that
time of year especially christmas you
know and people are accepting of that
because they're used to it so you want
to be able to plan accordingly so if
you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience if you're
aligning your ad with that time of year
so during christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping so it's a time of
year where you can really really really
take advantage of increasing your sales
increasing your conversions so you want
to plan accordingly and so if you're
planning you know months in advance you
don't have to do a full year but you
know for me if i'm thinking i'm going to
do a lot of advertising during the
holiday season i'm probably going to go
out maybe once summer ends probably
august beginning of september beginning
of september seasons change a little i
might start thinking about the holiday
season and when you can plan
appropriately you can come out with
really good ads you can think about what
you want to say and so in this case you
know target this particular ad is really
promoting black friday so black friday
is the day after thanksgiving in the
united states and so here they're
letting you know black friday's here and
there's deals to be had so planning in
advance gives you an opportunity to
really really tweak your messaging and
come up with some good creative ideas so
let's take another break and let's look
at another
good looking ad this example we're going
to look at dell okay so dell i've seen
their ads all over facebook they do a
lot of different advertising types
between videos carousels and this is a
single image ad they're really trying to
do is get you over to the storefront so
you can buy one of these good looking
you know dell computers okay so
you know here again they're promoting
their latest computer the dell inspirion
3000 series all in one desktop so to
them anytime they create a new product
they're going to go ahead and put out a
new ad for that product and here they're
putting a little bit of a different
twist on it if you notice the ad itself
is just the image of the product there's
really no promotion here they're letting
the product image speak for itself
they're really showing you hey look how
good this computer looks you know this
is our new model and you know we got a
shop now ctas if you're interested go
ahead and click on that shop now so
they're really putting the effort into
the image itself you know they're not
offering any promotion you know no
discounts you know what you see is what
you get with the image and you click on
it you're going to go right to their
storefront so dell does a good job of
really you know cranking out their new
products whenever they go to market so
tip 16 shorten the amount of time
between retargeting your audience so
target people have visited your website
within the span of a month or two weeks
so retargeting is reaching out to people
who you've already engaged with so if
somebody has seen your ad or somebody's
went to your website somebody's even
purchased from you before you have the
opportunity to reach back out to that
person so how often you reach out to
that person or how long between their
initial engagement and when you retarget
them really does depend on what it is
you're selling so if you're selling a
pair of shoes if you're nike then
chances are somebody's looking for a
pair of shoes it's not going to be a
long purchase window meaning they're not
going to wait two three months so
if i'm nike and somebody's seen my ad
i'm probably going to target that person
in a short period of time for
retargeting so it really depends on your
product but you don't want to wait too
long between the time they've been
initially engaged and the time you
retarget so it really depends on your
product you know again if you're selling
merchandise you know retail it's
probably going to be a smaller time
frame if you're dell computers you know
that's a bigger purchase somebody's
going to take their time so you know you
want to target people
you know for their dell computer
probably you know over a longer period
of time okay so just keep the product in
mind you don't want to wait too long you
don't want to keep it too short so you
want to find that nice balance of when
you could retarget someone okay tip
number 17 keep altering the hook of your
ad copy what do we mean by altering the
hook so here you can see a couple of
different options option one you know
we're talking about hey if you're
interested in getting some dmca
certification you know this is what you
need to do option two a little bit
different of a hook hey start your
journey to get your dmc ca certification
so you know just altering the way you're
trying to talk to somebody is really
what we're after here on tip number 17.
you have an ad especially the text
remember we always want to refresh that
copy but if you're testing it try
different hooks try different ways to
talk to people okay it always works well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so an effective
strategy would be to create multiple ads
with different hooks and see what
performs best so this is an option for a
b testing okay you have an option to add
messaging go ahead and talk one way in
one option and then you know tweak that
messaging tweak that hook a bit in
option b and see what resonates with
people so that's a good option for a b
testing is always you know look at the
way you're going to try and you know get
somebody to convert tip number 18 okay
respond to lead add responses as soon as
possible so remember one of your ad
formats is a lead ad okay so if you have
a lead ad basically what you're asking
somebody to do is add their name their
phone number and their email if you get
that information don't sit on it react
to it just like the messaging the
facebook messenger how it's almost
instantaneous think of the lead ads the
same way okay you have somebody who's
engaging with your ad by providing
information you don't want to sit on it
you want to respond as soon as possible
in fact you know when you do engage that
person let them know you're available on
facebook messenger so they can actually
then reach out to you via facebook
messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue interacting with you so there's
no real good rule of thumb here except
for do it as soon as possible okay tip
number 19
add scarcity to your advertisements so
what do we mean by that well in this
example we could see the top 100
registrations get free access so by
putting this into your ad copy we're
hoping your prospects are more inclined
to buy your product due to that fear
that they're not going to be one of the
first 100 registrations okay so it
allows you to really put some sense of
urgency
in the ad to get somebody to react so
that's what we mean by you know scarcity
okay so by doing so it could affect the
long-term credibility you know we don't
want to come across as fear-mongering by
any means but hey if your promotion is
the first 100 registrations get free
access then why not you know go ahead
and put it in there some other examples
could be you know only three days left
to register or
first 50 get 50 off or you know hurry
now there's only two days left so
there's other language you can put to
play around with the language but if you
only have certain slots available or
certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy to get people to react and so
that's the whole idea behind you know
the scarcity is you want to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here if you're
interested go ahead and take advantage
tip number 20 keep track of your ad
relevance scores so your ads do get
scored so the score ranges from 1 to 10
okay so what that score does is it's an
indicator to signify the quality and
engagement levels so you know if your
score is between one and six then the ad
isn't reaching the relevant audience and
your audience isn't reacting to it
however if your
relevance score is between seven and ten
then your ads are reaching the
appropriate audience and you're getting
a lot of interaction so keep an eye on
that you know the lower the number that
means hey we're not get our ads not
getting to the right audience and if
it's not getting to the right audience
our audience isn't going to react to it
so it all starts with making sure you're
reaching your audience with your ad when
your ad is reaching your audience and
you're doing a b testing your audience
is going to react to one of those two
ads so that's always going to help your
relevance score so keep an eye on that
relevant score okay so let's take
another break here and let's take a look
at an ad here by blue bottle coffee okay
so i'm a big coffee drinker myself i
frequent blue bottle in san francisco a
lot and so here this is a nice image a
nice close-up image of coffee and i
really like this notice there's really
no call to action here okay so they're
putting their website url the domain
bluebottlecoffee.com
they're saying hey we source great
coffees we roast them to perfection and
get them to you fresh so i can vouch for
that really putting their brand out
there okay so this is more of a brand
awareness type ad that's their objective
their objective is if you're going to
drink coffee at some other location or
with some other brand hey take a look at
ours you know we got good coffee too we
roast them pretty good and and we make
sure that you get them fresh that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
introduce their brand to you so this is
a good example of a brand awareness ad
single image ad they're definitely
making use of the added the image itself
you know with a nice close-up shot of
that roasted coffee so that's what makes
this ad so special brand awareness you
know the image is telling us hey this
coffee looks pretty pretty good it looks
nice and roasted it looks pretty fresh
and
maybe i'll give blue bottle coffee a try
so that's why they're putting their
domain there okay so it's a good brand
awareness ad and the hope is to convert
some people over to their brand okay so
tip number 21 include emojis in your ad
copy okay so emojis we know are popular
you use them in text use them on social
media
i mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays that you could pick and choose
from they are really specific and so
here you can see in the case of simply
learn hey if you're taking a digital
marketing course for simply learn it
doesn't hurt to have some emojis support
that that message so you always get the
thumbs up to get emoji you know the
image of the graduation you know that's
a good emoji so you know you always want
to align you know really fun relevant
emojis with your messaging it kind of
just helps it stick out a bit and people
resonate with emojis and so it doesn't
hurt to add those emojis in your ad copy
and especially if your competition is
not using emojis you want every
advantage you can
to have your ad stick out so emojis is a
good way to get your ad to stick out tip
number 22 use utm parameters to your ad
which can feed into your google
analytics account and provide tracking
information so i can't stress this
enough if you're using google analytics
to track your campaigns then you want to
use utm parameters so what do we mean by
utm parameters well let me show you an
example so all you need to do is type in
utm tracking or url builder in google
and then you're going to actually get to
this page here so what this does this is
a tool to help you create utm tracking
so if we're simply learn and we want to
advertise and drive the audience to a
specific page in this case artificial
intelligence masters program page so
this is going to be the url but we want
to append that url with some utm
tracking parameters our campaign source
parameter we're going to put facebook
because that's the source that we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
facebook is cpc which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name ai engineer to
identify
what it is that campaign is related to
so notice that the only required
parameter is campaign source in this
case we're going to put facebook but we
can also use campaign content if we want
to differentiate the different ads that
we have so you can use campaign content
parameter as well you don't have to the
only required parameters campaign source
my recommendation go all lowercase okay
and then when you're done you have a url
that you can use in your advertising so
when somebody actually goes to that url
notice the url includes the utm tracking
and then analytics is going to be able
to pick up that campaign from where
facebook the medium is going to be cpc
and the campaign in this case is going
to be ai engineer and that's what you're
going to look for in google analytics so
it helps you track your ads more closely
because if you don't use utm tracking
for example on facebook then analytics
might you know interpret that traffic
coming from that ad as you know organic
social so we want to be able to identify
specifically the campaign you're running
by putting in different variables for
those parameters so that's what utm
tracking is you want to use it for all
your facebook advertising okay so it
really helps you you know in analytics
identify how your campaign's performing
not only is it driving traffic but is
the campaign converting for you so if
you're trying to get somebody to sign up
for a class then analytics is going to
help us measure those conversions but
with utm tracking we can bridge the gap
between how many people facebook
delivered or drove to our site from the
ad and how many of those people actually
converted so utm parameters help bridge
that gap tip 23 use exclusion marketing
to improve your facebook return on
investment by not including people who
have already taken the action desired by
you okay so this is a very key feature
here so if we've already advertised and
people have reacted to our ad and has
subscribed they have subscribed then we
don't want to target that person again
so that's what exclusion marketing is we
want to be able to
you know target people that we're really
after so
if you know somebody's looked at our ad
and did not convert or did not go to our
website or to not download something or
whatever it is we wanted them to do then
those are the people we wanted to focus
in on okay so in this case exclusion
marketing we're going to exclude people
who have subscribed in this case we're
going to retarget people meaning
advertise again to people who have not
subscribed so that's what the exclusion
marketing feature does it helps you
really hone in on where you're targeting
and retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24 track the right
metrics for your business so keep your
eye on important metrics what are those
metrics you know those are going to be
kpis kpis are key performance indicators
and kpis differentiate from metrics
because kpis are related to business
goals so track the right metrics for
your business what are the right metrics
for your business more than likely it's
going to be conversions or conversion
rate but you could be running a brand
awareness campaign just like uh blue
bottle coffee did and so if you're
running a brand awareness campaign then
maybe your kpi or metric is going to be
a click okay or click-through rate how
many people are actually reacting to our
ad okay so you always want to align the
right metric with your business okay
it's just very important that you're
measuring against the right metric if
you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of how you judge the
campaign performance another set of
metrics could be reach and frequency so
reach and frequency allow us to measure
how many people saw the ad and post
engagement can determine how many users
are reacting to your ads cpc helps us
determine the cost effectiveness or how
much we're paying for every click you
could see that information in your
facebook ad manager for example if i go
to facebook's ads manager here i'm
looking at some some ads that we're
running here what can i see i can see my
reach how many people i'm actually
reaching the frequency in which they're
seeing my ad notice i can see my
relevancy score i can also see my cost
per result i can see the total clicks so
i have a whole set of metrics available
to me really what i want to do is pick
and choose the metrics that are most
important to the ad i'm running okay so
if it's reach am i reaching the full
amount of people possible if i'm running
a brand awareness campaign or it could
be some other metric like conversion so
we want to be able to align the right
metric with the right ad tip 25 take
advantage of facebook's location
tracking tool for your advertisements so
facebook allows us to advertise up to 25
countries with different states
provinces cities districts and zip codes
so we can really hone in location wise
on where we want to target so facebook
allows us to do that so basically it
could be somebody in a particular area
or people who have been recently been
there or traveling to that location or
actually lived there so really you could
hone in on a specific location based on
certain set of criteria so with this you
could take your marketing to the next
level by approaching your competitors
customers by offering them better
discounts so that's the whole idea
targeting your advertising on a specific
location and then knowing that your
competitors are there you can really put
out some really good ads with some
really good offers to really convert
some of those people in that audience
okay let's take a look at another ad
okay so grammarly this is an ad that
they've uh put out there and again you
notice there's no real true call to
action associated with the single image
ad here it's all about messaging here
they're saying hey download it free
today okay and so it's a browser
extension that they're promoting and
really they're trying to get you to
identify or identify with this
particular brand that offers a specific
product so they do have a promotion in
there it's brand awareness hey your life
is about to change i mean the messaging
is pretty you know matter of fact
they're trying to get you to hey i need
this in my browser as an extension so
for me this ad is all about the
messaging here okay so with grammarly
you know if you're in gmail you're in
word you're in outlook they got you
covered by using their browser expansion
it's free and by using it it's going to
make your life a lot easier so for me
the ad works from a messaging standpoint
not really big on the imagery but it's
really about this is who we are and
we can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life's about to change they've
got my attention now let's get started
first off let's have a look at an
introduction to facebook
facebook was first launched in february
2004 and was initially known as the
facebook
in 2005 it removed the from its name and
it has now become the facebook we all
know today
it is now the world's most popular
social media and social networking
service
next let's have a look at instagram
it was launched in 2010 for ios and then
in 2012 for android
by kevin systrom and mike krieger
instagram has now evolved to become one
of the fastest growing social media
platforms in the world
in april 2012 thanks to its popularity
it was acquired by facebook for
approximately one billion dollars in
cash and stock
now let's compare some stats between
facebook and instagram
first let's have a look at the worldwide
stats
first off facebook
like i mentioned earlier facebook is the
largest social media platform in the
world
reaching almost 60.6 of the internet it
has 2.5 billion monthly active users and
approximately 1.6 billion active users
in fact as of jan 2020 the u.s has
approximately 190 million and india has
approximately 280 million facebook users
an indication of a market that's still
ripe for the picking now let's have a
look at instagram
instagram although having released
significantly later earns its title of
the fastest growing social media
platform with 1 billion monthly active
users and 500 million daily users
in the united states there are
approximately 120 million and india has
close to 88 million instagram users
next up let's have a look at the next
statistic
age group of the user base
first off facebook
although there's a general opinion among
the younger population that facebook
isn't hip or isn't used all that much
anymore
this statistic has something different
to say
turns out more than 65 percent of
facebook users are between the ages of
25 and 34.
for instagram it's no surprise that 71
percent of the user base are under the
age of 35.
next let's compare the usage time of
both these platforms
let's take facebook first
in the united states users spend
approximately 1 hour on facebook every
day
in india users spend an average of 3
hours a day on facebook
shockingly high numbers for a platform
that's assumed to be dead isn't it
on the other hand in the united states
users spend 23 minutes on average on
instagram
in india users spend approximately 45
minutes
now for the most important stat
marketing
for facebook 86 percent of marketers use
it for advertising
instagram is used by 71 percent of
businesses for their marketing
requirements
now let's have a look at some industries
that can work well on both these
platforms
if you do belong to any of these
industries if you're not taking
advantage of these platforms you're
missing out
so let's have a look at some industries
that can capitalize on facebook
food and beverage companies news and
media
e-commerce
automobile
and packaged goods
next time you're on facebook take a
closer look at your feed there's a good
chance you'll see most of these
industries post on it
next up instagram we have industries
like fashion
athleisure cosmetics automobiles and
food and beverages
i can guarantee that if you take a
closer look you can find all these
industries advertising on instagram
now let's take a closer look at how
facebook can help with marketing
first off let's have a look at facebook
business pages
now these are basically platforms where
you can create an online presence for
your organization for free
moreover they've got some great
advantages to offer you as well
first off your business page can keep
your customers or potential customers
informed it can be about a new product
launch a webinar a live broadcast a new
store opening anything whatever it is it
can go on your facebook business page
it connects people with your products
and services with your page you get
greater visibility letting people know
about the products and services that you
offer you can offer customer service as
well in fact according to american
express ninety percent of users use
customer service as a deciding factor
for whether or not they continue to do
business with an organization so
customer service is pretty important
like i mentioned earlier your business
page provides a place where you can
offer your followers offers and other
advantages
and finally the page lets you build a
community a highly targeted community
that has a higher possibility of buying
your products and services
next we have facebook groups
with facebook groups you can build a
community of like individuals some of
the advantages that come with this are
it provides a highly targeted audience i
mentioned earlier that business pages
provide you with a highly targeted
audience
groups take that to the next level it
enables everyone to learn from one
another
with a large community there's a good
chance that some members know things
that others don't
your group will enable them to
communicate with each other and learn
these new things
you also get honest feedback
your customers who are also likely part
of the group will be able to give their
feedback on how they like your product
and perhaps even give you tips on how to
improve now since your group is filled
with a community that's highly
interested in your brand you can also
increase engagement in an organic manner
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get more leads and
conversions
next facebook has events with facebook
events your organization will be able to
mobilize your brand and enable online
consumer marketing basically meaning
that you have a platform for letting
people know about important
announcements not to mention there's
also the opportunity
to get some free advertising done events
also help you increase brand awareness
most people get to know about your brand
by attending the event or just seeing
the promotion for it now let's have a
look at facebook stories for groups and
pages a feature that is available for
both groups and pages it provides you
the ability to appropriately represent
your brand or business directly from
your mobile device or desktop
now some of its advantages
are that it helps you engage with your
audience with stuff other than the
usuals like articles videos and other
similar posts
this way you can also vary the kind of
content that you post
moreover stories can help you humanize
your brand
rather than seeming like you're
pandering to your audience or seeing
them only as potential leads or
customers
stories help your brand show that you're
genuinely interested in your audience
you can also reach your appropriate
audience with greater frequency
next facebook has facebook messenger
with messenger you can connect and
interact with your audience at a
personal level
in the last few years messenger has
proved itself to be a great marketing
tool it helps acquire more customers now
people are more loyal to a brand that
generally cares about them and by
directly interacting with them through
messenger their loyalty towards you is
certainly said to improve
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get a greater number of
transaction
and even if a customer doesn't give you
a transaction at least you're increasing
your brand awareness
then we have facebook live
facebook live gives you a platform to
interact with your audience in real time
it can be used to diversify your content
providing your audience with something
different from what they've received
from your brand initially
live can also be used to show what
happens behind the scenes in your
organization
further helping humanize your brand
and finally you can also provide instant
questions and answers to your audience
increasing engagement with them
next we have the facebook shop
the facebook shop is a business page tab
application that enables your customers
to purchase your products directly from
your store
it also has the following advantages
firstly you can use the shop to drive
new sales you can give the customers who
are on the fence about your product a
small push by engaging them and how can
you do that with deals and promotions
you can also reward advocates of your
brand with special benefits to be
availed from your store
and finally you can build brand
awareness and recognition
now let's have a look at facebook ads
facebook ads help spread product or
brand awareness in the news feed of a
specific targeted audience on facebook
now some of the advantages of facebook
ads are that they help increase brand
awareness
they enable you to advertise your
products and services to the appropriate
audience
and it provides you with greater reach
while making you spend lesser amounts of
money it also helps you re-advertise or
re-target your products to an existing
audience and finally it helps increase
revenue sales and leads
if you guys are interested in learning
about facebook ads you can check out our
facebook ads video i'll add it in the
live chat so you can check it out if
you're interested
now let's have a look at the final
feature facebook offers to help you with
marketing
facebook insights i'm sure all of you
have heard about google analytics
let's just say this is facebook's
version of that with insights you get
information that can help you refine
your brand strategy by tracking and
measuring results
it can help you determine reach and
engagement
actions people who are viewing your
posts when your fans are online the type
of posts that are working for you and
much much more
that brings us to the end of the ways
facebook helps you with marketing
now let's move on to instagram
first off we have instagram business
accounts
instagram business accounts enable
brands to be recognized as businesses
now it also has the following benefits
to offer
it's only with the business account that
you can get instagram insights we'll
talk about insights in a little more
detail in a little bit
you can also add a contact button on
your profile
enabling users to connect with you
directly
you can also specify what kind of
service you offer
by adding what industry you belong to in
your bio and finally you also have the
ability to add links to your instagram
stories now i'm sure you've all seen the
see more option in your stories so now
you know how that shows up
now if you guys are interested in
finding out how you can increase
followers on instagram you can check out
our video on the same topic of the same
name i'll add the link in the live chat
next let's talk about instagram stories
with instagram stories you have the
ability to grow engagement
build brand awareness and to drive sales
you can also use stories to provide
recent updates about your brand
now some of the advantages of instagram
stories are that they help businesses
grow their audience and can enable them
to engage with their audience regularly
with stories you can also drive traffic
to other websites like your company's
website it can also help diversify your
content setting it apart from the usual
videos and photos
next up let's talk about instagram dms
or direct messages
dms help you grow your business by
interacting with customers at a personal
level it can also help build connections
with your users by building a personal
connection with your followers
their loyalty towards your brand is
improved
not only that it helps you make or grow
your connections within the industry
and as an extension of the last few
points this leads to easier lead
generation and increased sales
next up we have igtv
now ittb is a platform that's gotten
really famous recently it enables your
brand to get closer to its audience and
enables it to be discovered by new
people
other benefits include greater
visibility of your products and services
having the ability to educate and
entertain your audience improved
engagement and greater chances of
conversions
finally it also helps build a community
of a highly targeted audience
next we have instagram live
instagram live enables you to
communicate with your audience in real
time
further improving your discoverability
and strengthening your connection with
the audience
moreover it provides a lot of visibility
your followers are immediately notified
when you go on live stream
and finally it helps you interact with
your audience in real time
this helps further humanize your brand
next we have instagram ads
instagram ads provides you with control
over advertisements
you decide how they appear and who sees
them like facebook instagram has a
number of different ad types to offer
they are photo ads video ads carousel
ads slideshow ads and stories ads
next up instagram offers an instagram
shop
the shop helps you incorporate your
product catalog with your instagram
profile
at some points even enabling users to
access the shop directly from an image
showing the same product
one of the major advantages of the
instagram shop is that it provides easy
product discoverability
and since it provides visual marketing
it also leads to more sales
and finally instagram insights
instagram's answer to facebook insights
and google analytics
insights is an analytical tool that
provides data on follower demographics
their actions and your brand content
it helps determine engagement
impressions and reach
best and worst performing content
profile visits website clicks and much
more
instagram is one of the fastest growing
social media networks
its appealing format and functionality
have driven people and businesses away
from traditional networks like facebook
video content is the most popular
content type on instagram so it's
obvious that we need to dedicate one
lesson to how to create optimize and
promote your video posts on instagram we
will start this lesson with showing you
how to make great instagram videos and
talk about the different types of videos
for instagram and we will then demo you
how to use the various video capturing
and editing tools you will find in the
instagram app we will close this lesson
with how businesses can use instagram
and how you can make money with it
instagram has extensive features to
create and promote videos
particularly with the growing appetite
in using instagram stories video is the
most important content form on instagram
it is important though to make sure that
before you start creating your video you
have a good idea of what you want to
achieve with it
is it to create awareness to generate
leads or are you answering questions
that clients may have
utilize the video editing features that
instagram has or use some external apps
if you want to go beyond what instagram
has to offer
there are enough tools for you to make
your instagram video a visual feast as
you can only create that on instagram
shooting and editing a great video
video is now the most shared content
type on instagram where in the early
days instagram video was only 15 seconds
long
nowadays you can upload 60 second videos
and turn multiple videos from your
camera roll into one video clip and
today instagram has lots of different
options within the app to create videos
and optimize them for the news feed or
for stories
recently instagram announced igtv
they're trying to take on youtube with a
dedicated video sharing app for vertical
and landscape videos with a maximum
length of 60 minutes for verified
accounts or accounts with a large
audience however anyone using the app
will be able to upload up to 10 minutes
of content to the platform
all in all instagram today is a
fantastic network for brands to build
brand awareness and to showcase their
products or services
to shoot great videos for instagram you
need to be aware of a few things
first of all you need to shoot the video
for instagram and instagram has its own
video formats video for the newsfeed
tend to be square whereas video for the
stories must be vertical
the aspect ratio for vertical videos is
9 by 16 which gives you a perfect 90
degrees flip for normal widescreen video
it's also better to use your phone's
native camera this will give you better
control over exposure and focus
instagram will allow you to upload
multiple clips and then edit them within
the instagram app
also think about short form versus long
form videos
stories are good for short clips whereas
igtv lends itself for longer videos
short videos are great for explaining
things that can be chopped up in steps
like recipes or how-to videos
long videos are good for brand
experiences and interviews
additionally it goes without saying you
always need to think about what you want
to achieve with your video
what's your end goal do you want new
followers do you want to get into
engagement with your followers
or do you want to drive traffic to your
website
all questions you need to think about
before you start shooting your video
video editing in external apps
once you have shot your video you can do
some basic editing within the instagram
app
you can also edit your video outside
instagram
the best environment for editing your
video is on your desktop computer
apps like adobe premiere from microsoft
or imovie from apple will give you an
extensive range of video and audio
editing options
you can then save the edited file and
move it to your phone via google drive
for instance
after which you can import the video
file into instagram
there are also many video editing apps
for your mobile they won't give you as
many features as to desktop video
editing but they come a long way
one of my favorite apps is video show
what i like about video show is that it
has a wide range of templates you can
use as a format for your edited video it
also comes with an extensive song and
music library
video categories
so what type of video would work best on
instagram
instagram lends itself for what we call
snackable videos a snackable video is
short compelling and entertaining and
they are designed to drive the viewer to
some sort of action like driving them to
a landing page or to a fill-in form
here are some examples of topics for
your next instagram video
it can feature your product features to
show your followers what products you
carry and why those products are unique
you can show your product in action
this is great for breaking up the
monotony of staged product features
you can also give a sneak preview in
these type of videos you announce news
with a teaser which gives your followers
a sneak peek of what is to come
behind the scene videos work very well
on instagram they are great for building
a more personal relationship with your
audience think of office tours staff
introductions a day in the life of
tutorials will show your fans how to use
your product
and finally video series
they are great for building a community
and for engaging with them
once your community has seen an episode
and they like it they may want to come
back for more
video types
besides different topics for your videos
you can also think about different
formats for your videos
looping videos can be created within the
instagram app
looping videos start automatically from
the beginning after the clip finishes
they can be very creative
and work well to showcase movable
product features
stop motion video is an animation that
is captured one frame at a time with
physical objects that are moved between
frames when you play back the sequence
of images rapidly it creates the
illusion of movement
both ios and android have lots of apps
to create stop-motion video
in a time-lapse video you capture lots
of photos of a scene over a period of
time
these images are then put together to
create a seamless sped up video
time-lapse videos work very well to show
how something is built or made and
finally hyperlapse videos
these are videos that allow you to
squeeze several minutes of film into the
one minute maximum set by instagram
they are a bit like time lapse videos
but the camera is moving
these videos are great to show behind
the scene footage
how to use instagram video options
there are various ways that you can make
a video on instagram so let me show you
how to do that if you go to the
instagram app it takes you to the news
feed where you can browse
to make a quick video you just click on
the plus button and that takes you to
this shot of my phone for instance you
need to make sure you activate video
if you click on the button you can then
make your video
you click again to stop recording and
your video is ready
you can now play the video and if you
are happy with it you click next and
then you can add a filter if you want to
i will come back to filters and editing
later then you just click next write a
caption tag people add a location
and share it your video is now posted on
instagram
this is the simple way there's also a
more advanced way of making your video
so let me discard this video go back to
the news feed we're now in the news feed
the creative way to create a video is go
to your instagram stories
to access your instagram stories you can
swipe to the right or you can also click
on the little camera on the top left of
your screen that takes you to the same
video screen
and now you see that you have more
options you can see that here at the
bottom
you can do live video you can do normal
video you can select boomerang video you
can do super zoom you can focus on your
video rewind your video and record
hands-free
so let me explain these in a bit more
detail for normal video you just click
on the video button and then you can see
that it's recording and when you're
ready with the recording then you let go
of the button
and what you see now is that you have
some extra options at the top where you
can add effects stickers drawings or
text
so this is the simple way of making a
video with added effects
you can also go for live video and this
is just like facebook live
when you click on go live then instagram
will announce it to your followers and
then you can start your live broadcast
when you're ready with your live
broadcast instagram will ask you if you
want to post it on your stories or in
your news feed and then you're done with
your broadcast
a very creative way of making videos is
using boomerang
boomerang was a separate app which
became very popular it was then acquired
by instagram
a boomerang video is a video that
repeats itself
if i click on boomerang i'm going to get
the phone and i will turn it
then when you look at the video i
created you see how the video repeats
itself all the time
you can do a lot of creative things with
the boomerang effect you can make people
move back and forwards you can make
objects move up and down and then post
them as short repeating videos
you also see that you can change the
camera into selfie mode and you can add
some special overlay effects as well
so there's different filters i quickly
scan through those
when you're in selfie mode you can have
funny face alterations as well
so lots of different effects that you
can create here
so now let's look at the super zoom
video
the super zoom is a bit like paparazzi
video also with different effects that
you can add to it so for instance i want
hearts on this video click on it and
then it will zoom in and you will see
hearts popping down
and here is the stamp effect click on it
and there you go
when i do a focus video it makes the
background blurred
with rewind video you can make the video
playback by itself
and then finally there's the hands-free
video
if you click on hands-free you don't
have to keep on pressing the record
button so you have more freedom in
camera movement when you choose this
option
so these are the different types of
video that you can make on instagram
how to use instagram video options and
filters
to show you how the effects work on
instagram i can go to instagram and then
into the story creation mode and here i
can just make a normal video
i can pan and move the video around a
bit
so the video is ready now and here i am
in the screen where i have the different
options to add creative effects to my
video so this is what i can do
first i can download the video on my
phone by clicking the downward arrow
i can then get different effects i can
add stickers i can play without sound i
can draw on the screen and i can add
text there are many different options
and when you click on the effect button
at the bottom you see the effects that
you can add to your video
there are effects that can be added when
there is a face on the screen but there
are also effects that can be added as an
overlay over the video
we can also add stickers like a location
sticker and a mention or a hashtag
sticker
interesting thing about these text type
stickers is that when you add these
instagram will actually understand the
text and will add them to the index for
search
you can easily move the stickers over
the screen you can add a time or a date
and you can also add quizzes so you can
ask a question for instance do you like
this
and then people can actually answer by
dragging the slider
you can do a poll and there's a whole
range of other stickers that you can add
to your video
you can draw as well you can have a thin
line or a thick line you can change the
color you can do special effects and you
can erase as well so you can do many
different effects with this you could
create an effect where you wipe out the
whole screen and then with the eraser
you can reveal sections of the video you
can get text and then when you're done
with it you can add a video to your
stories or save them as highlights on
your profile page or you can share it on
your news feed
monetizing your instagram videos
there are many different ways to make
money with instagram
you can make money as an influencer by
creating sponsored video posts
these are videos where you promote a
product from a brand
and the brand will reward you for giving
them access to your followers
tab influence is an excellent app to
connect brands with influencers you can
also sell your videos instagram is a
great place to showcase your content
2020 is an excellent website where you
can promote and sell your video content
and of course there is affiliate
marketing where you can promote your
products from your affiliate partners
and get a commission on each sale
sharesale is a website where you can
search for potential affiliate partners
or why not sell your instagram account
if you no longer want to manage it
famesweb is the place where you can do
this
finally instagram can also help you
indirectly to make money you could use
it to promote your youtube channel and
as we have learned in this course there
are many ways of making money through
youtube
takumi is one of the leading online
platforms where small influencers can
get connected with big global brands
when you have more than 1 000 followers
and you have good content you will be
able to use this network to identify
brands to work with
here are the takeaways of this lesson
video has become the top content type
shared on instagram
and today instagram has a whole range of
options to create and optimize your
videos for the news feed and for the
stories
short videos of maximum 60 seconds are
best for
instagram instagram uses looping videos
they start automatically from the
beginning after the clip finishes
use looping videos to showcase a fun or
versatile product feature
instagram has many different video
styles in the stories camera and once
you've shot your story video you have
plenty of options to customize them
takumi is an online platform where micro
influencers can connect with big global
brands to sell their original content
greetings everyone this is rob sanders
and welcome to this simply learn webinar
today we're going to talk about how to
increase instagram followers today's
webinar we're gonna have some tips and
and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about instagram so
instagram is not really an up-and-coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active instagram users 500 million daily
the user base growth of more than 300
year-over-year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular ever since it's launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the advent of mobile
technology that the instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photo so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's a
hundred million photos plus uploaded
daily and then there are 400 million
stories posted daily so when you post
something you can create a story out of
it and there's 400 million of those per
day and then there's more than 50
billion photos shared to date so since
2010 platform nat which is now owned by
facebook has become really really
popular
a good place for you if you have your
own company if you have your own brand
if you have your own product it's a good
place for you to really showcase that
service that product that brand because
of the user base how easy it is to use
and the wide reach it has for you in
which to tell your story so i mentioned
there are lots of photos shared today
close to seven billion dollars revenue
generated through instagram mobile so on
top of everything i just said there's a
lot of e-commerce going on here too so
instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform so as a business who offers up
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
instagram which is owned by facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
on instagram so instagram is an
e-commerce platform to say the least in
fact instagram is because it's so
popular because it's part of facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're gonna see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
going to go through some tips and tricks
today and we're going to talk about
everything there is to know about
instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if i go to my instagram account for
example using my desktop i could see my
profile and i can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear and
concise and compelling bio why because
this is your introduction to the world
you want people to know who you are and
because if you don't really become very
clear to people they're not gonna follow
you so this is where it all starts you
need to take advantage of your bio have
a clear and concise bio and have a link
to your website or some contact
information so to me this is where it
all starts you gotta have a bio because
that's what people are gonna look at and
they're gonna decide whether to follow
you or not based on primarily that bio
that's where it all starts so make sure
you have a good bio that's tip number
one so you'll have to make sure that
your landing page is also mobile
optimized since most instagram users are
on mobile so if you're going to put a
link to your website and somebody's on
the instagram app and they see your bio
and they like it and you have a link to
your website make sure that lanny page
they go to is mobile optimized so tip
number two everything you do on
instagram when it comes to posting
evolves around hashtags so that's the
backbone of the platform just like most
platforms out there social media
platforms like twitter or facebook
pinterest you're gonna have hashtags
accompany those posts so instagram is no
different but in this case you really
really want to take advantage of the
hashtag so hashtags are there to help
users find your content so you want to
start out by using hashtags that are
relevant to your business so if you're
in the food industry you're going to
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
are being searched on instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested followers and
sales so here really what i'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's gonna follow
you or that doesn't mean really mean
somebody's going to be interested in
what you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post is between 2 and 3 p.m and the best
day to post is thursday now that may be
all fine and true according to a sprout
social study and so you may want to go
with this 2 to 3 p.m and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone we're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try 2 to 3 p.m on thursday
the thing is what you're gonna have to
do eventually is figure out what the
best time to post is okay so if you're
pointing out a lot of content and you're
putting out content throughout the week
at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're gonna really have to lean
on a social media platform to help you
determine that because they're gonna
have the data that you need to determine
what the best time of day to post is
okay so we'll talk about social media
platforms here shortly we just know that
when you post post with some rationale
in mind ask yourself before you even
push that publish button or before you
even schedule that post this time of day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with
some platform and instagram also has
some analytics for business accounts so
instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitors brand then what the chance
of them like in your brand could be
great so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted engage with them okay it doesn't
take that much time it's a good way to
gain followers so if we're on instagram
we can simply just click on the brand's
followers so here i can see this brand
has 127 followers and here i can see all
the followers and what i could do is
simply just click on one of the
followers and i can go to their profile
and from there i could see what they've
posted in terms of videos and images and
i can like or comment so just doing
something as simple as this
gets you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip five pay for sponsored
posts and product reviews so a number of
ways you could do this here so pay for a
sponsored post so you could find an
influencer satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them and ask them
for sponsored post pricing so it's as
simple as that as reaching out to
somebody who has a large following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
you in front of a large number of people
and so by doing this it'll help expose
your brand to that larger audience and
help build your credibility because
you're connecting with somebody who has
a large audience as well so do a little
bit of homework find people out there in
your industry who has a large following
and make sure they have that email
address in their profile so you can
contact them and when you contact them
you know ask them for sponsored post
pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shadow so that's the
key so they got to have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location city or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you tip 7 use
instagram stories to attract followers
and grow your user base so stories a
really big feature on instagram so what
stories could be used for is just show
footage of an environment so it could be
your office it could be your home it
could be you know the playground it
could be the golf course it could be
anywhere that you want to show vintage
of so you want to post new
relevant to your industry so if you're
in the food industry hey why not go in
the back into the kitchen and post a
story about how a particular bread or
cake is made okay show off your product
so if you are in that food industry and
say you're in the pizza making business
perfect opportunity to show people via
an instagram story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a youtube
video or you can create an instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog post you can
post positive user reviews so these are
all features of a story increase
interactivity with polls sliders etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
instagram stories is a really big
feature with instagram check it out you
know you can just do a search for
instagram stories in fact let's get some
of you users involved what best
practices do you have when creating
instagram stories why don't you go ahead
and share your instagram story with us
by putting that instagram story in the
comment section below so we want to get
everybody involved here because there's
thousands upon thousands of great
instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back of your
mind you know for me i always go back to
what industry are you in if you're in
the food industry hey you know people
who are following you or interested in
food if you're a pizza company you know
show off that pizza if you're a bakery
show off how you make your breads and
goods baked goods whatever it is you
have show it off because if somebody's
following you that's what they're
interested in so tip number eight
highlight important stories so you want
to highlight highlight serve as the
easiest way to create a first impression
for a potential follower so with
highlights can be used to tease what
your contents about create a trailer for
what your brand offers promote and
promote your product highlights are
there it's a good feature it's a first
impression for potential followers so it
teases what the contents about it
creates a trailer so to speak for your
brand and promote your product so use
highlights and again any users out there
who have good examples of highlights go
ahead and put those in the content
section or comment section uh right
below this video so remember stories
have only a 24 hour life span so
highlights can be used to give them a
second wind okay so highlights serve a
purpose it teases what the contents
about it promotes the product and it
really kind of accentuates that story
tip number nine ask for followers so
sometimes people need a little push
before they can follow you on instagram
even if they enjoy your content so you
can ask users to become your followers
in the caption the comment section or
even work it into your content so in
other words when you're posting
something don't be afraid to say hey
follow me you know i got some good stuff
here be confident you don't want to do
it for every post of course but you know
pick and choose if you feel you have a
really good post you know really good
image that you think is going to gain a
lot of followers and engagers then you
don't necessarily need to put a caption
in there but if if it is popular then go
ahead and say hey this is a popular post
you know think about following me or put
something in the comment section you
want to do it kind of succinctly you
don't want to be begging but just work
it in to some degree okay but don't be
afraid have some confidence and asking
for followers so when you do this it's
very similar to how we do it on youtube
so you can ask viewers to subscribe to
their channels at the end of the video
so it's if on youtube basically you're
saying hey if you like what we have go
ahead and subscribe it's no different on
instagram if you have something you've
posted just go and say hey you like this
yeah go ahead and follow us it's that
simple so tip number 10 take on the
latest trends to get more followers so
align your content to cater to trendy
topics or hashtags to improve engagement
and discoverability so really what we're
trying to say here is your competitors
follow influencers what are the latest
trends and you can get an idea of the
latest trends by you looking at hashtags
so what hashtags are trending which ones
are people using the most so really what
you want to do is whatever's trending in
your industry you know ride that wave so
to speak now it doesn't have to take on
your entire profile but there's nothing
wrong with one or two posts if
something's really taking on popularity
then go ahead and post about it as well
you know for example in the wine
industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really gaining
some popularity go ahead and post about
it with the same hashtag and with the
unique hashtag so don't be afraid to
you know ride the wave of popularity so
to speak because it shows that you know
you know what you're talking about it
adds some credibility and it's going to
get some you know viewers over to your
instagram profile so keep in mind you
need to keep your content relevant
because if your audience is interested
in what you have to offer then they're
going to be engaged however you know if
you're joining the discussion in a
relevant manner keeping in mind whether
your audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
youtube just like on facebook i mean
instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
what's an idea of a contest well again
if you're running a pizza parlor you
know you could say hey what's your
favorite pizza or give me your favorite
pizza ideas and you can run a contest
and you know you can have people even
create their own pizza and post an image
of it you can have people create stories
on the best ways in which they create
pizza or their experience in another
pizza parlor there's lots of things you
can do to create a contest and you don't
always have to give something away you
can just do something for fun especially
if you have a lot of followers if you
have a lot of followers and somebody's
going to take part in it so don't be
afraid to run contests just to make it
fun and light it up a little bit so each
tag could bring you a new audience
member who could be a potential follower
so anytime you run a contest people are
gonna tag their friends to let them know
about that contest so those friends are
going to come over and likely engage so
that's the beauty of running a contest
or giveaway is chances are word's going
to spread and it's going to get you some
new followers so that's the the end
benefits so to speak but the real
benefit is keeping your audience engaged
so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with posts so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consistent you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within pizza you could branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complementary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we want to
stay consistent with your theme this
method involves less effort with a
faster production of instagram content
so that mean what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's going to muddy
the water suppose so to speak and you're
probably going to get less engagement so
set a theme on instagram by maintaining
consistency and your personality filters
colors and layout and really what i'm
referring to is post and when you have
post something you're you're really
creating a personality for yourself okay
so if you're in fashion for example and
you're in the jeans industry well jeans
jeans jeans right that's your
personality accentuate it with different
outfits related to jeans but you know
when you start talking about dresses and
shoes and and that kind of blurs your
your personality a bit so if you stay
consistent with thin jeans and outfits
that go with jeans then i think people
are going to start to pick up on that
personality so tip 13 keep track of your
instagram following so you can analyze
the growth of your channel with tools
like socialblade that could tell you how
many followers you've lost over time and
how engaged they are okay so you can use
data gather from here and from instagram
business account to diagnose where
you're faltering so let's take a look at
socialblade as an example here so if i
go over here i'm gonna go to socialblade
here i can enter in basically any
account after a register and i could see
how that account has performed you know
where they rank you know how many
uploads they have what country they
focused on what industry and the beauty
here is i could see and i'm looking at
youtube as an example i could see you
know how my post to perform well you
could do this for instagram you could do
it for facebook so you can really get an
idea of
how your account's performing so
socialblade's a great platform for
measuring and again you do also have
instagram business insights so with
instagram business insights basically
what you're gonna do is you're gonna go
to your app right and then from the app
you could basically look at your
insights from there so in the app itself
you're gonna click on the upper right
three lines and from there you're gonna
see insights and when you go to insights
you're also going to see you know what
your reach is how many impressions and
some engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're going to also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns in post what posts
receive the most amount of engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use instagram ads so instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mention this on other webinars for
facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if i go back into say
facebook ads manager i can pick and
choose my placements and really what i
want to do is pick and choose for
example instagram and so i have
instagram feed i have instagram stories
so and i could see what the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on instagram so with
instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
carousel so really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you you know what your audience
size is your potential reach okay what
your daily results would be so you're
gonna get all that information when you
run your ads on facebook ads manager but
it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting units you need
meaning you know who saw the ad do they
click on it okay you can refine that
target audience you can go back into
facebook ads manager and refine who your
audience is so lots of flexibility here
and advertising on instagram but the key
here is if you want to run advertising
on instagram you know think about what
it is you're trying to promote if you
feel something needs to get promoted
then go ahead and you know you can
either again reach out to somebody and
have them sponsor it or you can run it
as an advertisement so let's move on to
tip 15. so we want to create visually
attractive and eye-catching ads so if
you are gonna run ads you know here's
some things to keep in mind okay you
want to use images that are natural and
seem native okay you don't want to use
any stock photography first off you want
to use something that you've done okay
you want to minimize the amount of text
so let the image do the talking you want
to ensure your caption relates to the
image and resonates with your audience
okay so you have an opportunity to add
some text below the image okay so make
sure it resonates and then of course use
hashtags to show your ads to target your
audience but a wider relevant audience
so hashtags do play a role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create ads you want to take these
into account the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to either web page
or to your profile page okay so that
they can engage and take action so
instagram ads will help showcase your
product service or brand in a way that's
memorable and unique so if you really
want to get your vision your brand your
product out there in front of a lot of
people then advertising on instagram is
a good way to do that so since we've
been talking about pizza throughout this
webinar there's a good instagram a
profile here about pizza you know i'm
getting hungry just looking at this
hopefully this is an example for all veg
and non-veg pizza consumers i mean you
can see this profile here they got the
website you know they got the handle
okay so they have a lot of followers so
you know if i'm in the pizza industry i
can go ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who who's following
them who they're following so
some really good shots of pizza here it
looks like you know a lot of people were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo
so
here you know you could say use daily
pizza as a hashtag for feature okay so
they're even encouraging you to use a
specific hashtag so you can really do a
lot here on instagram this is just a
good example of what you can do and have
fun with you know with an example like
pizza just to give you some ideas so
let's move on to tip 16. take advantage
of instagram tools so you can use
scheduling tools like later hootsuite
and buffer so i can't stress this enough
you know when it comes to
measuring the engagement of your
instagram post you're definitely going
to need a social media tool so you're
also going to need it if you do a lot of
you know posting on instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com so if i go to later here i can
see you know i can use this to upload my
images to my profile so here you can see
it's scheduled throughout the day of the
week so that way we're not overlapping
you know we're scheduling based on the
times of the day that people are going
to look at this so
you know here i could see you know
particular stories if any stories are
posted okay i can look at it from a
weekly or monthly preview i could see
what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool i can
also see the analytics i could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing i want to be able to see what
posts perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again i can look at it by
post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags that this become a
particular company is using on instagram
so here you can see how many posts with
this hashtag you know and what and kind
of engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job i like this
platform especially for instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from best practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown here and later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay enabling you to
automatically post at a scheduled time
so you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and i have to worry about
it so it allows you to really hone in on
that particular time of the day and day
of the week so that you're really
maximizing your chances of getting good
engagement okay so develop your own
signature styles to set up a style and
content theme so that you're able to
stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza and but this is their
style this is who they are you know
they're not a particular brand they're
just you know people who like pizza okay
and they're having fun with it okay so
that's their style you know they're
posting really good shots of all these
different types of pizza different
styles different toppings and just to
give you an idea of how popular pizza is
and what you can do with it okay so
again this is a good basic example um of
what you can do
with something as simple as pizza so
don't be afraid to experiment you know
try something different with your
profile you know do something different
you don't always have to follow what
everybody else is doing that's the great
thing about instagram it allows you to
be free and creative in fact if anybody
has any styles that have worked for them
you know feel free to put something in
the comment section we'd love to hear
your thoughts so tip 18 use user
engagement to your advantage so i just
mentioned that using the later example
so we want to be able to
learn from what's working and not
working so user-generated content shows
off your brand to be authentic and
improves your relationship with your
followers so you know you want to be
unique with the content that you're
posting so
if you do that you're likely to build
that relationship and you know increase
your followers and you want to be able
to see of that user generated content
that ugc which is performing which is
not performing okay so basically your
followers and your audience are telling
you what's working and not working so
take advantage of that remember going
back to hashtags you could set up your
own unique hashtag and ask your users to
post images or videos relating to that
which you can post in your brand's
account so just like the whole pizza
thing they're saying hey look you know
use daily pizza for a feature okay
that's a good example of something you
can do as well so you could set up a
unique hashtag and say hey use this
hashtag and that'll help you gain some
followers that'll help you gain some
notoriety and some visibility on your
platform tip 19 use high quality images
and videos just like on youtube just
like on facebook instagram is no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original i mean again one
more time go back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality i
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational without causing
the user to lose interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know make you can make
it short make it fun okay you can see
here these guys are just showing you how
pizza is made doesn't take a long time
they're just going through the motions
they're not boring you with details
they're not talking really quick and
easy just to give you an idea it doesn't
have to be as serious it can be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you could do that you're likely gonna
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your instagram page and other
social media channels so facebook and
instagram are part of the same family so
this seems like a natural but you know
don't be afraid to
promote it on other channels like
pinterest or or youtube the whole idea
is to get users to your instagram page
and encourage them to follow it so you
know you can always put that url in you
know other platforms like youtube
nothing wrong with that at all okay you
can also promote your page offline with
print ads and during other relevant
events and then i would even take this
to further is you probably see you know
an instagram
logo on a web page along with other
social media icons so you always want to
help promote instagram on your web page
as well but you can do it for offline
with print ads so you can simply just
put you know whatever your your slug is
for instagram whatever your id is
whatever you're using on instagram
that's what you can use don't be afraid
to promote it offline or online
instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction with nearly 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily active users instagram is
a platform drive with marketing
potential
more than seven billion dollars revenue
has been generated from instagram mobile
and it's home to more than two million
advertisers
not only that marketing on instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to instagram's
parent company facebook instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by facebook ads with
this you can advertise to people based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them
you'll also get a greater understanding
of what your followers like and dislike
based on their engagement this enables
you to make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
your bio should also include a url to
where you want to drive traffic to be it
your brand's website or a page for a
particular product make sure to track
this link as well to see how much
traffic it brings
here's an example of how samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number 2 we have create a
content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
content calendar
a content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts it'll help you plan
ahead and automate the process of
publishing your posts when your audience
is most active
a calendar helps you decide what content
caption hashtags videos goes live on
what day date or time a consistent post
schedule will enable you to make the
most out of instagram it'll also keep
your audience engaged and also give you
access to historical posts if you want
to repost your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you'll need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
facebook like audience segmentation
based on likes interactions buying
habits and more
you also have a variety of ad formats to
choose from like story ads image ads
video ads collection ads and more
moreover they can also be set up from
facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from body
shop in which they're using a single
image ad the advertising works because
of its interesting creative and
attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link
let's go to number four have a visually
consistent feed
instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
to authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted earthly tones
with a low key editing style
your content must feel down to earth and
your brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have aesthetically pleasing images and a
somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell
now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them
this makes it more likely that they feel
closer to your brand and by your
products
your captions can tell stories that can
help your brand appear more human and
build deeper connections with your
audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
patagonia talks about forests in america
each of their posts tell stories about a
different issue that affects nature
their brand on instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such issues
that's the kind of stories you should
tell with your brand
next up number six
use the right hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your post showing up
on the explore tab for everyone to see
and it getting lost in the sea of
content
your hashtags shouldn't be too generic
like new year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way
let's now go to number seven take
advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc also by them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to ugc can
be used to convert followers into
advocates of your brand
here's an example of how starbucks uses
user-generated content and takes
advantages of their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stored at
starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
brand loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads
most instagramers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising video
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to instagram ads
single video ads that can create 60
second ads corrosions are a combination
of images and videos and instagram
stories that enable you to combine
images and videos to create visually
attractive ads
here's an example of the brand pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well short videos and captions
now for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how ralph lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products
the influencer showing off the latest
ralph lauren has to offer this
encourages his interested followers to
check out the page and buy something for
themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways
contests enable your audience to engage
with your brand with 3.5 times more
likes and 64 times the comments you can
give away a product or a service which
enables you to boost engagement and
brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned brands need to be partnered with
contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important
you would need to track your contest
performance and promote the results on
other social media platforms as well
here's an example of a contest run by
domino's pizza which encourages people
to contribute their own short stories
and connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic
adding links to the instagram stories
can also help with driving traffic to
your website
ittv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to the savvy
marketer
igtv provides you a unique mobile
friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews
another new tool they have introduced is
instagram reels instagram's answer to
tick tock
instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips and since it released very
recently it's rife with marketing
potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
styles and the best times to post
doing this you can develop the best
practices for your brand social
listening and analytics will help you
fine-tune your marketing strategy and
increase instagram engagement
now let's get started
first off let's have a look at an
introduction to facebook
facebook was first launched in february
2004 and was initially known as the
facebook
in 2005 it removed d from its name and
it has now become the facebook we all
know today
it is now the world's most popular
social media and social networking
service
next let's have a look at instagram
it was launched in 2010 for ios and then
in 2012 for android by kevin systrom and
mike krieger
instagram has now evolved to become one
of the fastest growing social media
platforms in the world
in april 2012 thanks to its popularity
it was acquired by facebook for
approximately one billion dollars in
cash in stock
now let's compare some stats between
facebook and instagram
first let's have a look at the worldwide
stats
first off facebook
like i mentioned earlier facebook is the
largest social media platform in the
world
reaching almost 60.6 of the internet it
has 2.5 billion monthly active users and
approximately 1.6 billion active users
in fact as of jan 2020 the us has
approximately 190 million
and india has approximately 280 million
facebook users
an indication of a market that's still
ripe for the picking
now let's have a look at instagram
instagram although having released
significantly later earns its title of
the fastest growing social media
platform with 1 billion monthly active
users and 500 million daily users
in the united states there are
approximately 120 million and india has
close to 88 million instagram users
next up let's have a look at the next
statistic
age group of the user base
first off facebook
although there's a general opinion among
the younger population that facebook
isn't hip or isn't used all that much
anymore
this statistic has something different
to say
turns out more than 65 percent of
facebook users are between the ages of
25 and 34.
for instagram it's no surprise that 71
percent of the user base are under the
age of 35.
next let's compare the usage time of
both these platforms
let's take facebook first
in the united states users spend
approximately one hour on facebook every
day
in india users spend an average of three
hours a day on facebook
shockingly high numbers for a platform
that's assumed to be dead isn't it
on the other hand in the united states
users spend 23 minutes on average on
instagram
in india users spend approximately 45
minutes
now for the most important stat
marketing
for facebook 86 percent of marketers use
it for advertising
instagram is used by 71 percent of
businesses for their marketing
requirements
now let's have a look at some industries
that can work well on both these
platforms
if you do belong to any of these
industries if you're not taking
advantage of these platforms you're
missing out
so let's have a look at some industries
that can capitalize on facebook
food and beverage companies news and
media
e-commerce
automobile
and package goods
next time you're on facebook take a
closer look at your feed there's a good
chance you'll see most of these
industries post on it
next up instagram we have industries
like fashion
athleisure cosmetics automobiles and
food and beverages
i can guarantee that if you take a
closer look you can find all these
industries advertising on instagram
now let's take a closer look at how
facebook can help with marketing
first off let's have a look at facebook
business pages
now these are basically platforms where
you can create an online presence for
your organization for free
moreover they've got some great
advantages to offer you as well
first off your business page can keep
your customers or potential customers
informed it can be about a new product
launch a webinar a live broadcast a new
store opening anything whatever it is it
can go on your facebook business page
it connects people with your products
and services with your page you get
greater visibility letting people know
about the products and services that you
offer you can offer customer service as
well in fact according to american
express 90 of users use customer service
as a deciding factor for whether or not
they continue to do business with an
organization
so customer service is pretty important
like i mentioned earlier your business
page provides a place where you can
offer your followers offers and other
advantages
and finally the page lets you build a
community
a highly targeted community that has a
higher possibility of buying your
products and services
next we have facebook groups
with facebook groups you can build a
community of liked individuals
some of the advantages that come with
this are
it provides a highly targeted audience i
mentioned earlier that business pages
provide you with a highly targeted
audience
groups take that to the next level it
enables everyone to learn from one
another
with a large community there's a good
chance that some members know things
that others don't
your group will enable them to
communicate with each other and learn
these new things
you also get honest feedback
your customers who are also likely part
of the group will be able to give their
feedback on how they like your product
and perhaps even give you tips on how to
improve now since your group is filled
with a community that's highly
interested in your brand you can also
increase engagement in an organic manner
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get more leads and
conversions
next facebook has events
with facebook events your organization
will be able to mobilize your brand and
enable online consumer marketing
basically meaning that you have a
platform for letting people know about
important announcements not to mention
there's also the opportunity to get some
free advertising done events also help
you increase brand awareness
most people get to know about your brand
by attending the event or just seeing
the promotion for it now let's have a
look at facebook stories for groups and
pages a feature that is available for
both groups and pages it provides you
the ability to appropriately represent
your brand or business directly from
your mobile device or desktop
now some of its advantages
are that it helps you engage with your
audience with stuff other than the
usuals like articles videos and other
similar posts
this way you can also vary the kind of
content that you post
moreover stories can help you humanize
your brand
rather than seeming like you're
pandering to your audience or seeing
them only as potential leads or
customers
stories help your brand show that you're
genuinely interested in your audience
you can also reach your appropriate
audience with greater frequency
next facebook has facebook messenger
with messenger you can connect and
interact with your audience at a
personal level
in the last few years messenger has
proved itself to be a great marketing
tool it helps acquire more customers now
people are more loyal to a brand that
generally cares about them and by
directly interacting with them through
messenger their loyalty towards you is
certainly said to improve
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get a greater number of
transaction
and even if a customer doesn't give you
a transaction at least you're increasing
your brand awareness
then we have facebook live
facebook live gives you a platform to
interact with your audience in real time
it can be used to diversify your content
providing your audience with something
different from what they've received
from your brand initially
live can also be used to show what
happens behind the scenes in your
organization
further helping humanize your brand
and finally you can also provide instant
questions and answers to your audience
increasing engagement with them
next we have the facebook shop
the facebook shop is a business page tab
application that enables your customers
to purchase your products directly from
your store
it also has the following advantages
firstly you can use the shop to drive
new sales you can give the customers who
are on the fence about your product a
small push by engaging them and how can
you do that with deals and promotions
you can also reward advocates of your
brand with special benefits to be
availed from your store
and finally you can build brand
awareness and recognition
now let's have a look at facebook ads
facebook ads help spread product or
brand awareness in the news feed of a
specific targeted audience on facebook
now some of the advantages of facebook
ads are that they help increase brand
awareness
they enable you to advertise your
products and services to the appropriate
audience
and it provides you with greater reach
while making you spend lesser amounts of
money it also helps you re-advertise or
re-target your products to an existing
audience
and finally it helps increase revenue
sales and leads
if you guys are interested in learning
about facebook ads you can check out our
facebook ads video i'll add it in the
live chat so you can check it out if
you're interested
now let's have a look at the final
feature facebook offers to help you with
marketing
facebook insights i'm sure all of you
have heard about google analytics
let's just say this is facebook's
version of that with insights you get
information that can help you refine
your brand strategy by tracking and
measuring results
it can help you determine reach and
engagement
actions people who are viewing your
posts when your fans are online the type
of posts that are working for you and
much much more
that brings us to the end of the ways
facebook helps you with marketing
now let's move on to instagram
first off we have instagram business
accounts
instagram business accounts enable
brands to be recognized as businesses
now it also has the following benefits
to offer
it's only with the business account that
you can get instagram insights we'll
talk about insights in a little more
detail in a little bit
you can also add a contact button on
your profile
enabling users to connect with you
directly
you can also specify what kind of
service you offer
by adding what industry you belong to in
your bio and finally you also have the
ability to add links to your instagram
stories now i'm sure you've all seen the
see more option in your stories so now
you know how that shows up
now if you guys are interested in
finding out how you can increase
followers on instagram you can check out
our video on the same topic of the same
name i'll add the link in the live chat
next let's talk about instagram stories
with instagram stories you have the
ability to grow engagement
build brand awareness and to drive sales
you can also use stories to provide
recent updates about your brand
now some of the advantages of instagram
stories are that they help businesses
grow their audience and can enable them
to engage with their audience regularly
with stories you can also drive traffic
to other websites like your company's
website it can also help diversify your
content setting it apart from the usual
videos and photos
next up let's talk about instagram dms
or direct messages
dms help you grow your business by
interacting with customers at a personal
level it can also help build connections
with your users by building a personal
connection with your followers
their loyalty towards your brand is
improved
not only that it helps you make or grow
your connections within the industry
and as an extension of the last few
points this leads to easier lead
generation and increase sales
next up we have igtv
now ittv is a platform that's gotten
really famous recently it enables your
brand to get closer to its audience and
enables it to be discovered by new
people
other benefits include greater
visibility of your products and services
having the ability to educate and
entertain your audience
improved engagement and greater chances
of conversions
finally it also helps build a community
of a highly targeted audience
next we have instagram live
instagram live enables you to
communicate with your audience in real
time
further improving your discoverability
and strengthening your connection with
the audience
moreover it provides a lot of visibility
your followers are immediately notified
when you go on live stream
and finally it helps you interact with
your audience in real time
this helps further humanize your brand
next we have instagram ads
instagram ads provides you with control
over advertisements
you decide how they appear and who sees
them like facebook instagram has a
number of different ad types to offer
they are photo ads video ads carousel
ads slideshow ads and stories ads
next up instagram offers an instagram
shop
the shop helps you incorporate your
product catalog with your instagram
profile
at some points even enabling users to
access the shop directly from an image
showing the same product
one of the major advantages of the
instagram shop is that it provides easy
product discoverability
and since it provides visual marketing
it also leads to more sales
and finally instagram insights
instagram's answer to facebook insights
and google analytics
insights is an analytical tool that
provides data on follower demographics
their actions and your brand content
it helps determine engagement
impressions and reach
best and worst performing content
profile visits website clicks and much
more
and there you go that's every way
facebook and instagram can help you with
marketing now we've laid out the facts
for you
keep in mind your requirements and make
a wise choice with that we have reached
the end of day six of our digital
marketing week i hope the past six days
were really interesting and informative
and helped you learn the leading digital
marketing skills if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video we'll be
happy to answer them thank you all for
watching this live session thanks again
and keep
learning hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you